Hallo und herzlich willkommen, wir sind's, die Freakshow, wir sind wieder da
und obwohl keiner danach gefragt hat.
Was? Fiel mir gerade so ein.
Das sind meine Spontanwitze. Weißt du, ich habe doch kein Konzept für den Beginn
der Freakshow. Alles andere ist total durchformatiert, aber hier, weiß ich auch nicht.
Wir sind wieder da.
Wir sind wieder da. Mehr kann man dazu erstmal noch nicht sagen.
Mal schauen, wie es am Ende der Sendung aussieht. Wir haben eine illustre Runde
mit bekannten Gesichtern.
Heute fange ich mal links an. Ralf.
Hallo.
Hallo. Frisch aus dem Arbeitsleben abgegriffen.
Müde, wie immer.
Das ist wirklich ein Drama. Der pfeift immer so aus dem letzten Loch.
Ja, und jetzt noch Freakshow und dann sterben.
Nächste Sendung, da bin ich bestimmt desmunter.
Mit Sicherheit. Mit Sicherheit. Na gut, und Roddy hat sich eingereiht,
frisch wieder reimportiert aus der Ukraine.
Aloha, ja, ich hatte auch schon Zeit, mich davon zu erholen,
aber sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich noch fertiger.
Ja, ich glaube, ich weiß, worauf du anspielst. Das werden wir natürlich heute diskutieren.
Und zugeschaltet aus dem schönen Bayern haben wir den Dom noch mit dabei.
Ja, hallo.
Hallo Dom.
Schön, dass es mal wieder geklappt hat.
Genau, hier auf unserem Präsenzbildschirm.
Ja, hoffentlich auch die ganze Dauer der Sendung über. Das hat das letzte Mal auch schon geklappt.
Ja, ich bin zuversichtlich, ich habe auch diverse Verbesserungen erzielt.
Es sollte jetzt auch nichts mehr brummen. Können wir mal kurz andächtig lauschen?
Nichts, oder? Kein Netzbrummen, gar nichts.
Super. Einmal mit Profis.
Stellt sich raus, wenn man nicht nur die Schirmung an Masse macht,
sondern auch noch die Buchse auch noch damit anschließt.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das vorher zehn Jahre mit meinem Yamaha-Mischpult nie
ein Thema war, weil da war ja nichts davon zu hören.
Aber der kleine Rodecaster, der jetzt hier übernommen hat, der ist da so ein bisschen zickig.
Der empfindliche kleine Racker.
Hat der ein Steckernetzteil?
Naja, da wird über USB-C versorgt, sagen wir es mal so.
Okay, das beantwortet die Frage eigentlich auch.
Warum? Wieso? Weshalb?
Na, der Yamaha wird wahrscheinlich eine ordentliche Netzbrummschirmung gehabt haben.
Während der, wenn der jetzt über USB-C, dann hängt der entweder an dem Mac oder
aber an einem Steckernetzteil.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht richtig brummgeschirmt.
Da würde man sich ja fragen.
Vielleicht nur zwei Pins oder so.
Du meinst, das eigentliche Problem ist das Netzteil?
Ja, ziemlich sicher. Also sagen wir mal so, ist ein kontributierender Faktor.
Aber dafür hat man ja die Schirmung, die man überall auf Masse legt,
damit du dann halt auch eine entsprechende gute Schirmung hast.
Wenn die natürlich nicht auf Masse liegt, dann schirmt die auch nicht richtig.
Genau. Und das wurde jetzt nachgeholt. Also hier wurde alles einmal ausgebohrt,
weil es hat mich einfach maßlos genervt und ich wusste nicht mehr so richtig weiter.
Und dann wurden die Dinger entnietet und mal nachgeschaut und festgestellt,
da könnte man nochmal ein Kabel ranlöten.
Gesagt, tun, getan.
Naja, ich meine, man merkt halt, wenn man eine Weile in einer Band gespielt
hat, wo man viele Kabel und viele Schirmungen und Brummprobleme hatte,
dass man dann einen gewissen Erfahrungshorizont aufbaut.
Du bist ja jetzt auch hier als Elektromeister bist du ja jetzt hier auch,
Okay.
Offiziell, sehr gut Du hast gesagt.
Du bist Elektromeister.
Also Malik hätte da zu dem Thema Brummen bei Bands bestimmt auch was zu sagen
aber der ist ja jetzt nicht hier Nee Brummen.
Achso Netzbrummen Ja,
Ja gut müssen wir halt damit klarkommen Dass.
Es jetzt nicht mehr.
Brummt, schlimm schlimm Ja, worüber sollt ihr euch denn dann noch beschweren?
Wenn alles funktioniert, das wäre keine gute Freakshow.
So, wir können mal mit ein paar Ankündigungen anfangen. Ich habe nämlich mitbekommen, dass der 38.
Chaos Communication Kongress angekündigt wurde.
Und da stellt man dann auch wieder fest, wird langsam Herbst.
Irgendwelche Gedanken, die euch dabei durch den Kopf gehen?
Das mit den Karten.
Das mit den Karten und ich war
schon länger nicht mehr Vielleicht wäre es dieses Jahr mal wieder dran Ja.
Same Ich muss da nicht mal wieder hin Naja.
Ich war das letzte Mal, wo ich nicht war, war 29C3 Insofern für mich ist das
sowieso eine Pflichtdauerveranstaltung,
Und das wird sich auch einrichten lassen, denke ich.
Also es ist wieder in Hamburg und findet statt und das mit den Tickets ist natürlich so eine Sache.
Ich fand das Motto sehr schön und zwar ist das Motto dieses Jahr Illegal Instructions.
Das finde ich passt sowohl in die Zeit als auch ins Schema und man fragt sich
fast, warum man da nicht früher drauf gekommen ist.
Aber es ist mal ein schönes Motto, bin ich komplett mit dabei.
Und ich hoffe, das wird dann auch grafisch schön umgesetzt. Aber da kann man,
glaube ich, so einiges bei rausholen.
Ja, andere Veranstaltung, die stattfindet, da muss ich jetzt nochmal für trommeln,
weil die ist nämlich jetzt bald, ist die Subscribe, die kleine Podcast-Konferenz hier in Berlin.
Und da geht es jetzt so ein bisschen in den Endspurt. Und wenn ihr noch nichts
davon gehört habt, dann habt ihr nicht Freakshow gehört.
Weil wir haben das ja schon mal erwähnt. Reif?
Ausführlich.
Ausführlich, genau. Und deswegen wollen wir das auch gar nicht alles nochmal erzählen.
Aber, falls unter euch Hörerinnen und Hörer noch interessierte Menschen sind,
die vielleicht Lust hätten, sich dem ganzen Zinnober anzuschließen,
dann könnt ihr das gerne tun.
Tickets gibt es auf jeden Fall noch und wir sind offen für alle Leute,
die irgendeiner Form Interesse haben.
Was so die Zielgruppe betrifft, naja.
Also natürlich wendet sich das vor allem an Podcaster, aber wir haben auch irgendwie
viel Talks, die so ein bisschen drumherum sind.
Also wir reden natürlich viel über Podcasting und wir reden über Formate und
über Podcast-Design, also wie man sozusagen Sendungsgestaltung macht.
Wir werden natürlich auch ein bisschen über das Business reden,
aber es ist definitiv keine Business-Veranstaltung, soviel kann ich euch schon mal versprechen.
Keine Schlipsis?
Keine, ja, also, nee, glaube ich nicht. Die Schlipsdichte wird sehr überschaubar sein, glaube ich.
Könnte ich mir kaum vorstellen.
Auch keine Werbeeinspielungen?
Auch keine Werbeeinspielungen und auch sonst keine Sachen in dieser Hinsicht.
Sie bekommen keine Matratzen verkauft und auch keine VPNs.
Was auch noch so ein bisschen ist, also es gibt zum Beispiel auch noch so ein
Talk, die Riffreporter, jemand von den Riffreportern wird da sein und ein bisschen
darüber reden, wie Podcasts da sind, aber eben auch wie dieser unabhängige Journalismus
derzeit so funktioniert.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema.
Ich habe auch das VOG dazu bekommen, mal ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen zu plaudern.
Das VOG ist ja das Video Operations Center vom Kongress und vom CCC und ist ja so,
finde ich, hat schon so ein bisschen so Legenden-Status, weil einfach das ist
so ein unfassbar produktives Projekt geworden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange gibt es das jetzt? Das gibt es seit,
ich glaube, seit dem 29C3 so richtig.
Also da ging das so los in Hamburg. 2930C3,
Also es gab es schon vorher in gewisser Hinsicht in Ansätzen,
dass man sich selber um das Videorecording kümmern wollte.
Also ich habe das so in Erinnerung, dass in Berlin auch schon vorher immer Videokameras
im Raum standen. Gut, die haben sich glaube ich sehr professionalisiert dann.
Ja, vor allem so konkret, dass sich das wog. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr so
hundertprozentig, wo es anfing. Auf jeden Fall fing es dann,
nachdem der Kongress nach Hamburg gegangen ist, fing es an so richtig wild zu werden.
Das heißt man hat es nicht nur hinbekommen eine Aufzeichnung zu machen,
sondern es ist dann halt mit der Zeit ein riesiger Open Source Fundus auch entstanden
an Tools, Werkzeugen, empfohlene Hardware.
Man kann sich beim VOG Hardwarelisten zusammensuchen und das im Prinzip nachbauen
und dann halt auch die Software vom VOG zum Einsatz bringen.
Da sind halt so viele Kleinigkeiten dabei, die ich gar nicht alle kenne,
deswegen werde ich jetzt auch gar nicht anfangen das groß aufzuzählen.
Das ist dann sozusagen auch Content auf der Subscribe und dann gibt es dann
auch einen Workshop dazu.
Also es gibt eigentlich in der Regel zu einem dann auch noch im Zweifelsfall
immer nochmal einen Workshop dazu.
Dazu, ich habe mich auch selber noch zu einigen Workshops durchgerungen,
also was ich glaube ich schon erzählt habe, ich wollte ja ein bisschen mal so
über Podcast-Editing reden.
Ich habe noch so ein Old-Fart-Talk angekündigt,
das heißt ich werde so ein Talk machen mit dem schönen Namen Im Dunkeln,
ist alles viel aufregender.
Da wollte ich mal so in die letzten 40 Jahre Internetkommunikationsentwicklung
reinschauen und mal so ein bisschen herleiten,
wo das eigentlich herkommt mit dieser ganzen individuellen Kommunikation,
die es ja so vorher in dem Sinne gar nicht gab.
und also klar, Telefon, aber das war es dann auch schon, aber so öffentlich
in dem Sinne ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Das ist dann eigentlich wirklich durch das Netz gekommen, aber welche Stufen
das alles so genommen hat und bis es dann auch letzten Endes technologisch beim Podcasting landete.
So diese Linie mal durch die ganze Entwicklung zu ziehen, das ist Aufgabe dieses Talks.
Genau und ich werde auch den ultimativen Rodecaster Pro 2 Workshop machen.
Oh.
Ja, nachdem ich schon im Sendegate mal mein ultimatives Rodecasa Pro 2 Review
abgegeben habe, kommt jetzt noch der passende Workshop dazu.
Genau, also wenn ihr mit dem Rodecasa arbeitet oder arbeiten wollt,
da zeige ich dann, da mache ich mal richtig die Trickkiste auf.
All die ganzen Features, die du durchgesetzt hast beim Entwickler.
Naja, da hält sich das so in Grenzen. Jetzt war ich ganz froh,
dass sie mir nochmal eine Mail geschickt hat mit so, ja, neue Beta-Firmware.
Und ich so, oh geil, Features.
Dann war das irgendwie aber nicht so richtig Features und mein Gerät hat sich
dann aufgehängt beim Firmware-Update und ich musste das dann irgendwie restoren.
Das war nicht so schön. Aber immerhin geht es.
Also man kann zur letzten Firmware zurückkehren. Es gibt ein Feature,
falls ihr das mal braucht.
Man muss tatsächlich achtmal hintereinander den Stromstecker rein und wieder rausstecken.
Also sozusagen man macht Strom rein, schaltet ihn ein und im Booten ziehst du
den Strom gleich wieder raus und das machst du acht Mal.
Es sei denn, du fährst fort zu zählen bis zur Neuen.
Die Fünf scheidet völlig aus. Das war jetzt schon die zweite Kulturreferenz
in dieser Sendung, die ganz versteckt so sich einschlägt.
So versteckt fand ich die jetzt nicht.
Und was war die erste?
Du hast es nämlich reflektiert in dem Moment, als ich es gesagt habe.
Habe ich?
Ja. Gesägt, tun, getan.
Achso, ja, ja. Hannover halt.
Richtig, Hannover halt. Mal gucken. Der Chat darf jetzt raten,
wenn der Chat rausfindet, was es ist, dann verraten wir es auch allen.
Ich bin gerade völlig perplex. Ich habe geguckt, der 29C3, das war mein erster
Kongress überhaupt und ich kann es nicht glauben, dass das quasi irgendwie der VOG,
Geburtstag gewesen sein soll, weil die waren da schon so professionell,
als ob sie den Job schon seit zehn Jahren gemacht hätten.
Also ich persönlich, das ist jetzt meine persönliche Erinnerung,
war auf dem 29C3 war dieser Begriff VOG auf einmal da.
Vielleicht ist er auch schon im Jahr vorher entstanden oder so und ich habe
es bloß nicht mitbekommen und mir hat weder keiner Bescheid gesagt.
Das kann ja auch sein, aber ich würde sagen, da hat sich das dann so richtig
manifestiert oder zumindest ist es da dann schon so richtig professionalisiert,
dass es also Teams gab und keine Ahnung.
Also was mir nur irgendwann aufgefallen ist, ich weiß noch nicht mal welcher
Kongress das war, war aber auch Hamburg, ist, dass die so eine Produktionskette
aufgebaut hatten, so eine krasse,
um zu verhindern, dass die Leute Stream-Rips ins Netz stellen,
weil die meistens nicht die Qualität hatten, die hinterher die richtig geschnittenen
Clips, Clips nenne ich es mal, also Mitschnitte hatten.
Und deswegen haben sie da sehr viel gemacht, um schnell gute Qualität zu liefern,
sodass alle mitkriegen, ja, Stream-Rip ins Netz stellen, das lohnt sich nicht.
Man kann auch auf den offiziellen Release zwei Stunden später warten.
Und das haben sie durch einen, achso dadurch, dass sie selber schnell released
haben, haben sie die Rips verhindert.
Genau und da hatten sie dann so eine Produktionskette aufgebaut mit,
man kann sich da irgendwie eine Schicht klicken und dann bekommt man irgendwie
den Kram reingespült und fängt an zu schneiden und zu tun und zu machen.
Also das hat mich damals sehr beeindruckt, als ich das gesehen habe.
Ich dachte so, ja sowas kann man bauen.
Genau und das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das Geheimnis, diese ganzen Workflows, die da drin sind.
Also ein Talk findet statt, wird irgendwie begleitet und kommt dann in einer
sagenhaften Geschwindigkeit online.
Also beim Kongress ist das Ding ja wirklich meistens nach einer Stunde spätestens
online. Online, weil das einfach.
Ja, die produzierten Dinger sind halt auch meistens insofern besser,
als dass man dann tatsächlich, wenn sich die Folie ändert, auch die Folie sieht
und nicht irgendwie den Typen.
Noch sekundenlang weiter, was mich immer wahnsinnig macht.
Es gibt so eine neue Folie, du hörst das Publikum lacht, weil sie auf die Folie
reagieren und im Video siehst du die Folie nicht und du willst aber wissen, warum die lachen.
und manchmal zeigen sie den Typen so lange, dass die Folie schon weg ist und
du hast sie gar nicht gesehen. Aber naja, okay.
So ist das.
Ja, Dominik, Kongress, was ist mit dir?
Der ist gerade weggelaufen.
Jetzt hab ich gerade mal,
da wollte ich nicht rausschleichen hier. Ja, von wegen, Dom.
Ich hab dich gerade gefragt, Dom, was mit dir im Kongress ist.
Findet es statt oder nicht?
Ich hätte Lust. Mal gucken, wie wir es hinkriegen. Weiß ich noch nicht.
Das wäre mal ganz schön. Mir hat gerade der Feuermelder gepiepst, glaube ich.
Oder ich habe was von euch gehört und dann muss ich mich da kurz drum kümmern,
weil ich habe keine Ahnung.
Der gibt den Geist auf und geht ab und zu an, weil wenn ich hier Fenster offen
habe, was da losgeht, macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn jemand von euch da weiß, kann mir ja geholfen werden.
Feuermälder.
Er hat doch gerade so gepiepst, oder? Habt ihr auch gehört?
Ich hab's nicht gehört, das wird aufgleichend, glaube ich.
Normalerweise ist es ein Zeichen dafür, dass die Batterie schwach wird.
Ja, das ist so einer, den kann man nicht austauschen. Also da muss man dann
das ganze Ding wegmachen, oder was?
So eine fest eingebaute Batterie, die zehn Jahre halten soll angeblich, oder?
Ja, sowas gibt's, aber ja, keine Ahnung.
Also ich hab neue da, einfach weghauen ist dann die Lösung?
Wenn das noch öfter passiert, würde ich's damit mal versuchen.
Also es ist jetzt das dritte Mal. Und ich kann da drücken nochmal so,
das hab ich gedacht, dass das irgendwie so ein Mechanismus ist,
dass er halt piepst, dass man einmal sich drum kümmert, dass er mal gedrückt hat.
Einmal im Jahr oder so, aber ist doch creepy alles.
Also ich habe mal in einem Haus gewohnt, da gab es halt auch so Rauchmelder
im Treppenhaus auf jeder Etage ein und irgendwie,
als hätten die sich abgesprochen, waren die Rauchmelder alle in der gleichen
Nacht, zur gleichen Nacht schlafen, an Uhrzeit der Meinung,
dass die Batterie jetzt alle ist und sie sich beschweren müssten.
Das klang irgendwie, als wäre da so eine Horde Robotervögel eingefallen und also keine Ahnung.
Wir standen dann zusammen mit der Nachbarin von gegenüber irgendwie im Treppenhaus
und haben uns gefragt, ja und jetzt?
Rauchmelder, die haben sich wirklich überall richtig reingeschlichen.
Die sind rein verpflichtet worden.
Rein verpflichtet worden, so kann man das sagen. Und jetzt ist es wieder so
ein weiteres Gerät, was einen irgendwie so latent nervt mit so latenten Fehlverhalten.
Ja, aber was einem auch latent das Leben rettet, wenn es richtig funktioniert.
Das will ich überhaupt nicht bestreiten. Es ist einfach nur generell so,
die Zahl von Geräten, die einem Nerven rauben können, theoretisch,
steigt einfach exponentiell an.
Also es fing ja schon an mit der Uhrzeit am Ofen.
Jetzt der Übergang.
An meinem Ofen habe ich jetzt einen Aufkleber gemacht.
Das ist so ein gelber Aufkleber mit so einer roten Sonne in der Mitte und da
steht drauf Atomuhr, nein danke.
Das ist der Hinweis dafür, dass dieser Herd nicht in der Lage ist,
die richtige Uhrzeit anzustellen, anzuzeigen und damit ist das für mich jetzt das Thema gegessen.
Ja, okay, gut. Und hast du auch an deiner Mikrowelle dann auch noch sowas?
Die ist ja dann auch noch mit im Boot.
Also ich habe keine Mikrowelle, die eine Uhrzeit anzeigt.
Kühlschrank.
Das ist so eine ganz einfache Mikrowelle, wo man nur so dieses Rädchen.
Am Rad dreht.
Da am Rad dreht, dann versucht irgendwie zwei Minuten einzustellen,
was natürlich nicht geht.
Tick, tick, tick, ping. pingen. Und das ist auch genau die Kategorie von Gerät,
sagen wir mal, die einem auch wirklich Dienst leistet.
Aber jetzt muss ja alles, muss ja auf irgendein Mikrochip und OS und Linux umgestellt
werden und IoT und Netzwerk und Home Assistant und hast du nicht gesehen.
Und dadurch wird die Scheiße einfach so unglaublich komplex und fehleranfängig.
Und auf einmal fangen all diese Geräte an, alle wollen irgendwas von dir.
Sie wollen, dass du ihnen die Uhr streichelst. Sie wollen irgendwelche Notifications,
ja gut, aber mit der Zeit geht es ja nur los, sondern dann wollen sie irgendwelche
Notifications haben, dann wollen sie irgendwelche WLANs einloggen,
dann änderst du mal das Passwort bei dir irgendwie, dann schlagen alle Geräte
Alarm, nichts funktioniert mehr.
Der Staubsauger funktioniert nicht mehr, wenn man das WLAN-Passwort ändert.
Naja, so weit sind wir doch jetzt schon.
Ich kämpfe auch gerade hier mit meinem Staubsauger. Das hat aber glaube ich
eher was mit der Batterie zu tun. Das meine ich zumindest nicht,
dass er mir irgendwelche sinnvollen Ergebnisse gibt. Der läuft einfach los und
bleibt dann irgendwo stehen.
Bei uns einfach zu viel Lego am Boden regelmäßig. Die manuelle Auflese des Legos findet nicht statt.
Deshalb hat der Roboter keinen Autozyklus. Deswegen fährt er so gut wie nicht.
Du hast noch keine AI drin, die Legosteine erkennt.
Der hat ja einen ganz guten Kasten. Da könnte man die auch wieder rausholen.
Doch, die hat auch eine AI.
Die macht Fotos von allem, was er denn so denkt, was er denn so sieht.
Und die kann man dann angucken.
Wenn er wirklich intelligent wäre, würde er die Legosteine nehmen und was Sinnvolles daraus bauen.
Du, die Hersteller müssen ja gegenseitig noch.
Ja, wo ist denn die Zukunft, wenn man sie braucht?
Der kleine Arm, der die Sachen dann einsammelt.
Kinderzimmerfester Staubsaugerroboter ist glaube ich noch fünf Jahre entfernt.
Tierhaare und Haare können die ja inzwischen halbwegs gut. Also der jetzt von
der Bauart ist schon weit besser als der alte Staubsauger wieder.
Im Sinne von wie schnell lange Haare die Rolle voll tackern.
das reicht ja mir jetzt alle paar Monate mal da was entfernt und nicht jetzt jede Woche.
Ja und angeblich erkennen die neueste Generation auch Tierfäkalien und machen
die nicht platt und verteilen sie das ist glaube ich auch sehr von Vorteil also ich habe kein Tier.
Aber,
ja
ja aber ihr wisst was ich meine also diese Diese übermäßige Anreicherung von
Geräten, die alle so den Finger heben und sagen, ich habe hier auch irgendwas zu melden.
Also die Geräte, die sagen, meine Batterie ist alle, ich brauche mal eine neue
Batterie, die gehen mir eigentlich auf den Sack.
Alles andere, da habe ich jetzt nicht so ein Problem mit.
Ja, kommt drauf an, welchen Grad an Komplexität sie in deinem Leben mit reinbringen.
Aber sie wollen halt alle deine Aufmerksamkeit haben.
Und es werden halt immer mehr. Dann kommt der Fernseher und dann wollen sie
Software-Updates haben.
Man hat ja Geräte, weil man nicht will, dass Leute zu einem kommen und Aufmerksamkeit haben will.
Ich sage nur, es war mal einfacher.
Aber dafür hat man auch alles selber machen müssen. Also du kannst nicht beides haben.
Ich gehe jetzt den anderen Weg. Ich habe jetzt einen Plattenspieler von 1958.
Und der tut noch. Torenz TD 124.
Und den wollte meine Schwiegermutter auf den Sperrmüll werfen.
Ihr könnt ja mal Google bemühen, was so ein Schätzchen wert ist.
Ja, sag nochmal.
Also ich...
Torens TD 124.
So und das ist aber, also convenient ist halt anders.
Das Gerät hat viel in Rundfunkanstalten gestanden, die damals noch keine CDs und ähnliches hatten.
Das alles wurde wirklich noch von Vinyl im Radio abgespielt und das ist also
Schweizer Präzisionsarbeit.
Ich habe auch einen Schweizer Präzisionsplattenspieler. Das ist glaube ich so
das letzte Aufbäumen von Hi-Fi und Plattenspieler,
bevor es dann in die Esoterik abgebogen ist und die Leute angefangen haben mit
Goldkabeln und so weiter.
Der hat einen Tangentialarm.
Und eine aktive Nachführung dieses Schlittens, der da tangential an der Platte vorbeifährt.
Das meint halt, dass der Arm nicht so rüber wandert, wie man das kennt,
sondern dass der halt quasi gerade immer im rechten Winkel zur Platte geführt wird.
Richtig, weil die Skidding-Kräfte immer tangential an der Platte anliegen und
wenn der Tangentialarm aber genau tangential quasi ausgerichtet ist,
dann hast du keine Skidding-Kräfte nach innen oder nach außen.
Und das ist theoretisch, wahrscheinlich auch praktisch, auch besser für die Schallplatten.
Sondern immer wenn du so einen Arm hast, dann stimmt der Winkel eigentlich nur
an einer Stelle genau und alle anderen Stellen wandert er nach außen oder nach innen.
Ich bin ja nur mit Ausschussplatten aufgewachsen. Meine Eltern hatten welche, mein Bruder hatte noch.
Ich habe so eine Schneider-Stereoanlage, so ein kleiner kubischer Turm auf Rollen
mit so einem Glasding mit einer ganz billigen Plattenspielereinheit obendrauf
mit alten Platten von meinem Bruder geerbt.
und da bin ich nicht gut mit umgegangen per se, weil es war aber auch schon vorbei die Zeit.
Also Platten, diese Platten-Nostalgie habe ich gar nicht.
Lustig war es und irgendwie der Plattenspieler auch vorhin im Wohnzimmer hatte so einen wilden,
Plexiglas-Deckel, der so der immer im Schrank dann oben anstieß,
wenn man eine Platte einlegen wollte und dann hat man die Platte,
ist die Platte an den Plexiglas-Deckel gedotzt, anstatt da reinzulegen und ach ja,
man durfte ja früh, als kleines Kind durfte man nicht hin, weil man alles kaputt
gemacht hat und wenn man dann älter war, da wollte man nicht mehr,
weil es hat sich nicht mehr gut angehört.
Na, das mit dem nicht gut anhören, also im besten Fall klingt es halt so gut wie CD.
Aber das ist dafür, dass es jetzt eine Technik, die halt irgendwie 70 Jahre alt ist.
Auch im besten Fall nicht.
Finde ich ist das schon, ich habe da noch ein Röhren-Amp davor und dieses Plexi-Teil,
das brauche ich in der Tat. Das war nämlich nicht dabei, leider, im Keller.
Und jetzt muss man also, damit das nicht wieder komplett zustaubt,
muss das wieder irgendwie beschützt werden.
Aber dieser einen Ausschalter ist so irre. Das ist also so, als ob man irgendwie
im Atomkraftwerk irgendwas einschaltet.
Das ist so ein Beehender-Schalter?
Das ist einer, mit dem du gleichzeitig, der ist sowieso ganz skurril,
also mit dem stellst du auf der einen Seite die Geschwindigkeit ein,
also wie viele Rotationen pro Minute, Sekunde und zwischen den verschiedenen
Stellungen ist immer wieder aus.
Das heißt also du hast quasi 33, 0, 45, 0, 88 ist glaube ich noch drauf und
unten ist auch noch irgendwie eine 13 oder sowas.
Und du hast also irgendwie vier Auspositionen. 13?
Ne, 16 müsste es sein.
Das ist also auch von der UX her irgendwie sehr, sehr sonderbar, dieses Teil.
Aber es klingt fantastisch. Ich habe es jetzt hier in Berlin überarbeiten lassen.
Es gibt ja durchaus noch Läden, die sowas noch verstehen und wertschätzen und
für relativ wenig Geld aufarbeiten lassen. Und jetzt spielt der wieder eins.
Ich habe so irgendwie 2000 Platten zu Hause.
Was? Du hast 2000 Platten zu Hause?
Ja. Habe ich.
2000 Schallplatten?
Ja, das ist eine Geldanlage. Wenn du also bei Release die richtigen Platten
kaufst, dann haben die ganz schön Wertsteigerung.
Da müssen Aktien lange rudern. Du musst sie immer noch verkauft bekommen, irgendwann der eins.
Ja.
Genau.
Das ist der.
Was ist das? Vinyl-Bitcoin oder was?
Also ich habe gar nicht so wenige Platten, die ich für irgendwie 30 Euro gekauft
habe, die jetzt so auf 180 Euro verkaufswert sind.
Wenn ich sie jemals verkaufen würde.
Und nicht vorher selber verschenkt.
So Vangelis, Blade Runner, Soundtrack.
Ich kann mir gerade so diesen entseelten Blick deiner Kinder vorstellen,
wenn du vor diesen Platten hinstellst. so, Kinder, das wird alles am Ende von euch gehören.
Auch mutig.
Was ist das, Papa? Nationale Ölreserve oder was?
Da ist ein TikTok-Kanal gestartet, der hat gesagt, jetzt höre ich jeden Tag
eine Platte. Deswegen, weil meine Eltern sind gestorben mit so einer Wand.
Roddy, hier siehst du das, wie das aufgebaut ist. Mit 45, 0, 33, 0, 16.
Ich schon, die anderen nicht. Schmeiß meinen Slack.
Ja, es erinnert hat lustig meinem kleinen Fünfjährigen habe ich genau diesen
Talk vor zwei Tagen gegeben, was er alles mal erben wird und was er aber auf
gar keinen Fall verscherbeln darf für Koks und Nutten.
Der hat sehr andächtig genickt und das alles. Meine Gypsen, das Paul,
die wird auch nicht verkauft.
Also damit ja schon mal die Spielregeln klar sind.
Du weißt schon, dass wenn er
das erstmal geerbt hat, dass du dann keine Entscheidungsgewalt mehr hast.
Ja, dann wird er noch irgendwo in seinem Hinterkopf wird ihn eine Stimme warnen. Ja.
Ich versuche gerade meine ganzen Besitztümer zu reduzieren.
Ich freue mich über jedes Device, was hier rausgeht und ehrlich gesagt freue
ich mich auch, ich habe auch so das eine oder andere eingelagert,
noch im Keller, wo ich mir denke, so ey, was soll das?
Ich habe auch tatsächlich noch aus den 80ern Sony Hi-Fi Equipment.
Was wahrscheinlich auch wirklich irgendwas wert ist. Ich bin bloß bisher noch
nicht dazu gekommen, es auszulagern. Ja.
Das Problem wegschmeißen ist halt auch Aufwand.
Vielleicht wäre das ja was für dich. So ein Sony-Verstärker irgendwie noch mit
Holzwangen aus den 80ern.
Ja, mal gucken.
Da habe ich mal viel Geld für ausgegeben.
So eine neue Zarge brauche ich auch noch. Falls da draußen irgendwo Tischler
unterwegs sind, dann mal gerne melden.
Es gibt immer noch welche, die auch für dieses Modell noch Zargen bauen.
Also diese Holzkonstruktionen, die dann so drin hängen.
Aber es ist natürlich alles ganz schön teuer und ich habe natürlich dann wieder
sehr konkrete Vorstellungen und am Ende wird also dann das ganze Drumherum-Gebau
wieder viel teurer, als die Reparatur jetzt gekostet hat. Aber naja.
Also eine Sache, an die ich mich schon noch erinnere, ist, dass man die Platten
halt eigentlich, da hat man so eine Seite halt gehört.
Da hat man einfach die vier, fünf, sechs Lieder, die auf dieser einen Seite
sind, die hat man halt einfach dann angehört.
So am Stück, so bei der Kassette auch. Und heutzutage hat man irgendwie,
ich habe dieses Album-Ding nicht mehr, weil die Playlists funktionieren für mich nicht so gut.
Und bewusst jetzt mal Musik hören, jetzt nimm dir mal Zeit und hör dir mal was
und was dann wieder auswählen.
Das war halt früher irgendwie mit so Geschichten irgendwie cooler,
Platte auflegen und dann hören und wenn die Platte aus ist, ist sie aus.
Ja und darum prangere ich aber auch an, diese ganzen Re-Issues,
die jetzt auf Vinyl rauskommen, wo also klassische Rock, Pop,
was auch immer Alben neu aufgelegt werden und die dann auf 180 Gramm Vinyl kommen,
okay, kein Problem, aber wo das dann nochmal die ursprüngliche.
Was heißt das, 180 Gramm Vinyl?
Das ist einfach dickes, schweres Vinyl, damit der Gleichlauf noch runder ist und so.
Damit das alles nicht so schwabbelt und wabbelt. So, aber vor allen Dingen fangen
die dann an, aus einem Album, was vorher eine A-Seite und eine B-Seite hatte,
dann noch eine C- und D-Seite zu machen.
Das heißt also, die verändern dann die Spurweite, damit die Nadel noch mehr
Kontakt hat und noch mehr Klang rauskitzeln kann und die Rillen noch tiefer gefräst werden können.
und dann kriegst du aber nicht mehr so viel auf eine Plattenseite drauf und
darum musst du dann halt die Hälfte der Songs nochmal auf eine andere Platte drauf.
Das heißt, du bist nur noch am Plattenwechseln, weil du nur noch zwei,
drei Lieder pro Plattenseite hören kannst.
Und das ist scheiße, weil das ist nämlich genau das, was Dom sagt,
du willst halt eine Platte hören und die wurde vorher ja auch so ästhetisch, Musik,
empathisch eben genauso zusammengebaut. Das ist der erste Song auf der Seite,
das ist der letzte Song auf der Seite, dazwischen ist bestenfalls eine Dramaturgie,
dann dann drehst du die Platte um und hast dort wieder eine Mini-Dramaturgie
und das wird jetzt komplett zerschossen. Du bist nur noch am Aufstehen und Platten
wechseln, das ist scheiße.
Das übrigens ist eine der Dinge, die ich meinte, als ich von Vinyl-Esoterik
sprach, weil das hat alles ein Maß angenommen, das irgendwie nicht mehr okay ist.
Vinyl-Esoterik. Ja, also es kann sogar noch sein, dass in meinen Beständen sogar
noch Schallplatten sind.
Also ich habe neulich meinen CD-Bestand komplett gespendet.
Also ich habe einfach mehrere Kartons voll mit CDs, wohl sortiert,
wohl erhalten, alles tiptop.
Habe ich hier irgendwie zu so einem Projekt gefahren, wo Leute sich das kostenlos
leihen oder mitnehmen können.
Ich auch, nachdem ich gescannt hatte.
Wenn du das mal findest und loswerden willst, sag Bescheid. Dann gucke ich mir das gerne mal an.
Ja, wobei bei meinen Schallplatten könnten tatsächlich mittlerweile echte Schätze dabei sein.
Tatsächlich, ich überlege nämlich gerade, gerade was ich noch als Schallplatte überhaupt hatte.
Gib dann eine Spendenquittung.
Ich meine sogar, dass ich eine, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich die noch habe,
ich glaube nicht, aber ich hatte, glaube ich, eine Schallplatte von Nancy Sinatra.
These Boots Are Made For Walking.
Hm.
Das ist dann schon, glaube ich, da können wir uns schon fast vorstellen,
dass Leute dafür Geld bezahlen wollen.
Das sage ich möglicherweise auch auf Vinyl, kann ich jetzt nicht mit Sicherheit sagen.
Da geht der Preis schon wieder runter.
Aber die Frage ist ja, in welcher Edition.
Klar, natürlich.
Also ich habe noch eine Rubber Soul von den Beatles in der deutschen Erstauflage. Vielen Dank.
Oh, allerdings ist die auch relativ weit runter, also dafür kriegst du nicht
mehr so richtig viel Geld, aber so als, naja, man hat so ein Schätzchen,
wo halt hinten auch noch draufsteht, Stereo auch Mono abspielbar.
Ja, genau. Genau.
Ja.
Meiner war Mono, jetzt der Thorens.
Und da hat dann hier mein Platten-Vinyl-Bauer-Schrauber schon sehr verächtlich
geguckt, als ich gesagt habe, den musst du jetzt auf Stereo umbauen,
weil ich habe nur Stereo-Platten und ich sehe den Punkt.
Man könnte jetzt nochmal Beatles-Mono-Platten kaufen und ich weiß,
es hat mehr Rums und so, aber mach mal Stereo. Oder so.
Naja. Also das Bono finde ich dann zu hardcore. Das geht nicht.
Aber die frühen Beatles-Platten sind alle zwei Spur Mono. Oh mein Gott.
Der Chat vermutet, ich hätte Edith Piaf beim Release gekauft.
Leute, so alt bin ich nun wirklich nicht.
Ja, aber Kate Bush hatte ich definitiv. Ich glaube, ich habe Also ich habe eigentlich
mein Musik-Imperium komplett auf CD aufgebaut.
Jetzt mit den Schallplatten war eher so eine Übergangszeit, wo ich noch so ein bisschen Reste hatte.
Aber ich weiß nicht. Ich bin, dieses ganze Aufbewahren und Speichern und so
weiter ist irgendwie nicht mein Ding.
Das sind alles so Sachen, die machen einen nur träge.
Die Platten, die ich habe, die sind auch alle nur von meiner Mutter.
Die hat sie mir mitsamt des Plattenspielers übergeholfen. Was soll man machen?
Was soll man machen? Na gut. Kommen wir zu unseren Reisen. So Roddy,
jetzt musst du auspacken.
Ja, ich war letztes Mal nicht dabei, weil da war ich gerade,
ich glaube, im Nachtzug von Odessa nach Lviv.
müsste gewesen. Egal. Also ich war in der Ukraine, das haben ja viele schon
mitbekommen, jetzt zwei Wochen.
Du hast mal eine Tour nachgefahren, sozusagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich deine Tour nachgefahren hätte. Ich habe die offensichtliche
Tour gemacht, Lviv, Kiew und Odessa.
Also das ist so irgendwie, Lviv vor allen Dingen, weil man kommt in dieses Land
ja nicht mit dem Flugzeug, also du kannst ja nicht einen Flug nach Kiew buchen.
Geht ja nicht, weil ist ja kein Flugverkehr, also zumindest kein kommerzieller Flugverkehr.
Und das ist glaube ich auch besser so.
Weswegen ich dann tatsächlich mit dem Zug gefahren bin und zwar nach Berlin
bis nach Przemysl. Jetzt müssen alle Polen weghören.
Ich habe Ich habe das zumindest mit der Aussprache so weit hingekriegt,
dass mich der Busfahrer verstanden hat, was ich meinte.
Aber gut, der ist vielleicht geübt gewesen, da drin rauszuhören,
was denn diese ganzen Nicht-Polen von ihm wollen.
Also Przemysl ist so eine ganz kleine Stadt.
Warte mal, ich kann das mal hier kurz wiedergeben. Przemysl. Przemysl. Przemysl.
Na ja, Przemysl, meinetwegen. Ähm...
Ähm, die, jetzt, also Przemysl oder wie auch immer, ist halt so eine kleine
Stadt, sagen wir mal westlich von Kiew.
Nicht sagen wir mal, sondern die ist ziemlich genau westlich von Kiew.
Westlich von Kiew sind wir alle.
Ja, aber halt direkt hinter der Grenze. Also du kannst quasi mit dem Lineal
rübergehen und irgendwie so ein paar Kilometer hinter der Grenze ist dann dieses Przemysl.
Es gibt von Berlin aus tatsächlich einen Zug, der durchfährt.
Das ist ein EC, der hat allerdings den nicht ganz unwichtigen Nachteil,
dass die polnische Bahn einen den nur buchen lässt, wenn man auch gleichzeitig einen Sitzplatz hat.
Dieser Fakt wird noch interessant werden. Das hat aber auf der Hinfahrt hat das funktioniert.
Bin ich also mit diesem Zug dahin gefahren, habe dann eine Nacht dort in so
einer Ferienwohnung übernachtet, bin am nächsten Tag mit einem Bus weitergefahren bis nach Lviv.
Das hat prinzipiell auch gut funktioniert, mal abgesehen davon,
dass Fernbusfahren in In Ländern, wo man die Sprache nicht spricht und teilweise
auch nicht entziffern kann,
ist es fortgeschritten.
Das hätte ich mir nochmal genauer überlegen sollen.
Hast du nicht ein Telefon dabei gehabt, was dir live dein Geschriebenes auf
Ukrainisch übersetzen konnte und umgekehrt?
Ja, ich rede noch von Przemysl. Aber ja, im Prinzip schon.
Aber da musst du auch jemanden finden, den du fragen kannst.
Also die Hinfahrt war noch okay.
Die Hinfahrt war noch okay, war ein bisschen nervös, aber der Bus hatte halt
20 Minuten Verspätung und da stand eine ganze Menge Leute, die offensichtlich nach Lviv wollten.
Also war ich mir halbwegs sicher, dass ich an der richtigen Stelle stehe.
Die Stadt ist auch relativ klein. Die Busse fahren direkt am Bahnhof los.
Also da ist es nicht so ein Problem.
So, dann war ich zwei Tage in Lviv, habe da so ein bisschen die Stadt angeguckt.
Ach so, Przemysl selber, wenn man in der Gegend ist, kann man sich das angucken.
Es gibt ein ganz niedliches Schlösschen dort.
Ansonsten da extra hinfahren, halte ich jetzt für übertrieben.
Ja, ganz ehrlich. Also ich will die Stadt nicht schlecht machen,
aber die ist schon sehr, sehr weit weg von uns.
Aber ist halt so ein Durchgangsding nach Lviv.
Lviv selber, kann ich da jetzt irgendwas zu sagen?
Ich muss sagen, dieses Hotel, was du mir da empfohlen hast, das war ziemlich gut.
Das hat mir gut gefallen.
Ich hatte auch in Lviv selber noch keinen Luftalarm. Da wusste ich noch nicht
so genau, was mich erwartet.
Und ich bin dann von Lviv mit dem Zug nach Kiew gefahren.
Das war so ein ganz normaler...
Ein normaler Zug mit Sitzen halt, also kein Nachtzug mit Liegewagen,
sondern so ein Zug mit Sitzen.
Das war maximal unspannend. Der Zug fuhr pünktlich.
Tickets hast du wie gekauft?
Über irgendeine App. Da müsste ich jetzt nochmal kurz gucken.
Aber über irgendeine App?
Über irgendeine App, genau. Wie ich eigentlich alle Tickets über irgendeine App gekauft habe.
Da gibt es eine ukrainische App, da müsste ich jetzt kurz nachgucken,
wie die hieß. Die war zumindest zum Zugticket kaufen ganz gut.
Die war fürs Busticket kaufen nicht ganz so gut. Aber gut, Busse und Bustickets, ja, kommt noch.
Genau, der Zug, der war wie gesagt, also der ist halt einfach gefahren und dann war ich in Kiew.
Kiew war ja nur eine Ferienwohnung. Und da habe ich dann das erste Mal so richtig
mitbekommen, was das bedeutet, dass ständig der Strom weg ist.
Und der war nämlich wirklich auch sehr oft weg.
Deswegen habe ich mehr oder weniger am Morgen des nächsten Tages,
war ich in so einem Café, das war ganz nett.
Der Typ, der konnte relativ gut Englisch, deswegen habe ich ihn mal gefragt,
wo ich denn meine Taschenlampe kaufen kann.
Die Frage hat ihn extrem aus der Reserve gelockt, er hatte nämlich keine Ahnung,
wie er mir jetzt beschreibt, also wo erstens man eine bekommt und zweitens mal
wie er beschreibt, wie ich da hinkomme.
Insofern dachte ich, naja, brauchst du jetzt gar nicht zu versuchen.
Was ich dann gemacht habe, mir war nämlich aufgefallen, du kriegst so Handy-Zubehörläden,
sind ja in der Ukraine überall. Überall.
Und zwar, also ich glaube, man könnte mit drei Tonnen Handyhöhlen wiederkommen
und die sind alle unterschiedlich.
Also das ist wirklich, das Angebot ist unglaublich.
Und dann habe ich halt einfach mal versucht zu gucken, es gibt ja Powerbanks mit Lampe.
Und dann habe ich in einem dieser Läden halt diese Powerbank erstanden,
die die Hörer jetzt nicht sehen.
Ich meine, du kannst mal kurz ein Foto machen.
Also eine Powerbank, wo eine Lampe mit drin ist.
Ja, aber eine relativ große.
Keine Ahnung, mit was man das jetzt vergleichen kann. Also erstens relativ groß,
relativ hell. und diese Powerbank hat, da steht 20 mAh drauf, 20,
20.000 mAh bei 3,7 Volt, ich habe es gerade nachgerechnet, sind 74 mWh angeblich, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde es immer bemerkenswert, wenn die Dinger alles in mAh angeben, diese Akkus.
Aber man weiß nicht, wie viel Volt die eigentlich jetzt da rechnen.
Weil die geben ja verschiedene Ströme raus. aus?
Die können ja 5 Volt, 12 Volt, 15 Volt und 20 Volt und deswegen ist Milliampere-Stunden
genau gar keine Aussage.
Ja, hier steht aber Battery Capacity 20.000 Milliampere-Stunden bei 3,7 Volt.
Also insofern kann man es da rausnehmen.
Also Sie rechnen das quasi auf Zellspannung.
Ja. Ich nehme mal an, das ist üblich.
Ja, weil dann haben Sie die größte Milliampere-Stunden-Zahl sozusagen,
die am geilsten klingt. Richtig.
Gut, es ist natürlich ein chinesisches Produkt, aber dieses Ding,
das war dann auch wirklich ein guter Kauf.
Du musst ungefähr fünf Sekunden auf den Button an der Seite drücken, dann geht die Lampe an.
Also ich hatte dieses Ding vollgeladen, dann war der Strom alle,
dann habe ich es angemacht und nach mehreren Stunden entschloss ich dann die
Anzeige da oben mal von 100% auf 99% runter zu gehen.
Also ich hätte glaube ich das Ding den gesamten Aufenthalt anhaben können und
wäre nicht alle geworden.
Also genau eine Lampe, wie man sie haben will.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Kurbel?
Nee, Kurbel nicht. Dann muss man schon irgendwie elektrisch laden.
In Kiew, ja, habe ich so das Übliche angeguckt.
Also unter anderem die, wie heißt sie auch, Mutterheimat?
Ja, ich glaube. Die große Statue, die da steht.
Ja, ich war ja vor 2007 oder so, also für ewigen Zeiten war ich ja mal in Volgograd.
Da gibt es auch eine Mutterheimat-Statue.
Ähnlicher Stil.
Allerdings, ich glaube, die hat kein Schild und da ist auch kein Sowjet-Symbol
drauf, aber aber die ist noch martialischer als die Mutterheimatstatue.
Die haben jetzt auch kein sowjetisches Symbol mehr drauf, weil das haben sie ja runtergekratzt.
Richtig, und haben jetzt das ukrainische Symbol.
Dazu gibt es dann noch irgendwie, naja, so diese typische sowjetische Erinnerungskultur.
Ja, dieser Brutalskulpturwald, der da irgendwie drumherum ist.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, wenn man in Volgograd die Erinnerungskultur dort gesehen
hat, dann denkt man sich, wow, ganz niedlich.
Wenn man das nicht kennt, sondern nur, weiß ich nicht, das russische Ehrenmal
oder das sowjetische Ehrenmal hier in Treptow, Treptower Park kennt,
dann ist es schon sehr beeindruckend.
Also weil sehr viel Beton, sehr viel diese sowjetischen Soldatenskulpturen und
dieses ganze, also es ist, ja, also.
Man kommt da unglaublich schwer
hin. Ich bin dann irgendwie mit der U-Bahn gefahren, aber das ist so.
Genau, U-Bahn fahren, überhaupt Zug fahren. Apropos, was sie überhaupt nicht
drauf haben, die Ukrainer, ist beim öffentlichen Nahverkehr oder auch sonst Dinge ausschildern.
Also man kommt eigentlich ohne GPS, also wenn man Zug fährt ohne GPS kommt man
nicht aus, weil man nicht weiß in welcher Stadt man ist.
Es steht zwar irgendwie am Bahnhof dran, aber auf dem Bahnsteigen gibt es keine
Schilder, es gibt nirgendwo Schilder.
So normale Busse in der City erkennt man eine Bushaltestelle im Wesentlichen
daran, dass da ein paar ältere Frauen am Straßenrand stehen und so gucken,
als würde da jetzt irgendwas kommen.
Also das ist so, naja.
Genau, Kiew, dann Odessa. Nach Odessa bin ich….
Gab es den Luftalarm in Kiew?
In Kiew gab es relativ oft Luftalarm.
Das musste man mal beschreiben, weil ich hatte ja nicht das Vergnügen.
Also der einzige Luftalarm, der war, da war ich dann schon unten in der tollen
Bar, wo man den nicht hört, sondern nur auf dem Handy angezeigt bekommt. kommt?
Das ist halt das, also wenn Luftalarm ist, dann hat man ja einmal die Sirene.
Also es gibt ja diese Air Alarm App auf dem Phone, die funktioniert auch sehr gut.
Normalerweise geht die an, bevor die Sirenen losgehen, was ich auch interessant finde.
Und du hast dann im Prinzip in der ganzen Stadt sind Sirenen,
Wie man sich das so vorstellt, so aus dem Krieg, Luftalarm-Sirenen.
Wie gesagt, das war relativ oft. Was ich gemerkt habe, ist, dass die Ukrainer
da auch nichts mehr drum geben.
Also, gerade in Odessa ist mir das dann auch ein paar Mal passiert,
dass es halt tagsüber war und dann überall Sirenen, die Leute flanieren ganz
normal weiter und tun einfach gar nichts.
Also ich glaube, das geht schon viel zu lange.
Die haben da auch keinen Bock mehr auf Bunker oder irgendwas.
Das passiert einfach nicht mehr.
Wenn man das das erste Mal mitkriegt, man liegt im Bett, wird um drei Uhr in
der Nacht vom Luftalarm rausgehauen und soll sich eigentlich jetzt mal in einen Schutzraum begeben.
Und man hat aber die Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht und weiß nicht, wo der Schutzraum ist.
Und erinnert sich dann, naja gut, zwischen Außenwand eines Hauses und da,
wo man ist, vielleicht zwei massive Wände.
Dann habe ich mich halt auf den Flur gesetzt und habe das dann auf dem Flur irgendwie.
Aber irgendwann hast du auch wirklich keine Lust mehr.
Ja, ich war auch in dem Hotel in Odessa und dann hat dann die Dame am Empfang
uns auch erklärt, so ja und es gibt natürlich dann auch einen Schutzraum,
weil den müssen sie haben.
Ja, der war auch gut ausgeschildert.
Ja, und ich war dann aber ganz überrascht, dass ich den sehen wollte.
Also ich wollte da mal hin.
Nicht, weil ich da unbedingt hin, also ich wusste ja nicht, ob ich nicht vielleicht
da noch hingehen wollen würde, aber ich wollte zumindest mal sehen, was es war.
Und es war jetzt nicht wirklich so ein ausgebauter Schutzraum,
sondern es war halt einfach nur so ein, ja wohl vom ganzen Gebäude eingerahmter
Bereich, irgendwie so ein bisschen Backstage in ihren Orga-Flächen.
So ein Kellerraum, Die hatten dann da ganz viele Stühle und ein paar Liegen und fertig. Da war ich.
Nicht mal so ausgestattet. Ja, aber sie war dann auch ein bisschen überrascht,
dass ich das auch wirklich sehen wollte.
Ja, man merkt, das ist irgendwie nicht mehr so.
Und gab es auch einen Einschlag da, wo du mal warst? Hast du irgendwas gehört?
Ist auch mal was runtergekommen oder abgeschlossen worden?
Nee, also ich habe weder was gehört noch gesehen ähm, ich habe jetzt auch die
News natürlich nicht verfolgt, weil ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht wie ähm.
Gibt da Telegram-Kanäle für?
Ja, schon. Aber ja, also ganz ehrlich, ich habe davon überhaupt nichts mitbekommen.
Also man bekommt die Luftalarme natürlich mit. Man bekommt auch immer die Stromausfälle
mit. Das waren doch schon sehr viele.
Also gerade in Odessa war das extrem auffällig.
Also Odessa ist ja eher eine kleinere, etwas ruhigere Stadt.
Klar, da gibt es auch viel Kopfsteinpflaster. sondern wenn die Autos da fahren,
ist es halt laut. Aber es ist eigentlich eine Stadt, die nicht so laut ist.
Bis wenn der Strom ausfällt, weil dann gehen nämlich alle Stromgeneratoren an
und dann wird es richtig laut in der Stadt.
Das war in Kiew und Lviv nicht ganz so auffällig, aber da war es eigentlich auch so.
Also kaum fällt der Strom aus, wird die Stadt laut und stinkt,
weil die Stromgeneratoren alle laufen. Und vom kleinen Eisladen bis hin zum
großen Hotel, alle haben sie diese Dinger und die werden dann halt auch angemacht.
Also das ist so, ja, keine Ahnung.
Ja, jetzt bin ich ein bisschen aus dem Konzept, also gut,
Kiew habe ich jetzt, ehrlich gesagt habe ich gar nicht so viel geguckt,
also ich habe mich da nicht so unter Druck gesetzt, jetzt unbedingt alle Schönheiten
der Stadt sehen zu müssen oder alle Kirchen, die goldene Dächer haben,
das schaffst du sowieso nicht, weil alle Kirchen haben goldene Dächer da.
Also ich bin dann bin dann mit einem Zug nach Odessa gefahren,
der eigentlich ein Nachtzug ist, aber der ist ein Nachtzug, wenn er von.
Von Wien nach Kiew fährt, fährt er als Nachtzug, kommt dann irgendwie morgens,
in Kiew an und fährt dann einfach weiter nach Odessa und das ist so ein bisschen
komisch, so tagsüber in so einem Liegewagen irgendwie auf der Liege sitzen und
ja, aber Aber war auch irgendwie kein Problem.
Lustig an Odessa fand ich, du kommst da mit dem Zug an, steigst aus dem Zug
aus und denkst dir so, ah, Meer, Urlaubsort.
Weil du kommst aus dem Zug raus und es riecht einfach nach Meer,
nach Badeort irgendwie.
Und dann dazu diese Platanen, wie man sie ganz in vielen so südfranzösischen
Städten am Mittelmeer kennt und so.
Also dieser Mix aus so französischer Mittelmeerstadt und aber auch sehr viel
so Art Deco-Architektur,
wie man sie so aus Brüssel kennt.
Und dann aber auch klassizistische Bauten und so weiter.
Also wunderschön. Also Odessa, finde ich, das kann man mal gesehen haben. Diese...
Diese Treppe, die man aus Panzerkreuzer Potemkin kennt, diese Potemkische Treppe,
war jetzt nicht so aufregend wie in dem Film.
Da haben nicht so viele Leute zusammengeschossen worden dann.
Der Kinderanlage. Das war es jetzt nicht.
Du hast sie ja immerhin betreten dürfen, bei mir war sie noch gesperrt.
Also sie hatte unten, unten war Stacheldraht, aber von oben konnte man runterlaufen.
Also man hat auch so ein bisschen bei Odessa gesehen,
dass sie sehr viele Zugänge von dem Schwarzen Meer, von der Küste nach oben
in die Stadt ganz stark abgeriegelt haben.
Gut, vieles davon wirkte nicht so, als wäre das noch so richtig in Betrieb oder
so richtig gepflegt, aber man hatte das Gefühl gehabt,
also als der Krieg losging,
dass die schon Angst hatten, dass die Russen da anlanden.
und über diverse Wege einfach irgendwie den Hügel rauf in die Stadt laufen.
Deswegen war da halt viel abgesperrt, also besonders im unteren Bereich.
Na gut, das ist ja auch alles Hafenanlegegebiet und so weiter.
Da ist ja nicht wirklich Strand.
Ja.
Ja, ja, das wäre schon ganz sinnvoll, wenn das mal irgendwann alles mal wieder
richtig zum Leben kommt. Und man merkte auch, glaube ich, wirst du wahrscheinlich
auch gemerkt haben, also es sind halt viel weniger Leute da, als da hingehören.
Was ich sehr auffällig fand, zumindest in Lviv,
war, dass der Anteil Frauen, Männer auf der Straße ein komplett anderer Mix ist als bei uns.
Also dass da vor allem Frauen auf der Straße zu sehen sind und eigentlich keine
Männer. Also sie sind wirklich eine Ausnahme.
Also daran sieht man das schon sehr stark. Deswegen, ich bin halt immer gefragt
worden, ob ich da irgendwie Angst hatte oder jetzt in der Ukraine oder Bedenken oder sonst was.
Ich habe mich nie unwohl gefühlt, aber das lag vor allen Dingen auch daran,
dass du läufst auf der Straße und hast das Gefühl, du bist der einzige Mann weit und breit.
Da ist niemand, der dir aufs Maul geben kann oder so.
Sondern ansonsten sind da halt nur Frauen unterwegs. Das fand ich ein ganz merkwürdiges Gefühl.
Aber ein sehr angenehmes Gefühl irgendwie, dass da halt keine Typen sind und
vor allen Dingen keine Shady-Typen.
Also gar nicht.
Ist jetzt auch übertrieben. Aber in Lviv,
ich hatte so das Gefühl, in Lviv haben sehr viele Männer ihre Familien geparkt.
Oh ja.
Das war so mein Gefühl, weil da halt tatsächlich auch irgendwie,
und wer sich's leisten konnte, der ist nach Lviv gegangen.
Das wirkte so, Lviv ist so das München der Ukraine, wo so, wenn man da Geld
hat, dann geht man da hin.
Kiew war mehr so das Berlin.
Laut, schrill. Weil, also ich war an dem einen Tag, wo ich da war,
das war ein Samstagabend, da bin ich da über die Hauptmeile gelaufen und dachte mir,
also das ist mir jetzt eigentlich fast schon zu viel Party.
Also ich habe ja auch Hamburg erlebt. Hamburg war mir ja auch schon so grenzwertig
an wie viel Party das ist.
Aber da war das echt krass. Also jetzt nicht unangenehm, aber ich hatte das
Gefühl so, alter, das ist jetzt nicht meine Welt so heftig Party zu machen,
wie die da Party machen an einem Samstagabend.
Tja, das könnte deine letzte sein. Also es ist nicht.
Dass ich es nicht verstehe, ich sage nur, es ist nicht meine Welt.
Aber zu der Frauenwahl, ich habe gerade überlegt, wie ich das eigentlich wahrgenommen
habe und mir stand bei mir jetzt nicht so im Vordergrund, aber jetzt wo du das
erwähnt hast, fiel mir auf, dass ich gerade in Lviv,
da gab es dann so auf einmal eine komplette Polizeitruppe, die für,
was weiß ich, wofür die zuständig war.
Ich glaube, die waren teilweise auch gerade außer Dienst und sahen irgendwie
so aus, als ob sie gerade vom Dienst kommen.
Weil die waren irgendwie im Supermarkt und so weiter. Und das waren halt alles
Frauen. Also es war so eine komplette Frauen-Polizei-Gruppe.
Das fand ich dann irgendwie so, ah, ja okay, gut, hier verteilen sich dann sozusagen
die Aufgaben auch wieder neu.
Ja, also ich bin, das ist auch so lustig, weil du Polizei sagst,
ich bin einmal kontrolliert worden, da bin ich ja mit der U-Bahn Richtung diese Star-Tour da,
diese Mutterheimat gefahren und bin dann an einer Stelle rausgekommen,
wo du als Tourist eigentlich nicht rauskommst, weil das ist nicht an der U-Bahn-Station
und dann musste man nochmal drei Kilometer laufen und so weiter.
Und dann hat halt so ein Polizist geguckt, die waren irgendwie so zu zweit in
der U-Bahn, als man aus der U-Bahn rauskam und dann wollte er mal irgendwie meinen Pass sehen.
Und dann habe ich ihm halt meinen deutschen Pass gezeigt und dann war es ihm
schon fast peinlich unangenehm, dass er mich aufgefordert hat, ihm den Pass zu zeigen.
Das hat man richtig gemerkt, dass er jetzt irgendwie, dass er fand,
dass er jetzt, dass er da drüber war. Irgendwie sowas habe ich noch nie erlebt
mit einem Polizisten, also das ist so.
Ja
Also habe ich jetzt so nicht erlebt sowas aber kann ich ganz gut nachvollziehen
Ich weiß ja nicht, was er bei dir gedacht hat Ich glaube.
Ich bin ihm einfach aufgefallen, weil ich erstens ich sag mal keinen ukrainischen
Männerhaarschnitt habe Weil ich zweitens...
eigentlich in einem Alter bin oder erscheine, wo man normalerweise mich eben
auch, sagen wir mal, an der Front vermuten würde, vielleicht.
Und drittens, weil ich halt auch einfach so, ich bin halt einfach aufgefallen, glaube ich.
Mhm. Naja, okay. Ist ja vollkommen okay.
Naja, dass es ihm dann peinlich war, das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen. Weil natürlich,
kann man ja gar nicht hoch genug einschätzen, also,
das wird natürlich sehr geschätzt, wenn man gerade aus dem Westen da ist.
Wenn man sich das anschaut, wenn man präsent ist, da vielleicht auch Geld ausgibt,
Also überhaupt sozusagen, weil da ist ein Mangel an West-Touristen.
Das kann man mal ganz klar feststellen. Also wenn ihr schon immer mal irgendwo
Urlaub machen wolltet und ihr habt normalerweise zu viele Engländer und zu viele
Deutsche um euch herum, dann ist Ukraine echt guter Tipp.
Naja gut, es gibt so ein paar Stellen in Kiew, wo man dann doch auch irgendwie Westler trifft.
Klar, im Interkontinental.
Ja, beziehungsweise da, wo die Ferienwohnung war, direkt um die Ecke,
war so eine komische Bar.
Die hatten so im Innenhof Tische.
Kann man jetzt nicht Biergarten nennen.
Ja, aber du warst im Zentrum von Kiew, da wo alle Journalisten hängen.
Also das ist einfach genau der Ort.
Ich habe mich dann mit einem Ami unterhalten. Das waren zwei ganz offensichtlich
irgendwas mit Militär von den Amis.
Und der eine war so ein richtiger weirder Trumper.
und wir haben uns ein bisschen unterhalten und der ist dann irgendwann getürmt,
weil ich so ein paar Sachen gesagt habe, wo er einfach die kognitive Dissonanz
so groß wurde, dass er dann direkt irgendwie los musste.
Es war ganz lustig, weil der Typ so so bulkig und so Strongman-mäßig rüberkam.
So, er ist hier der fette Macker und so weiter.
Der hat dann aber auch so ein bisschen Angst bekommen Ich weiß nicht, ob es Angst war.
Was hast du gesagt?
Das Erste, was ich gesagt habe, ist, dass ich CNN nicht für links halte,
sondern eher für rechts.
Okay, der Start.
Und dann meinte ich noch so, ja, Twitter ist mir eigentlich egal.
Seit Elon Musk Twitter gekauft hat, habe ich meinen Twitter-Account zugemacht.
Und danach war dann Feierabend bei ihm.
Verstehe.
Aber der kam auch mit so ganz kruden Sachen an, so nach der Art,
ja eigentlich hätte es gar nicht zwei Weltkriege gegeben,
sondern es wäre nur einer gewesen und wir hätten da das in der Schule nicht
richtig gelernt und es waren auch die Juden an allem schuld und hast du nicht gesehen.
Was macht der Typ in der Ukraine?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber der Typ, der mit ihm da war, dem war massiv peinlich.
Mit dem konnte man sich auch normal unterhalten und der ist dann auch abgezogen,
weil die Situation… Wurde mir zugeteilt.
Konnte ich nichts gegen tun.
Irgendwie so. Also es war auf jeden Fall, ich habe mich sehr amüsiert,
obwohl ich hinterher dachte so, what the fuck, was war das jetzt?
Ich frage gerade, hatte der auch so ein Tierfell um? Genau, Sturm auf.
Tierfell? Nee, aber das hätte ihm gestanden, sagen wir mal so.
Schamanenhelm.
Ja, so in der Art. Kapitol.
Okay, jetzt noch so ein paar Beobachtungen, die ich mir so aufgeschrieben habe. Einige Sachen.
Kartenzahlung, das funktioniert ja so gut wie überall.
Mein Tipp an der Stelle, wenn ihr da hinfahrt, nehmt trotzdem ein bisschen Bargeld
mit, weil gerne Taxifahrer nicht die Möglichkeit haben, dass man da per Karte zahlt.
Nicht haben wollen oder was?
Nee, die einfach kein Lesegerät mithalten.
Was?
Ja, ja, ist mir zweimal passiert. Dem ersten habe ich 5 Euro gegeben für eine
Taxifahrt, die glaube ich irgendwie umgerechnet 1,50 gekostet hätte oder so.
Und dem anderen habe ich irgendwie 3 Euro gegeben, weil dann irgendwie,
ich hatte dann nur noch Münzen. Genau, 3 Euro und 20 Riffen her.
Also egal, auf jeden Fall, das ist so.
Und dann habe ich in Odessa das deutscheste Café überhaupt gefunden,
weil da standen nicht nur auf Deutschcafé dran, sondern man konnte auch nicht mit Karte zahlen.
Gut, das war nur eine temporäre Sache. Die hatten das irgendwie mit ihrem Internet
und ihrem Strom nicht so richtig am Start.
Deswegen, als der Strom weg war, konnte man nicht bezahlen.
Aber es war trotzdem irgendwie sehr auffällig. Das, naja, apropos Kaffee,
das fand ich, ich weiß nicht, ob dir das aufgefallen ist, man kriegt ja überall guten Kaffee.
Also gerade die drei großen Städte, die bersten ja quasi von guten Kaffees,
wo man überall einen richtig guten Kaffee kriegt, aber versuch mal einen Tee zu bekommen.
Das ist wirklich faszinierend. Also man hat das Gefühl, die empfinden Tee als
etwas, was russisch ist. Das ist eBay, das machen wir nicht.
Und wenn du im Supermarkt im Regal guckst, alles was da an Tee ist,
der ist immer mit Union Jack und da steht London oder Großbritannien oder sonst was drauf.
Dann ist das ein Earl Grey und hast du nicht gesehen.
Aber es gibt definitiv keinen russischen Tee da. Das ist alles englischer Tee, der muss englisch sein.
Also das war….
Es gibt überhaupt definitiv nichts Russisches überhaupt noch irgendwo irgendwie.
Und das Beste war in dem Hotel in Lviv, da hatten sie zum Frühstücksbuffet auch
Tee und der Tee war dann in so gelb-blauen Tütchen eingepackt und dann stand drauf,
ukrainischer Guten-Morgen-Tee.
Also auf Englisch.
Nur damit klar ist, das ist jetzt auch kein russischer Tee.
Das ist das eine. Und das andere, was mir aufgefallen ist, du findest fast keine
kyrillische Schreibschrift.
Die benutzen nur Druckbuchstaben.
Gibt es das überhaupt?
Oh ja, wenn du mal in Russland warst, dann, also ich meine, Kyrillisch ist sowieso
schon die erste Stufe, ist nicht so ganz einfach, aber kriegt man schon irgendwie hin.
Die Druckbuchstaben, das kriegt man hin, aber die Schreibbuchstaben,
die verstehst du halt gar nicht, weil die so unterschiedlich aussehen zu den Druckbuchstaben.
Und ich habe vielleicht zwei oder drei Mal Schreibbuchstaben in der Ukraine
gesehen, das wird glaube ich auch als russisch empfunden.
Schreibschrift haben die nicht nirgendwo, also das steht das steht in kyrillischen
Druckbuchstaben da oder gleich in lateinischen Buchstaben oder beides das fand
ich auch sehr sehr faszinierend irgendwie.
Ich meine es ist ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt bei uns besonders viel Schreibschrift noch sehen würden Ja.
Good point, aber trotzdem. Also ich fand es sehr auffällig. Ich fand es auffällig.
Ich kenne den Vergleich nicht, ich war ja nie in Russland.
Ja, ja. Dann noch was. Elektroautos.
Überall Elektroautos in der Ukraine. Das fand ich extrem faszinierend.
Gut, das waren alles so ältere Modelle, so erste Generation Zoe,
ein i3 von BMW oder eine erste Generation Leaf, zweite Generation Leaf oder so.
Alles so Autos, die bei uns verschwinden von der Straße, weil die Leute sie nicht mehr fahren.
Die sind scheinbar alle irgendwie in der Ukraine und die fahren die da glaube
ich mit sehr viel Freude.
Also das fand ich erstaunlich.
Also ich würde mal sagen, man sieht in Lviv und in Kiew sieht man einen höheren
Elektroanteil, Autoanteil auf der Straße als in Berlin.
Da hast du einen etwas geschärfteren Blick, da habe ich jetzt nicht so drauf geachtet.
Das ist so meine Sackbeobachtungen, die jetzt hier kommen.
In Polen gar nicht. Da sieht man einfach keine Elektroautos.
Ich bin immer nur durchgefahren, aber trotzdem sind mir da nur eins aufgefallen.
Insofern würde ich jetzt mit meinem Elektroauto nicht unbedingt,
also ich hätte jetzt keine Bedenken in die Ukraine zu fahren und dort zu fahren,
Aber man muss halt einmal durch ganz Polen durch.
Wie heißt es so schön? Ist schön, aber zieht sich.
Strom oft weg, das hatte ich schon gesagt.
Plastikstrohhalme. Es gibt da noch Plastikstrohhalme.
Spaß!
Ja, ist ja keine EU.
Alle Eltern dahin.
Also ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre ich jetzt der große Verfechter des Plastikstrohhalms.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Ich sehe das ein, dass man die nicht mehr haben will.
Aber wenn man plötzlich wieder welche hat, dann merkt man schon,
was einem fehlt, weil diese Pappdinger sind ja echt schlimm.
Makaroni.
Macker. Naja gut, besser als Pappe, ja.
Restaurants ist auch ein Phänomen. Die sind wirklich alle extrem schick, extrem gut.
Und ja gut, die Preise sind jetzt im Vergleich sowieso niedrig ohne Ende.
Also, keine Ahnung, es gelingt einem fast nicht, da viel Geld auszugeben,
weil das nach dem Umtauschkurs kostet alles nichts mehr.
Obwohl, ich habe einen Laden gefunden, da gab es Dinge, die waren teurer als bei uns.
Das war in Odessa so ein Laden für so China-Kram, diese Instant-Nudelsuppen
und dieses Zeug. Was irgendwie wirklich richtig teuer war da.
Spezialitäten für China. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, das stimmt. Die Restaurants waren da wirklich richtig schick.
Sie haben ein Dinglaufen mit gutem Restaurantdesign. Das ist da irgendwie angesagt.
Ich war in, in Lviv, war ich in so einem, so einem japanischen Suppenladen und
hab da so eine Suppe gegessen, hat sich so ein Typ zu mir gesetzt und wir ins
Gespräch gekommen, der war ein bisschen weird,
der hat mir dann auf seinem Handy irgendwie so Filmchen gezeigt,
wie er mit seinem, mit seinem Performance Tesla irgendwie Donuts auf dem Parkplatz
dreht und so, also keine Ahnung.
Aber der hat mir zumindest ein paar Tipps gegeben auch für Kiew und da war so
ein Laden-Club-Restaurant-Dingens dabei, in so einem Innenhof.
Draußen mit so Sitzsäcken und so weiter. Das war so richtig entspannt.
Da konnte man so richtig chillen und die hatten auch gute Musik und so.
Also Musik ist manchmal so, ist nicht immer so geil, aber die hatten wirklich auch nette Musik und so.
Das war schon. Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, Getränke werden immer getrennt
abgerechnet, besonders alkoholische Getränke.
Also wenn du da was isst und ein Bier dazu trinkst, dann musst du zweimal bezahlen,
weil du das Bier immer extra bezahlen musst. Keine Ahnung, das muss sowas.
Das ist wirklich eine merkwürdige Geschichte. Also das hat irgendwas mit Lizenzierung
zu tun, mit Alkohollizenz.
Ja, davon bin ich auch ausgegeben.
Weil das Restaurant, da steht dann auch auf den Rechnungen eine andere Anschrift
oder eine andere Rechtsperson sozusagen.
Ja, davon bin ich auch ausgegeben.
Und deswegen musst du das dann immer separat zahlen, weil das ist dann sozusagen,
der Alkohol kommt von da und das Essen kommt von da und keine Ahnung,
was da noch für Steuertricks dahinter stecken.
Und dann kommen sie auch an, so nach der Art, wollen sie noch ein Bier trinken,
wir können bis 10 Uhr, können sie mit Karte noch eins bezahlen, danach nur noch bar.
Also es scheint da so eine Art Sperrstunde für Alkohol zu gehen,
die sie natürlich nicht umgehen können, wenn du mit Karte zahlst,
weil dann ist ja das Transaktionsdatum da.
Das heißt entweder du bestellst vor 10 noch eins und rechnest es bar oder du bezahlst es bar.
Dann wird die Zukunft abgeschaltet.
Ja, das fand ich auch sehr niedlich irgendwie. Genau, ÖPNV.
Ich bin, wie gesagt, in Kiew mit der U-Bahn gefahren.
Das ist relativ simpel. Es gibt ja diese Kiew-App. Und in der Kiew-App kann
man sich sogenannte QR-Tickets klicken.
Da kostet dann eine Fahrt,
20 Rüvenjahr, das sind 10, glaube ich, sind 25 Cent ungefähr.
Ja, das war die Größe.
Also nix. Und dann kannst du halt sagen, ich kaufe jetzt 10 von den Tickets
und wenn du einmal fährst, ist halt ein Ticket weg.
Und du machst halt diese App auf, scrollst zu dem Ticket und hältst es an so
einem QR-Code-Reader dran.
Und dann geht da die Schranke auf und dann fährst du dann Ticket und irgendwie
merkt die App dann, dass das Ticket jetzt verbraucht ist.
und das hat sehr gut funktioniert, Bus oder Tram fahren habe ich nicht gemacht
das ist quasi unmöglich, mir ist nicht gelungen Netzplan zu finden,
herauszufinden, wie man ein Ticket kauft, wo die Dinger überhaupt fahren und
so weiter welche Linien, also keine Ahnung, wir schimpfen so viel über BVG und
andere Verkehrsbetriebe, aber mal ganz ehrlich,
also Also das mit der Ausschilderung und Informationsweitergabe und so weiter
von solchen Dingen, das kriegen sie überhaupt gar nicht hin.
Bist halt alle Bescheid.
Ja, du musst da Bescheid wissen oder bist aufgeschmissen. Also das ist ein bisschen schade.
Ich hätte durchaus auch mal einen Bus genommen oder so, aber das ist mir halt
einfach nicht gelungen. Ja.
Genau, jetzt kommen wir noch zur Rückfahrt, weil die war nämlich auch relativ
spannend. Das war von Odessa mit dem Nachtzug nach Lviv.
Das hat funktioniert, abgesehen davon, dass, also ich war dann im Abteil mit
drei anderen Leuten, drei Frauen. Weil auch der Zug waren im Wesentlichen Frauen.
Das war einfach so, war aber jetzt kein Problem.
Die beiden älteren Frauen haben dann irgendwie ein riesiges Picknick ausgepackt
und mich dann genötigt irgendwie daran teilzunehmen.
Genau und dann wäre eigentlich nachmittags mein Bus gefahren.
Jetzt war das aber so, dass auf dem Busticket war nicht ersichtlich,
wo der Bus fährt und ich hatte angenommen, naja dann fährt er halt wieder am
Hauptbahnhof. Aber es gibt in Lviv auch einen zentralen Omnibus Bahnhof.
Das wusste ich aber nicht.
Und auf dem Ticket stand es im Prinzip auch nicht drauf.
Oder ich war zu doof, das zu sehen. Auf jeden Fall fuhr dieser Bus dann ohne mich.
Das war an dem Freitag.
und dann habe ich halt gleich an dem Tag noch einen Bus gebucht,
wo ich dachte, er würde am gleichen Tag fahren, tat er nicht,
war dann einen Tag später,
und dann bin ich halt nochmal zurück in das Hotel, wo ich schon beim ersten
Mal war, hab dann nochmal eine Nacht verbracht,
bin dann mit dem Bus losgefahren und Und irgendwie,
der Bus war sowieso schon komisch, weil er, also auf der Hinfahrt hat der Bus
von Chemischel nach Lviv zweieinhalb Stunden gebraucht.
Das sind ungefähr eine Dreiviertelstunde Fahrzeit und der Rest an der Grenze, mehr oder weniger.
Also eine Stunde, anderthalb Stunden an der Grenze, irgendwie sowas. Krass.
Die Rückfahrt sollte halt irgendwie 6 Stunden oder 6,5 Stunden brauchen und
da hatte mich schon so ein bisschen gewundert, aber egal, Hauptsache Bus,
aber irgendwie wollte ich wieder nach Hause kommen.
Und stellt sich also heraus,
dass die nicht den normalen Grenzübergang benutzt haben, den man normalerweise
von Lviv nach Przemysl nehmen würde.
Da gibt es nämlich eine Straße, die fährt direkt rüber und auf dieser Straße
ist der Grenzübergang. Ist ja irgendwie logisch, ne?
Geradeaus und dann über die Grenze. So aus irgendeinem Grund hat dieser Bus
aber einen Grenzübergang angesteuert, der so 30, 40 Kilometer weiter südlich war.
Und ich möchte hier mal den Ausdruck des artisanalen Grenzübergangs prägen.
Also der war, naja das war schon so in den ersten Ausläufern der Karpaten,
landschaftlich wunderschön, da hinzufahren aus dem Fenster zu gucken war wirklich
super, aber die Täler wurden immer kleiner und immer kleiner.
Die Straße wurde dann irgendwann so, dass ich sie mit meinem Auto nicht fahren wollen würde.
Und dann kam der da an. Es gab keinen Empfang mehr.
Die ukrainischen Grenzer hatten ganz offensichtlich sich eine Starlink-Schüssel
hingestellt, weil sie irgendwie Netz haben wollten.
Und dann hat es gedauert. Also die ukrainische Seite, die ging noch,
die war glaube ich nach einer Stunde oder so durch.
Also in dem Bus waren ja außer mir und der Buscrew waren ja nur Ukrainer und fast nur Frauen.
Ich glaube es waren drei ukrainische Männer, also zumindest drei Männer im wehrfähigen
Alter. Die anderen waren Kinder.
Und die mussten auch nochmal so ein Packen Extrabescheinigungen mit abgeben,
dass sie das Land verlassen durften. Das hat aber irgendwie alles funktioniert.
Und dann hat sich der Bus, nachdem das alles durch war, hat sich der Bus,
naja, 50 Meter weiter bewegt.
Dann mussten wir alle aussteigen und sämtliches Gepäck wieder an uns nehmen.
Die gesamte Bus wurde ausgeräumt.
Auch das polnische Busteam musste alles das, was sie dabei haben, rausnehmen.
Und dann sind wir wie so am Flughafen an so einem Grenzkontrollding mit Gepäck
und so Schaukästen, wo halt der Grenzer drin sitzt und so eine Durchröntgenanlage und so ein Kram.
Genauso sah das aus, nur halt ungefähr so groß wie eine Doppelgarage oder eine
Dreifachgarage oder so. Also wirklich kleiner Raum.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt fiel es mir dann wie Schuppenmaus den Haaren.
Ja, EU-Außengrenze, natürlich.
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen aufwendiger.
Hat das vorher keiner gesagt.
Naja, im Prinzip hätte ich das wissen müssen. Aber es gibt so Dinge,
die man prinzipiell eigentlich wissen müsste, die man aber nicht auf dem Schirm hat.
Weil man sie nicht täglich erlebt.
Weil man sie nicht täglich erlebt, genau. Und da habe ich das erste Mal so dieses Gefühl gehabt,
ah, so ist es für einen Amerikaner, wenn der Immigrations macht und sich nicht
an die Bittstellerschlange anstellen muss, wie alle anderen,
sondern einfach da so durchmarschiert mit seinem amerikanischen Pass.
Und so war es dann auch bei mir.
Irgendwie sämtliche Ukrainer, also gut, und dem polnischen Bus-Team natürlich,
sämtliche Ukrainer wurden nochmal extra fotografiert.
Und mit Pass hier und Pass dort. Und hast du nicht gesehen und nochmal zurechtgewiesen,
nein, warten Sie hier, da muss erst da.
Also da war schon so, also nicht schlechte Stimmung, aber so,
wie man es halt so von der Grenze kennt. Alle sind so ein bisschen in...
jetzt nichts Falsches tun, Stimmung irgendwie.
Und die Grenzerin hat mich dann gefragt, oh ja, wo waren sie denn?
Ja, Lviv, Kiew, Odessa. Oh, toll.
Mich durchgewunken und dann war es das. Das war schon, da habe ich mich fast
ein bisschen scheiße gefühlt, weil alle anderen irgendwie so.
Mussten so leiden.
Mussten so leiden, ja. Und dann
war das aber so, eine Mitreisende hatte irgendein Problem mit ihrem Pass.
Und dann dauerte es zusätzlich zu den zwei Stunden, die wir da schon verbracht
hatten an diesem schönen Ort, nochmal weitere drei Stunden, bis das geklärt war.
Das heißt für diese, wie viel sind das? Ich glaube nicht mal 100 Kilometer?
waren es dann neun Stunden Fahrt.
Oh Mann.
So.
Dann war ich da im Hotel in Polen. Das Hotel hat so viel gekostet wie das Luxushotel
in Lviv und hatte die Anmutung einer Jugendherberge.
Also das war so.
Willkommen in der Europäischen Union.
Zurück in der Europäischen Union. Es gibt wieder EU-Preise zu zahlen.
Dann war der durchgehende Zug ja schon ausgebucht. Ich hatte eine andere Verbindung
genommen und diese Verbindung hatte irgendein Problem,
was dazu führte, dass ich in Breslau dann gestrandet bin, weil der Zug fast
eine Stunde Verspätung hatte.
Genau. Und dann habe ich da freundlich, aber sehr bestimmt die Frau da am Schalter
irgendwie um Rat gebeten.
Und dann meinten sie, ja, kann ich jetzt nicht viel machen, aber sie haben mir
da so einen Zettel gegeben hier, damit können sie bla und so weiter,
Fahrgastrechte und sie müssen aber
eine neue Karte kaufen. Eine neue Karte gekauft und wo bin ich gelandet?
Im Kulturzug.
Es gibt zwischen Berlin und Breslau einen Kulturzug.
Aha, was ist da anders? Ist der auch artisanal?
Ja, so ein bisschen. Also es ist so ein Regionalbahn-Diesel-Ding,
so ein Doppel, also weißt du, so zwei Diesel-Kombinationen, wo man,
wenn man von einem Teil des Zuges zum anderen will,
muss man an irgendeiner Haltestelle außen rumlaufen.
Und dann hatten die da in dem einen Zugteil halt Kulturprogramm und das führte dann dazu,
dass der Zug losfuhr und sie über den Lautsprecher erstmal Musik abgespielt haben und zwar...
Den Eisenbahn-Dampfgalopp von einem gewissen Gunkel.
Was? Ja, so heißt das Stück. Eisenbahn-Dampfgalopp. Ich kann nichts dafür.
Ist ganz lustig. Ich habe hinterher versucht, den zu finden und siehe da,
es gibt noch ein zweites Stück.
Trab und den gestreckten.
Ja, es gibt noch ein zweites Stück. Eisenbahn-Dampfgalopp ist aber nicht von
diesem Gunkel oder wie der hieß, sondern von irgendeinem Schweden oder Dänen oder so.
Ja, und damit nahm das dann sein Ende und dann war ich wieder in Berlin.
Der Kulturzug.
Der Kulturzug. Also ich glaube, das lohnt sich den mal zu nehmen,
um mal ein Wochenende in Breslau oder wie auch immer.
In der dreieinhalb Stunden Fahrzeit verbindet der Kulturzug Berlin mit der polnischen
Metropole Breslau mit einem tollen zweisprachigen Kulturprogramm an Bord.
Genau. Dafür hatte ich überhaupt keine Nerven mehr übrig.
Ja, wieso? Also hier, Programmemfehlung. Lesung und Talk, Gedanken vom Tellerrand der deutschen Einheit.
Lieder, Lyrik und Revolution mit dem lettischen Dichter Marisch-Saddisch in
Kooperation mit und so weiter. Okay, ja.
Das ist dann auch am 3. Oktober, da kann man mal über die Einheit reden.
Der Kulturzug, der ist, lustigerweise kostet der nicht viel Geld,
weil der nämlich subventioniert ist, weil es ja ein Kulturprojekt ist.
Alright. Na, da hast du ja was gesehen.
Also die Rückfahrt war sehr nervenaufreibend, weil, ich sage es ungern,
aber das Einzige, was geklappt hat, was wirklich geklappt hat, war die Deutsche Bahn.
Ich stand fünf Stunden im Stau auf der Autobahn, das war auch keine große Freude.
Also das ist so, naja, der Kulturzug, der hat funktioniert.
Dom, warst du mal im Osten?
Nee, interessanterweise gar nicht. Also auch nicht.
Gar kein Osten. In Berlin war es ja schon.
Ja, aber jetzt Richtung Polen.
Tschechien.
Ah doch, jetzt bin ich ja gemeint. In Tschechien war ich einmal mit dem Tanzen.
Europameisterschaft. Die war in Tschechien und die Grenze, wir hatten einen
Ausweis zu wenig dabei und wir hatten ein bisschen Backschisch dabei.
Was heißt Europameisterschaft?
Bist du Europameister im Tanzen geworden?
Nee.
Aber du hättest es werden können.
Zweiter oder Dritter sind wir, glaube ich, geworden.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, mit Ludwigsburg.
Sie haben mein Interesse geweckt.
Ich habe mit Ludwigsburg Formation getanzt. Standard.
Formation Standard. Genau.
Und Weltmeisterschaft in Berlin habe ich gemacht. Das habe ich dir doch mal erzählt.
Das war der einzige Moment, wo ich das erste Blinkenlights Live gesehen habe, gerade noch.
Deswegen.
Das lief dann ja noch länger und dann bin ich da, also wie wir da in der Weltmeisterschaft
waren, da habe ich das gesehen. Daher kannte ich es.
Okay, das ist schon so weit her, dass du mir das erzählt hast.
Das habe ich mir nicht gemerkt.
Ja. Aber ansonsten, ich war nie urlaubsmäßig im Osten irgendwie.
Großartig. Bin aber auch kein großer Urlauber per se.
Ja, ich glaube, das war jetzt auch eher mehr so eine Kulturreise, bei Roddy.
Eine Kulturreise, ja. Eine Sache ist mir noch aufgefallen, wenn du in der Ukraine
versuchst mit jemandem Englisch zu reden,
gibt es Leute, die können das halbwegs, da ist das kein Problem,
gibt es die Leute, die können das nicht und denen ist es fürchterlich peinlich.
Wenn du in Polen versuchst, mit jemandem Englisch zu reden oder irgendwas anderes
als Polnisch, gucken sie dich nicht mit dem Arsch an.
Also das ist so, ja, keine Ahnung.
Andere Basissituation.
Vielleicht kam ich auch zu sehr als Deutscher rüber und die mögen sie ja nicht.
Das kann auch sein.
Das kann auch sein, aber das ist so, nee, also war eine Kulturreise, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde ja, wir müssen alle mehr in den Osten, weil zumindest als Westler
muss man mehr in den Osten.
Wir sind ja hier alle Westler, ne?
Also geboren in West-Berlin.
Tief im Westen.
Wir senden zwar aus dem Osten, aber sind irgendwie so komplett,
ja alle nur so Westflüchtlinge.
Was ist denn für dich Osten? Ist Türkei auch Osten?
Ne, also es ist natürlich östlich, aber wenn ich jetzt Osten sage,
meine ich halt der ehemalige Ostblock. Vor allem der slavisch geprägte Raum.
Das ist so das, was ich meine.
Das grenzt es, glaube ich, ganz gut ein und das schließt halt auch so ein paar
Sachen wie Griechenland und Türkei aus.
Aber alles, wo slavische Sprachen gesprochen werden, das ist,
glaube ich, für viele im Westen so ein totaler blinder Fleck.
und das ist halt auch nicht gut, weil das ist einfach zu nah dran an uns,
als dass wir das so machen können.
Jetzt ist es natürlich in allen Ländern so, wohin du auch fährst,
du wirst immer auf mehr Leute treffen, die das Land noch nie verlassen haben,
als die, die wirklich reisen und du hast natürlich immer die Polyglotten und
die hast du auch überall, aber so grundsätzlich,
sind wir natürlich durch unsere krasse Westorientierung über Jahrzehnte so dermaßen
in Richtung Westen gebiased, dass wir glaube ich viele,
kommen noch nicht mal auch auf, ich kenne das auch aus eigener Erfahrung oder
auch aus einem eigenen Gefühl daraus, man kommt noch nicht mal auf die Idee es zu tun.
Also wir Westler kommen nicht auf die Idee.
Jaja, ich rede nur über uns Westler.
Naja gut, ich bin ich bin ja jemand, der wenn sich eine Möglichkeit bietet dann
auch gerne einfach mitmacht. Also es ist jetzt seit langem die erste Reise,
die ich einfach mal so alleine gemacht und organisiert habe.
Aber deswegen war ich ja auch schon mal in Volgograd, das mal Stalingrad hieß
übrigens, für alle, die es nicht wissen.
Das war halt ein Austausch mit dem Chor.
Dann war ich einmal so richtig weit im Osten in Nowosibirsk.
Das ist die drittgrößte russische Stadt.
Und zwar, als die Transsibirische Eisenbahn gebaut wurde, musste die auch über
einen riesigen Fluss drüber den Don.
Und an der Stelle, wo das Arbeitslager war, wo sie die Eisenbahnbrücke gebaut
haben, aus diesem Arbeitslager wurde halt eine Stadt und sie ist jetzt die drittgrößte Stadt Russlands.
Dass dieses Novosibirsk, was Novosibirsk auch so ein bisschen einzigartig macht,
ist, dass relativ viel so akademische Leute und auch so Technologie sind dort, weil zu Sowjetzeiten….
Die Sowjets der Meinung waren, sie müssten möglichst die wichtigen Dinge weit ins Hinterland tun.
Und wenn du dir anguckst, Nowosibirsk ist, ich glaube, auf der Höhe von Neu-Delhi,
breiter Höhe, wie sagt man, egal. Egal.
Also quasi nördlich von Neu-Delhi.
Und das ist wirklich weit im Osten.
Ist das schon hinterm Ural? Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Also wenn du jetzt den Längengrad meinst, dann ist es nicht nur nicht Neu-Delhi,
das ist dann schon eher Nepal.
Naja, wie auch immer, es ist weit im Osten. Die,
Russen haben da die Zeitzonen auch so ein bisschen anders als der Rest der Gegend
dort, weswegen es rein auf der Uhr nicht so viel Zeitunterschied ist.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein brutaler Jetlag, den du da hast, wenn du da hinfliegst.
Ja, also du hast auf jeden Fall Ost-Experience und ich sage ja nur.
Alle anderen sollten das auch mal haben. Das war das weiteste und es ist nicht
hübsch, die Stadt braucht man nicht hinfahren.
Wunderte mich nur gerade, dass das die drittgrößte Stadt ist mit 1,6 Millionen.
Alright, wollen wir mal weiter schreiten.
Ja, wir haben noch.
Wir haben ja noch ein paar Themen und denen sollten wir jetzt mal ein bisschen
Aufmerksamkeit gönnen, finde ich.
Sind wir jetzt schon soweit?
Sind wir schon bereit für Apple-Kram?
Ja. Und?
Apple-Kram. Also es gab Apple-Kram. Ihr habt es wahrscheinlich alle mitbekommen.
Und wenn es Apple-Kram gibt, dann müssen wir uns ja da auch drüber unterhalten.
Wir sind ja der Apple-Podcast angeblich.
Ja, habe ich auch gehört, dass wir das sind. Wie man gerade an dem Segment gesehen hat.
Ja, was ist passiert? Es gab mal wieder hier iPhone-Keynote,
wie es das immer gibt. Und iPhone Keynote heißt halt New Devices und nachdem
ich mich die letzten Jahre extrem zurückgehalten habe, habe ich mich diesmal
nicht extrem zurückgehalten.
Du kamst von?
IPhone-technisch. iPhone 13 Pro Max.
Ein Gerät, mit dem ich ausgesprochen zufrieden war. Drei Jahre lang.
Das hat mich gut begleitet und war eine gute Wahl, sodass ich auch auf Pro Max geblieben bin.
Oh, das ist ein Max hier.
Du brauchst die Größe.
Ich brauche die Größe, ja klar. Klar.
Ich habe auch das iPhone Pro und ich hatte einmal den Max mal,
wie die Kamera einen Unterschied gemacht hat, einen großen.
Und ich habe es wegen der Kamera nicht bereut, aber wegen sonst allem,
weil es viel zu groß ist. Dann brauche ich nicht.
Also ich habe auch zugeschlagen, leider ist es noch nicht angekommen.
Es ist aber für morgen angekündigt.
Ich komme vom 12 Pro zum 16 Pro.
Ja, eigentlich war das so, dass ich mir gesagt habe, so Apple muss mir jetzt
mal was anbieten, weil eigentlich ist es noch gut.
Und dann aber muss ich sagen, die Sache mit dem Kamerabutton,
kommen wir ja sicherlich gleich drauf, hat mich dann doch überzeugt.
Nach vier Jahren kannst du jetzt vielleicht doch mal.
Ich bin ja Anfang des Jahres erst von einem 7 auf einen 14 Pro gewechselt Du
hast es verdoppelt Das war in der Tat mindblowing Von einem 7?
Von einem 7 Ich hatte ganz tapfer noch einen 7 und jetzt aber vom 14 Pro das
lohnt jetzt nicht so Da bin ich immer noch täglich so von geflasht was das für
ein schönes Stück Technik in der Tat ist Ich bin da sehr glücklich mit,
Das wird jetzt noch so Also zwei, drei Jahre mindestens halten.
Ganz interessant, seitdem ich nicht mehr hauptberuflich auf der Plattform arbeite,
wie sehr mir das eigentlich relativ egal ist, die neuen Geräte.
Meine Grundbedürfnisse sind schon lange gedeckt.
Die Fotoqualität wird immer besser. Das ist so das eine Eck, wo ich Lust drauf habe.
Und die andere Sache ist halt wirklich, mit dem 13er hatte ich schon auch Promotion.
und ich kann halt echt mit so einem 60-Hertz-Telefon kann ich,
das kann nicht mehr mit mir, das geht nicht, weil ich hätte diesmal fast downgegradet
vom Pro, weil alles andere ist ja lecker bei einem 16er.
Aber ich habe da einmal gescrollt im Apple Store und dann bin ich nach Hause
gegangen und habe denen das Pro bestellt.
Das geht einfach nicht. Ich kann nicht mehr ohne ProMotion arbeiten bei sowas,
bei iPad und Telefon, das geht nicht. Wenn es beim Scrollen ruckelt, das geht nicht.
Ruckelt es?
Ja, 60 Hertz sind zu wenig.
Pro-Motion ist jetzt 120 Jahre.
Pro hat 120. Also bis zu 120. Wenn es das braucht, genau.
Das passt sich ja dynamisch an, ob es hochgefahren wird oder auf 60.
Also ich konnte da nie so richtig einen Unterschied feststellen.
Du hast auch irgendwie 10 Jahre Retina ausgesessen und hast gesagt,
du siehst ja keinen Unterschied. Ja, aber warum das schon? Mit deinen Augen.
Aber warum dann das Pro, wenn du keinen Unterschied hast? Weil du kannst das
große Normale kriegst, oder auch? Also was ist dein Grund fürs Pro?
Also mein Hauptgrund Erklären Sie sich. Ist Akku.
Das ist beim großen, kleinen auch groß.
Ich will diese drei Kameralinsen, ich will also maximal Zoom haben.
Also gerade der Fünffach-Zoom, das hätte mich letztes Jahr schon interessiert,
aber das hat dann nicht gereicht alleine.
Also auch ich bin jetzt nicht derjenige, der jetzt, oder mittlerweile zumindest
nicht mehr derjenige, der jetzt jedem iPhone hinterherrennen muss.
Ich hatte definitiv nicht alle in den letzten Jahren, sondern habe mir das immer
ein bisschen aus der Ferne angeschaut.
Aber für mich ist halt Akku, ist halt für mich einfach ein Riesending.
Ich will einfach so viel Akku haben. Ich will auf jeden Fall immer,
egal wie sehr ich das Ding trete und quäle, möchte ich durch den Tag kommen.
Dann wollte ich auf jeden Fall auch das hellstmögliche Display haben,
dass also möglichst auch noch im Sommer in irgendeiner Form mir was angezeigt bekommt.
So und ja und ansonsten weiß ich nicht, sehe ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt gar
keinen Vorteil da drin weniger zu haben.
Also warum soll ich mir jetzt ein Telefon kaufen mit weniger Features?
Weiß. Einfach nur der Preis.
Ja, aber der Preis ist ja nicht so groß der Unterschied. Also das spielt dann
am Ende irgendwie keine große Rolle, finde ich.
Findest du. Sind schon ein paar hundert Euro zwischen dem Pro und dem normalen.
Ja, aber es ist das aller, also neben meinem Laptop ist das mein aller,
aller wichtigstes Gerät.
So, und Gott, ich kaufe mir das dann alle drei Jahre, dann teile ich jetzt mal
diese Preisdifferenz durch die Monat, also es spielt einfach keine Rolle.
Also da denke ich jetzt gar nicht groß drüber nach, ich nehme einfach das rechts
unten Modell und fertig.
So, dann muss ich nicht, ich habe auch gar keine Lust drüber darüber nachzudenken.
Ich weiß nicht, hat das 16er diesen Action-Button?
Ja.
Hat es auch, ne? Ja, okay, jetzt haben sie es nachgedacht.
Das 16er hat jetzt beides, das hat ja das 15er. Bei der 15er,
bei der Pro und jetzt 16er ist wirklich, bis auf die Kamera und das Display,
on par. Mehr oder weniger.
Ja, also das Einzige, was mich jetzt noch kurz hat zögern lassen,
aber ich hab mir gedacht, jetzt will ich auch mal sofort am ersten Tag das Ding
haben, weil es wird schon irgendwie hinhauen.
Ich hänge halt von diesen SP-Connect- Höhlen ab, die sind für meinen Lifestyle,
extrem wichtig. Hast du deine schon? schon für...
Die kommt erst nächste Woche dann. Ich habe ja noch die alte ohne MagSafe hier.
Die hatte ich nämlich dummerweise für das 13.
Bekommen.
Und die neue ist dann mit MagSafe. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die ohne MagSafe überhaupt noch gibt.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir über SP-Connect schon mal gesprochen?
Ich glaube am Rande schon.
Ja, das kann man ja nochmal kurz erwähnen. Also SP-Connect ist halt so dieses,
universelle Telefon mit Dingen verbinden. Das ist ein Bajonettverschluss.
Genau, der funktioniert wirklich
ausgesprochen gut und in dem Fall ist es halt direkt im Cover drin.
Das heißt, ich bin für den offenen, für den sonstigen Handyhöhlenmarkt sowieso nicht zu haben.
Ich brauche halt diesen SB Connect, der macht das Telefon unwesentlich dicker hinten.
Also es ist wirklich sehr flach eingearbeitet in die Hülle und ja,
dann kann man das einfach überall ran tackern.
Also ans Fahrrad, Motorrad, Auto.
Es gibt es irgendwie als magnetische Haltung, aber es gibt eben auch diesen
Verschluss, der eben auch bei voller Motorradvibration sozusagen immer ordentlich
zupackt und das funktioniert bemerkenswert.
Das gibt es als Armbandbefestigung, kannst also allen möglichen Quatsch kriegen
mit Ladeadapter drin eingebaut und so weiter.
Also SP-Connect kann ich sehr empfehlen. Das hat mir jetzt in der kurzen Zeit,
in der ich das habe, also seit anderthalb Jahren oder so, sehr gute Dienste
geleistet und das ist einfach super.
Ja genau und dann habe ich halt meine alte Hülle von meinem 13 Pro Max ausprobiert
und gemerkt, ich kriege es da rein, auch wenn irgendwie Kamerabatten natürlich,
ja also ich habe es physisch reinbekommen, es ist nicht perfekt,
aber es ging und dann wusste ich so, ah ok, ich kann auf jeden Fall schon mal
wechseln und ja jetzt bin ich halt da.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das habe ich mir jetzt eben geleistet als professionelles
Gerät und bereue jetzt soweit erstmal nichts.
Mal gucken, ob alle Versprechen mit, dass es nicht so heiß wird und so weiter
und dass der Bildschirm wirklich heller ist, auch eingehalten werden.
Werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht, aber naja.
Was man auf jeden Fall festhalten kann, ist, dass Apple jetzt schon etwas überraschenden
Schritt gegangen ist, indem sie das 16 Normal und das 16 Pro doch so extrem
dicht aneinander gerückt haben.
Also gerade bei der CPU, die haben ja zuerst das normale 16er vorgestellt und
dann haben sie wieder so diese sehr abstrakten Performance Charts gezeigt und
dann haben sie ja zum 15er Normalen verglichen und das war ja ein irrer Sprung.
aber halt einfach, weil sie eine Prozessor-Generation quasi übersprungen haben
und dadurch halt nicht nur ihre normalen irgendwie 10 bis 15 Prozent Leistung
reinholen, sondern halt 20 bis 30 Prozent.
Also bisher hat man ja mit dem normalen iPhone 15 quasi immer die CPU vom Vorjahr
dann reinbekommen und dieses Jahr ist es dann auch der A18, ist es glaube ich, ne? Ja, genau.
Das ist bemerkenswert, dass sie das jetzt einfach mal so gleich ziehen.
Ja, Aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist dieses mit den CPUs doch schon sehr
abstrakt inzwischen bei den iOS-Geräten geworden.
Meinst du, es ist eh alles schnell genug?
Erstens ist es eh alles schnell genug und zweitens ist es halt auch,
also ich meine, Lügen, Notlügen, Benchmarks.
Was Apple da an Zahlen, dem kannst du ja sowieso nicht über den Weg trauen.
Und wie gesagt, in Real World ist das alles schnell genug.
Die Frage ist eher, wenn du was hast, was ein bisschen mehr Wumms braucht,
wie schnell saugt es den Akku leer?
Und dazu gibt es aber auch keine richtige Aussage von Apple insofern.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind so die zwei relevanten Fragen wirklich.
Die eine ist, wie schnell saugst du den Akku leer? Und die andere ist,
wie schnell wird es so heiß, dass es nicht mehr brauchbar ist?
Also dass es im Auto irgendwie zu heiß wird, wenn es unter Sonneneinstrahlung
ist und dann nicht mehr weitergeht oder wenn es halt was unter Volllast macht
und dann wirklich dann drosselt.
Weil dann hast du ein Problem, wenn du die Performance brauchst.
Also wenn du in dieser Zielgruppe bist, was weiß ich, du musst halt so eine
Videoaufnahme machen, die halt eine Stunde dauert, draußen in der prallen Sonne irgendwo.
Das macht einen Unterschied dann. Ansonsten für Normalos, glaube ich,
ist das echt Schnurzipups.
Ja, oder du musst unbedingt eine Stunde lang ein Spiel mit Raytracing und allem drum und dran spielen.
Aber was mich jetzt halt interessiert, ist dieser Kamera-Button.
So, den will ich doch jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Kamera-Control bitte, Control.
Kamera-Control, jawohl, ja. So, das heißt also, wir haben jetzt so eine Kaprezive,
wie heißt es nochmal genau? Kapri...
Kapriole.
Kaprezive, genau. Taste an der Seite, so und die geht auch erstmal gar nicht an.
Weiter unten, du bist im Action-Button gerade. Da oben ist der Action-Button und da unten ist der...
Der war schon richtig jetzt hier, oder?
Für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, er ist so ungefähr auf Daumenhöhe,
wenn man es im normalen Senkrecht hält.
Als Rechtshänder.
Als Rechtshänder, genau.
Und damit ist er auch ein bisschen weit drin, wenn man ihn als Kameraknopf benutzt,
finde ich, wenn man so einen Kameramäßig hat, der ist ein bisschen arg mittig
gefühlt für Querformat Kamerabilder.
Wenn man sie denn mal ins Querformat schießt, macht man heutzutage mit dem Telefon
selten. Also ich, wenn ich Videos mache, noch ab und zu.
Aber ich habe ja immer noch die geheime Hoffnung, dass den Linkshänder designt hat.
Also es ist jetzt halt ein etwas länglicher Button und den kann ich halt so
halb durchdrücken und ich kann ihn ganz
durchdrücken, also wie man das auch so von von Fotoapparaten kennt,
halb durchdrücken, um quasi irgendwo einen Fokus zu setzen, ganz durchdrücken,
um dann auszulösen und wenn ich auf dem da halt länglich ist, mit dem,
Finger dann so hin und her swipe, dann meistens, jetzt gerade nicht,
doch jetzt habe ich den Modus aktiviert, kann ich dann also rein und raus zoomen,
aber so richtig geil fühlt es sich irgendwie nicht an, also als ob er so ein paar,
es ist nicht so richtig flüssig, im Sinne von es springt irgendwie so ein bisschen
und man rutscht und es tut aber nichts.
Nur am am Meckern.
Wie kann ich...
Das ist den Eindruck, kann ich teilen, von dem man sich im Store ausprobiert hat auch.
Es ist halt eine sehr kleine kapazitive Fläche, die nicht so super genau geht
und das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Beim Stift hatten sie es ja auch mal, dass man da hoch und runter wischen kann und drauf tappen.
Da hat das auch nicht so geklappt. Das Wischen haben sie ja nie rausgebracht.
Das konnte der Stift zwar, aber das hat man ihm dann nicht gegeben. Ja,
Ich finde es interessant, dass es grundsätzlich geht an der Stelle,
aber mein Finger war jetzt auch nicht sauber genug, um da irgendwie netter zu
agieren, als wenn man mit dem Daumen
dann gleichzeitig auf dem Bildschirm rumdrückt, der viel länger ist.
Zum Beispiel für Zoomen finde ich so ganz brauchbar und der Rest ist halt so Kleinkram.
Aber es ist halt ein Knopf, wo man ein Foto machen kann, der wie ein Knopf funktioniert.
Das finde ich persönlich ganz gut. Die Haptik zum Halbdurchdrücken finde ich
gut, dass man wirklich merkt, er ist halbdurchgedrückt und dann abdrücken.
Und wenn man damit rein diese Point-and-Shoot-Geschichten macht von früher,
mit jetzt Autofokus fokussieren, ein bisschen woanders hinzeigen,
Fotos machen und man ist dann schneller, das wird mir auch schon reichen.
Aber das Abdrucken hattest du ja auch schon immer mit den Lautstärketaster.
Das heißt also mit der Lautstärkeregelung konntest du auch schon immer physisch.
Mir ist es immer passiert, dass ich den An-Aus-Button drücke,
weil ich manchmal das Phone so halte, dass der auf der falschen Seite ist und
zack. Und dann denkst du so, oh.
Ja, alles vorbereitet, alle machen Cheese und dann zack drückst du den Knopf,
anstatt vorne auf das Display zu drücken und dann ist das Handy aus,
anstatt dass das Foto gemacht wurde.
Ja, ja, das habe ich mir dann auch irgendwann.
Also man kann halt auch hin und
her schalten, was man denn genau jetzt mit diesem Swipen halt oben macht.
Also ob man jetzt zoomt oder ob man die Blende einstellt oder Belichtung rauf, runter.
Also all das, was man im normalen Kameramodus halt auf der rechten Seite umschalten kann.
Aber auch dieses Umschalten von was ich jetzt gerade haben will,
das hat alles sehr klein und fusselig da oben.
Hast du es hinbekommen? Ich habe es damals nicht mal hinbekommen.
Ich wusste nämlich auch nicht, dass es ein Doppel-Halb-Tab sein soll, um das umzustellen.
Achso, ich habe jetzt einfach drauf gedrückt mal auf dem Display.
Ein Doppel-Halb-Tab. Ja, drauf drücken macht ja das Foto. Deswegen.
Was ist denn ein Doppel-Halb-Tab?
Ja, das ist ja das Halb-Durchdrücken.
Ein Halber-Doppel-Tab.
Also ein Halber-Doppel-Tab.
Nein, du hast zwei. Weil es ist gar kein... Es ist...
Es ist erstmal... Erstmal ist es kein Tap, sondern ein Press.
Okay, stimmt.
Und zweitens...
Naja, du hast halt eben dieses Anteasern, wie du es bei einer normalen Kamera auch hattest.
Hat man das heute noch bei einer normalen Kamera? Ja. Man drückt halt oben drauf
und kündigt im Prinzip an, ich würde jetzt gerne ein Foto machen.
Und ich muss sagen, allein dafür, also ich fand schon den Action-Button in der
Hinsicht ganz gut, da dachte ich mir so, ah, endlich mal eine Taste,
wo man einfach, ich will fotografieren sagen kann.
Und bin aber dann aus den verschiedenen Gründen halt auf die Generation noch nicht eingestiegen.
War aber sehr froh, dass jetzt noch zusätzlich ein, das ist jetzt nur Kamera
und immer Kamera und ich habe den Action-Button für andere Sachen frei,
was dann wahrscheinlich bei den meisten Leuten Taschenlampe ist.
Oder andere Tricks, können wir auch nochmal drüber reden. Also ich weiß noch
nicht genau, ob ich was zu meckern an habe, aber ich bin schon mal sehr froh,
dass ich den habe, auch wenn ich ihn derzeit nicht benutzen kann,
weil ich ja noch nicht die richtige Handywelle dafür habe.
Bin ja gespannt. Aber wie er durch das Loch dann gut durchfunktioniert überhaupt,
weil die haben ja ein Loch reingemacht, die SP-Lar habe ich auf dem,
ich habe es ja nicht in echt gesehen, sondern nur auf der Webseite, weil ich,
hoffe, das funktioniert gut, weil es wird halt noch ein bisschen fummeliger,
wenn das dann in der Hülle ist.
Also wenn Apple so weitermacht, muss Tesla nachziehen und doch wieder Buttons ins Auto einbauen.
Das müssen sie eh Ja.
Aber sehen sie es vorher ein?
Naja, die kriegen ja jetzt schlechtes Security-Rating für keine Buttons.
Keine Blinker-Tasten und so.
Okay, also meine Arbeitsthese ist noch jetzt einmal kurz in der Hand gehalten.
Wenn ich da meine Kinder mit filmen oder fotografieren will,
ist es auch zu fusselig, so um da irgendwie dann schnell in der Bewegung irgendwie das...
Naja gut, vielleicht gewöhnt man sich auch ein bisschen dran.
Vielleicht gewöhnt man sich dran, ja, aber gut, gewöhnen tut sich halt auch
ans normale Display und das ist irgendwie größere Trefferflächen. Naja.
Du kannst es ja immer noch machen. Also insofern, du hast ja jetzt nichts verloren dadurch.
Das stimmt.
Und zum Aktivieren der Kamera ist es halt wirklich so ganz nett.
Das ist wohl ein bisschen doof, dass wenn du es aus einem gelockten Zustand
aktivierst, dann musst du zweimal drücken oder so. Oder wenn das Display praktisch an ist.
Aber das, was mich eh schon, was mich wundern wird, ich habe ja bisher noch
kein Always-On-Display gehabt.
Dieser Display ist an, aber das Telefon ist eigentlich noch zu Zustand,
dass man da praktisch doppelt irgendwie das Ding bedienen muss, damit es aktiv wird.
Das ist mir noch unklar, ob mich das nerven wird oder nicht.
Weil da bin ich sehr empfindlich, was das Ganze angeht.
Und für alle, die jetzt kein so ein Telefon haben, bei dem Always-On-Display
per se, muss man ja trotzdem noch mal erst mal das Display aktivieren und dann
kann man auf dem Display agieren.
Also einmal drauf tappen und dann noch mal was machen.
Das Erste kann kein durchgängiger Touch, Swipe, sonst irgendwas sein, bedienen vom Telefon.
und so ähnlich ist es auch mit dem Fotobutton dann, dass wenn er praktisch gelockt
ist, musst du praktisch einmal drücken und dann anlocken und dann nochmal drücken,
um in die Kamera zu kommen,
damit er wahrscheinlich auch nicht immer aus Versehen im Kameramodus ist und
wenn es angelockt ist, dann ist der eine Knopfdruck halt die Kamera.
Das heißt dann, wenn man das praktisch nicht im Griff hat, dann hat man aus
Versehen immer mal ein Foto gemacht.
Was mir eh schon ständig mit Screenshots passiert, zum Beispiel bei dem Plus-Minus
beim Screenshot, also beim Beim lauter Leiser machen, dadurch,
dass die Knöpfe genau gegenüber sind, passiert mir auch immer wieder mal.
Egal, wie lange ich dieses Telefon
schon habe. Dann habe ich wieder einen Screenshot, den ich löschen muss.
Ja, und wenn man es nicht ausschaltet, macht er ja gleichzeitig von der Uhr
auch noch einen Screenshot.
Stimmt, die Uhr. Das habe ich, glaube ich, irgendwann mal ausgeschalten und
ich habe immer umgezogen, deshalb macht er das nicht mehr.
Aber diese Uhr-Screenshots habe ich auch noch von den Anfangszeiten.
Ja, neue Telefone. Müssen wir eigentlich ein bisschen noch breiter was dazu
sagen oder ist es so, wissen das eh alle?
Also hier fragt jemand, ob unserer Meinung nach, nach dem iPhone X es noch eine
richtige neue iPhone-Generation gab.
Und ich weiß nicht, ich finde das Hinzufügen von zwei neuen Buttons,
das kann man schon so ein bisschen als Generation feiern, weil es auch so ein
bisschen das User-Interface nochmal verändert.
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt zwischen dem iPhone X und dem aktuellen iPhone,
also mal diese fünf Generationen oder so, die dazwischen waren, was gab es?
Sechs, sieben.
Ja, eigentlich gab es danach direkt das Elf.
Elf, zwölf, dreizehn, vierzehn, fünfzehn, sechzehn.
Oder habe ich nicht verzählt.
Ja, wenn man die fünf dazwischen mal rauslässt, also nur vom Ten auf Sechzehn geht.
Naja, dann hast du Dynamic Island.
Ja, wobei Also keine Notch mehr.
Sondern Dynamic Island Ob das jetzt ein gutes Feature ist oder nicht sei mal dahingestellt Vom.
Interface her ist das ein großer Unterschied, ob da oben wirklich zwei zusätzliche
Stati angezeigt werden oder nicht Das haben ja alle gesagt, die das auch schon benutzt haben Dann.
Hast du halt die zwei neuen Buttons und dann hast du halt diesen ganzen Kleinkram
wie Satelliten Notruf und das ganze Gedöns halt noch Was vom USB-C,
Du hast auch USB-C, wenn man das als Feature sehen will, ja.
Das ist ein Feature.
Also allein wegen der Datentransferrate und die Geräte, die man so benutzen kann.
Das habe ich beim iPad gemerkt, so per se. Aber dass du das Gefühl hast,
da kann ich was anstecken und das wird dann in irgendeiner Form wahrscheinlich
irgendwie funktionieren. Dank des Adapters.
Genau so, wie ich es wollte.
Aber so.
Dank des Adapters.
Vielleicht sogar ohne Adapter.
Ja, aber das ist zum Beispiel etwas, was auch mir so klar geworden ist.
oder so, ah ja, alles was ich so mit USB-C an meinen Computer anschließen kann,
das ist jetzt automatisch auch für das Telefon verfügbar.
Wenn es dafür einen Treiber gibt.
Ja, fürs meiste gibt es ja so HDMI, diese ganzen normalen Dongles,
mit denen du da so Multiport, USB und so weiter machst, das funktioniert ja alles.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das, was ich meine. Und Audio-Interfaces halt auch.
Ja, aber wenn ich mein SimRacing-Lenkrad anschließe, dann passiert da gar nichts.
Wenn du dein was anschließt?
SimRacing-Lenkrad. dann passiert da gar nichts, da passiert ja schon auf dem
Mac nichts, weil es dafür keine Treiber gibt.
Ja gut, ich meine ja Sachen, die auf dem Mac funktionieren, funktionieren meistens
auch auf dem iPhone gut so und das ist definitiv ein Feature und dann hast du
natürlich, weiß ich, mittlerweile so viel schneller, höher, weiter,
was Bildschirmhelligkeit,
hier so Sachen wie ProMotion und so weiter, also ob irgendwas,
also revolutionär, ich meine auch das iPhone X fand ich jetzt nicht revolutionär, sondern evolutionär.
Ja, aber es hat zumindest das Beseitigen von dem Homebutton.
Und das Einführen der von unten nach oben Swipe-Geste als ich will auf die Homepage,
das war schon, kann man sagen,
eine revolutionäre Änderung, weil es doch deutlich das User-Interface verändert
hat. Also das finde ich, das kann man gelten lassen.
Insofern kann man sagen, nein, es gab keine Revolution, kannst noch ein paar, vier Jahre warten.
Es gab nur eine Evolution, aber es gab viel Evolution.
Es gab viel Evolution, aber keine Revolution. Das ist auch meistens besser.
Du, die Evolution hat uns weit gebracht.
Die einen sagen so, die anderen so.
Ich muss mich übrigens korrigieren, ich bin vom iPhone 11 gekommen.
Gerade nochmal hier im Apple-Vergleich nach.
7 kam mir jetzt doch selber auch ein bisschen spanisch vor.
Das 11 hatte ich vorher. Aber der Sprung war trotzdem radikal.
So lange halten ja die Batterien.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe es bestellt, morgen soll es kommen.
Okay, gut. iPhone haben wir erstmal besprochen.
Dann gab es Apple Watch und da war ich auch sofort in der Verlosung aus denselben
grundsätzlichen Erwägungen wie bei der... Ich nicht.
Wie alt ist deine aktuelle?
Bitte? Wie alt ist deine aktuelle?
Ich hatte eine Series 6.
Ich habe eine 5 sogar noch.
Ich hatte eine 7. Das war wirklich die 7.
Ich habe sogar noch eine 4, aber die will keiner haben. Aber jetzt am Arm habe
ich eine Ultra 2, aber nicht in dunkel, sondern in hell.
Weil es die ja noch nicht gab.
Es gab die ja nur in hell, aber jetzt gibt es die auch in dunkel und es scheint
die gleiche Hardware drin zu sein.
Das heißt, mit dem Update von dem WatchOS habe ich jetzt auch alles bekommen,
was sie angekündigt haben.
Ja, ich meine, die helle, ich bin nicht so für hell zu haben,
aber die sieht schon extrem anders aus als so die.
Normale Apple Watch, auch dadurch?
Ja, sie ist mir eigentlich auch zu klobig. Ich hatte das Gefühl oder zumindest
die Hoffnung, dass die meiner, weiß ich nicht,
meiner Tendenz Uhrenschaden anzutun etwas besser gewachsen ist als die normalen Apple Watches.
Und bis jetzt hat es auch gut funktioniert.
Da ist noch kein Kratzer drauf auf dem Glas.
insofern, keine Ahnung man weiß es nicht, ob eine mit rundem Glas jetzt schon
zerkratzt wäre oder nicht.
Also ich war auch hab schon längere Zeit mal überlegt, ob so ein Ultra-Ding
für mich auch noch was ist, weil mich der größere Screen gereizt hat,
aber mich hat diese Klobigkeit nicht wirklich angeturnt und insofern war ich
natürlich sehr glücklich, dass jetzt genau diese Displaygröße auch in der normalen
Apple Watch zur Verfügung steht und das ist natürlich auch schick,
also großer Screen und dann nochmal flacher geworden,
und es gab Titan, also go for it.
Also, du hast dir die Titan gegönnt auch, nicht nur die Alu?
Ja.
Zeig mal her, das interessiert mich jetzt.
Trage ich halt viele Jahre und leicht und.
Darf ich mal?
Also nachdem ich die jetzt ein halbes Jahr getragen habe, würde ich auch nicht
wieder zu einer Ultra greifen, weil,
ich glaube, das eine Feature, was nur die Ultra hat, nämlich diesen Tauchmodus
und schalte dich mal ab zwei Meter Wassertiefe automatisch in ich bin jetzt
am Tauchen und zeige jetzt Tauchtiefen an,
habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gebraucht.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich in meinem Leben auch nicht mehr brauchen.
Die Crown ist halt so, dass man sie nicht aus Versehen drückt.
Das ist so das einzige Killer-Feature, das ich wahrscheinlich wieder bei der
anderen wieder nicht schaffe, dass ich nicht ab und zu mal die Reaktivierung,
weil ich mich beim Abstützen an der Hand kannte.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Die Crown ist jetzt so, dass sie gerne mal hin und her dreht,
wenn ich das Handgelenk drehe und dann kommt dieser komische,
also auf dieser Seite, also wenn ich sie auf der Seite trage,
für die sie gedacht ist, dann geht es.
Ich habe die im Rechtshändermodus, jetzt ist sie gerade links,
aber ich wechsle da auch gerne mal den Arm, weil da wird es schwitzig drunter und unangenehm.
So und wenn ich jetzt die im Rechtshändermodus auf der rechten Seite trage,
dann ist es tatsächlich so, dass die Crown so weit übersteht,
dass wenn ich den Arm bewege, kann es passieren,
dass er dann die Crown dreht und entsprechend auch diesen völlig unsinnigen,
weiß ich nicht, was das ist für einen Modus anmacht.
Wir brauchen unbedingt so einen Jingle. First World Problems at Freakshow.
Ja vor allen Dingen First World Left Hander Problems.
Ich bin mir dessen bewusst, dass das wirklich das First World Left Hand Problems
sind, aber ich hab die halt.
Es ist aber echt auch immer wieder gut, dass du es erwähnst.
Finde ich super, weil Nachwuchs bei uns ja auch Linkshänder.
Und da merke ich erst auch wieder, wie viel Unterschied es macht bei so vielen
Sachen. Weil, letztens haben wir Pfannkuchen gemacht am Ofen,
da wo ich die Pfanne habe, wenn er den Ofen steuert, dann verbrennt er sich.
Super. Weil natürlich er von der anderen Seite an die Mittel Gas dran dreht
und dann ist der ganze Arm da.
Und das Verbrennen hat natürlich damit zu tun, dass er nicht so vorsichtig ist,
aber auch, dass er halt von der Seite ran lag, wo ich die Pfanne hingestellt
habe, weil ich Rechtshänder bin.
Das ist bei Wasserhähnen, die irgendwie den Hebel rechts haben, ist das viel schlimmer.
Ja, das hat er auch. Auch wenn man abspült, merke ich auch, dann macht er sich
immer das Wasser an über seine Hand.
Das ist ganz schön gemein.
Tim muss nochmal nachfragen mit deiner Watch. Also ich habe mir halt die Aluminium-Diamant-Schwarz
geholt, die so von der Anmutung her sowas von schwarzem Klavierlack hat.
Und ich dachte eigentlich, dass die Titan eher auch so ein bisschen angeraut
ist, so wie die Titan von der Ultra 2 hier.
Also ich habe jetzt unsere beiden Uhren jetzt einfach hier unter einer hellen
Lampe nebeneinander gehalten und es ist praktisch nicht auseinanderzuhalten.
wenn man nicht genau weiß, worauf man achtet. Also was war jetzt der Grund,
jetzt quasi auf die Totalen zu gehen? Haltbarkeit oder...
Gibt es leicht?
Na gut, Aluminium ist jetzt auch nicht als schweres Metall.
Ich glaube, die Alu ist immer noch ein paar Gramm leichter als die Titan. Ich meine ja.
Die ist garantiert nicht so schlagfest, die Alu.
Das kann gut sein.
Ja, das war ja damals immer auch so.
Das Glas oben drauf ist, glaube ich, nochmal ein anderes, auch bei der Titan.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich nicht viel nachgedacht. Ich habe einfach nochmal das
geklickt, was ich das letzte Mal hatte.
Aber es ist beides wahr.
Das Glas ist ein bisschen robuster und das Gehäuse selber ist robuster.
Und dadurch, dass es jetzt Titan ist, ist es nicht mehr so viel schwerer,
als es vorher war. Also insofern, alle drei Argumente zählen bei Tim.
Ja, ich meine, ich kaufe mir ja, also ich sehe ja auch immer die Produkte bei
Apple im Sinne von was ist der Wiederverkaufswert?
Weil diese, Naja, ich meine, der Preis ist immer nur relativ zu dem,
was du bekommst, wenn du es dann wieder abstößt.
Und da erzielst du mit hochwertigem Apple-Kram immer gute Werte.
Also umso teurer das Teil ist, umso mehr steigt auch so der Wiederverkaufswert an.
Also er steigt nicht non-linear an sozusagen. zu sagen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Baby-Beistellbettchen.
Ja, also wenn du ein Kind kriegst so und dann kaufst du dir so Gier,
was du dir sonst nie kaufst, wie so Baby-Beistellbettchen, also die man so ans
Bett, an der Seite ranmacht.
Da kannst du dann so Baby-Bay. Baby-Bay, genau. Da kannst du dir die billigen
kaufen, die es irgendwie so keine Ahnung, aus China tra-la-la, hast du nicht gesehen.
Oder du kaufst dir dann so die teuren Baby-Bay, die völlig überteuert sind. Ja.
die aber dann die geilen Features haben, die schön aussehen und so weiter.
Am Ende gebraucht, verkauft, mehr Geld dafür bekommen, als du ursprünglich bezahlt hast.
Diese Luxusartikel haben dann einfach immer so einen Reiz auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt.
Den kriegst du halt einfach nicht für das Ordinäre.
Ist natürlich bei der Uhr nicht mehr so, weil da ist die Batterie so abgegriffen.
Also die alten Uhren, da kriegst Also meine 5er hat jetzt keinerlei Wert.
Da kommt dann eine neue Batterie rein, AppleCare, Tralala, Batterietausch und
dann ist das Ding quasi eine neue Uhr.
Du kriegst eine neue Uhr und dann kannst du eine niegelnagelneue Uhr weiterverkaufen.
Also verkaufst du die jetzt selber dann, deine alte?
Entweder verkaufe ich sie oder ich mache halt so Family Hand Me Down.
Weil ich habe zum ersten Mal überhaupt dieses Apple Trade-In gemacht für meine alte.
Da gab es auch relativ viel.
Weil die war vom Display her dermaßen ramponiert. Die hättest du also nie mehr
irgendwie vernünftig losgekriegt.
Das war so nicht abgesplittert, aber es hatte also wirklich,
die obere Hälfte war total zerkratzt.
Und das ist Apple in der Tat egal beim Trade-In.
Die schreiben hin, solange, selbst Absplitterungen sind okay,
solange sie nur am Rand sind. Schreiben sie hin.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Grad der Zerkratzung ist egal. Aber sobald der Zerkratzthaken
sitzt, ziehen sie halt was ab.
Also ich habe den Maximalpreis von 125 Euro jetzt gekriegt für meine 7er mit ziemlich Akkutod.
Aber was gekostet hat? Hm?
Die mal was gekostet hat?
Was hat die frisch gekostet? 400 irgendwas? Ja.
Mir hätte es 50 gegeben bei der 5. Also ich habe zu lang gewartet.
Also wenn man das Spielchen machen will, dann muss man es rechtzeitig noch verkaufen.
Ja, 3, maximal 4 Jahre.
So das 13 Pro geht wahrscheinlich jetzt auch noch ganz okay über die Hand.
Aber das ist bestimmt auch nicht mehr so wie der Bringer. Mal abgesehen davon.
Ich habe es kurz geschaut. Das war, glaube ich, ein ganz guter Wert.
Aber ich werde das weiter verschenken. Von daher war das jetzt eh keine Option.
Ja, was war noch neu, außer größer, längerer Akku, mehr Einfallswinkel angeblich
im Display, helleres Display und Sekundenzeiger im,
Schlafmodus, hätte ich schon fast gesagt, geht jetzt auch.
Im Always-On, genau.
Der Always-On war früher, glaube ich, so weniger als eine Sekunde.
Früher war es einmal pro Minute aktualisiert und jetzt kann er einmal pro Sekunde aktualisieren.
Das heißt, man kann einen Sekundenzeiger jetzt auch im Always-On Was speziell bei so Trainingssachen.
Immer ganz gut ist.
Oder wenn man kocht oder so. Das finde ich immer nervig, wenn sich mein Telefon
ausschaltet. Wenn ich eigentlich so ein bisschen den Timer verwende, die Stoppuhr.
Die Stoppuhr schaltet sich nämlich auch normal am Telefon aus.
Und was Sie jetzt drin haben, das hat mich interessiert, weil ich da gerade
eben mit meiner Ärztin darüber diskutiert hatte.
Oh Gott, wie spricht man das richtig aus? Eine Schlafapnoe-Messung.
Schlafapnoe.
Genau, das gibt es sogar auch bei der 9er. Das ist jetzt kein 10er-Exclusive-Feature.
Es geht wohl über den Bewegungssensor, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Es ist also kein neuer zusätzlicher Sensor, der verbaut ist.
Dann würde es ja auch mit der 9er nicht gehen, sondern halt über den Bewegungssensor.
Aber die hat dann irgendwie genug...
Die Ultra 2 macht das auch und ich habe das schon im Betrieb.
Und hast du schon Warnungen bekommen? Eine richtige Warnung nicht.
Aber in der Übersicht sind sämtliche Daten unterkritisch.
Messwert, also unterhalb im Sinne von unkritisch.
Erhöht.
Also vielleicht kurz, worum geht es da überhaupt bei Schlafapnoe?
Das ist ein Krankheitsbild, was dem wenigsten Menschen bewusst ist.
Das ist während des Schlafens, setzt dann mal die Atmung aus,
aus verschiedenen Gründen, wegen irgendwie Schnarchen oder sonstigen Gründen
und das führt dann schon zu einer Menge an unangenehmen Krankheitsbildern,
wenn man das irgendwie über Jahre hat und nicht irgendwas dagegen tut.
Gut, so ganz viel kann man aber auch gar nicht tun.
Und es ist super schwer zu diagnostizieren. Warum bin ich irgendwie ständig
erkältet oder immer müde, wenn ich in der Freakshow sitze? Weil ich habe Schlafapnoe.
Naja, wenn du die Diagnosetools benutzt, die es gibt im Medizinwesen,
dann ist es nicht schwierig zu diagnostizieren.
Aber die musst du halt erstmal haben.
Die Hausärztin sagte so, das Einzige sei eigentlich so Schlaflabor.
Da müsste man dann hin und da halt irgendwie ein, zwei Nächte Probeschlafen
und dann wüsste man, was dann die Basis ist.
Nee, es gibt aber auch so Zeug, was du dir dann selber ausleihst und schlafst.
Genau, bei Ärzten kannst du dir so ein Gerät ausleihen, da hast du dann eine
monatelange Wartezeit und dann musst du das akribisch anbringen,
musst auch sicherstellen, dass du mindestens so und so viele Stunden Schlaf kriegst und so weiter.
Ist es dann so, dass man wie in der amerikanischen Popkultur als Abhilfegerät
so eine Sauerstoffmaske auf Nummer bekommt?
Das ist die eine Variante. Die andere Variante ist der sogenannte Zungenschrittmacher.
Okay.
Ja, das ist ein Gerät, was irgendwie der Zunge Stromstöße gibt,
wenn der Gaumen versucht, nach hinten zu fallen und die Luftröhre zuzumachen.
Das ist wohl was, was man da nicht so richtig merkt. Aber wenn man das lange
benutzt, dann trainiert man die Zunge eben darauf, nicht nach hinten zu fallen.
Verstörte Blicke bringen sich auch von dir.
Es geht schon wieder so in medizinische Bereiche, da muss ich mal vorsichtig sein.
Da ist mir letztens mal ein Tipp, weil ich bin ja Schnarcher auch,
dass man die Zunge so ein bisschen vorne am Gaumen einklemmt und dann durch
die Nase atmet nur und wenn du mit ein bisschen Unterdruck die vorne lässt,
dass du dann weniger schnarchst für die anderen.
Wenn es dann da so hält, aber dann sabberst du halt viel unten in den Mundraum. Aber leiser ist es dann.
Gesundheit. Danke. Auf jeden Fall muss man es jetzt einen Monat lang machen und Messwerte sammeln.
Und dann eicht sich quasi die Uhr so auf den eigenen Schlaf und auf das,
was da halt so am Handgelenk dann zuckt oder nicht zuckt.
Weil wie gesagt, Bewegungssensor ist es, was da ausgelesen wird.
Und dann wissen wir mehr und werden hier berichten. Mein erster Wert war jetzt...
Das Erste, was ich machen werde, glaube ich, ist, mit dieser Uhr mal die Nachtsand zu tragen.
Auch weil die anderen waren immer mit der Batterielaufzeit nicht so ganz den
ganzen Tag über fit. und wenn ich sie eh so selten habe, dann habe ich sie halt
lieber am Ladegerät anstatt, dass ich, wenn ich sie dann mal brauche, dass es dann geht.
Und die wird jetzt hoffentlich so gut durchhalten, dass man sie einfach mal
nachts dann trägt. Dann habe ich auch mal diese Daten. Bin ja mal gespannt.
Sie lädt ja auch schneller.
Also ich habe damit schon angefangen, seit ich das WatchOS Update drauf habe,
und naja, der Monat ist aber noch nicht rum und vor allen Dingen habe ich es
auch nicht jede Nacht geschafft, die dann zu tragen, weil dann muss man sie
ja kurz vorm Schlafen gehen aufladen.
Das dauert zwar nicht allzu lange, aber wenn man vorher einschläft, dann war es das halt.
Da gehört noch so ein bisschen Logistik dazu, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ich
finde es gut, so ein Gerät zu haben, was einen vor,
dem drohenden Tod bewahrt. Davon gehe ich jetzt mal aus. Deswegen habe ich da
jetzt Geld investiert. Ich möchte gerne, dass die mich rettet.
Du bist auch vorne im Spot praktisch immer auftauchen können.
Darauf arbeitest du quasi hin, um endlich mal in den Kino zu werden.
Tim gerettet.
So viel dazu.
Also wenn es so weiter geht, ist Apple voll die geriatrische Marke, oder?
Ja, also ich meine, ich finde ja diese ganze Ausrichtung auf Gesundheit,
das ist in der Tat eine kluge Strategie.
Und da haben sie ja bisher auch eine ganze Menge richtig gemacht.
Also das muss man ihnen schon mal lassen.
Vielleicht noch ein kurzer Nachtrag zum,
iPhone oder wollen wir erstmal das Gab es eigentlich noch andere Produkte? Ah ja, genau.
Lass mal noch über die AirPods reden. Da ist ja auch was für die alten Menschen.
Hast du da denn welche schon neue?
Da gibt es ja keine neuen.
Ja, die Vierer.
Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden.
Ich habe ja Pro.
Pro gibt es keine neue Hardware. Irgendwann ein Update.
Die Airpods sind jetzt die normalen Airpods. Die sehen jetzt anders aus.
Die sind komplett neu gemacht.
Die haben jetzt auch einen kürzeren Stummel.
Aber die haben halt auch viele Features, die jetzt bisher nur bei den Airpods Pro zu haben waren.
Aber die sind halt nach wie vor keine In-Ears.
und sie haben diese ganzen advanced Features, auf die wir gleich kommen,
nicht. Aber es gibt sie gegen Aufpreis auch mit Noise Cancellation.
Wo gemuten war es wird, ob das vielleicht nicht sogar dieselbe Hardware ist.
Hat das mal einer aufgeschraubt mittlerweile? Hat das mal einer verglichen?
Weil selbst auf den Packungen ist es wohl so, dass das ANC nur draußen als zusätzlicher
Aufkleber draufgeklebt ist, was ich bei Apple schon irgendwie weird finde.
Also dass die billigen und die die mittleren, die gleiche Hardware sind, das kann sein.
Genau, dass das ANC-Quad neu über eine Software freigeschaltet wird.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist sozusagen das Neue an Hardware und die AirPods
Pro kriegen halt eine neue Firmware und mit dieser neuen Firmware wird alles
nochmal ein bisschen toller, angeblich.
Die AirPods Pro 2, ich habe die einsau und die kriegen nämlich nichts Neues.
Nein, die sind auch nicht gut.
Nee, das ist ja...
Die sind ja deutlich schlechter auf alle Fälle.
Ich kann auch, ehrlich gesagt, AirPods, normale AirPods, also ich weiß nicht,
wenn du, dann hast du das Licht nicht gesehen.
Ich habe auch die Pro, ich habe aber die Einser Pros.
Und die knistern bei dir nicht?
Achso, jetzt verstehe ich.
Die knistern bei dir nicht?
Was heißt die knistern? Eigentlich, äh.
Wenn du nicht weißt, was ich meine, dann knistern sie.
Also der eine fängt jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen an zu rauschen, manchmal rechts.
Ah, fängt also schon an.
Okay. Ja, aber die habe ich jetzt auch schon echt lange, äh, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, da wirst du dann wahrscheinlich auch keinen Ersatz mehr kriegen,
wenn sie dann durchgehen.
Ja, also das neue Feature ist halt, dass sie die Dinger jetzt quasi als Hörgeräte
verkaufen können. Das ist schon eigentlich geil.
Und das sind ja im Prinzip auch wieder zwei Features, die zusammenspielen.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig mitbekommen habe, korrigiert mich.
Erstmal wird es einen eingebauten Hörtest geben.
Den gibt es jetzt noch nicht. Das kommt jetzt erst wahrscheinlich mit dem nächsten Dot-Release oder so.
Und dieser Hörtest, das gab es ja auch schon von Third-Party-Programmen so in mehr oder weniger gut,
spielt ja halt so Sachen vor, linkes Ohr, rechtes Ohr, verschiedene Frequenzen,
keine Ahnung, ich bin sehr gespannt, was sie da machen und damit kannst du dann
quasi Rückmeldung geben auf deinem Telefon und sagen, höre ich,
höre ich nicht, was auch immer.
mit anderen Worten, es wird vermutlich so ein paar Minuten langer Test durchgeführt
werden, an dessen Ende quasi für das Telefon die Erkenntnis steht,
in welchen Bereichen, welchen Frequenzbereichen, auf welchem Ohr du wie gut hören kannst.
Fun Fact am Rande, ich habe Hauptfach Akustik gehabt.
Ach, du weißt ja alles.
Einer der Fächer war Psychoakustik und wie man Hörtests macht.
Also wenn du was wissen willst.
Ja, also Und ich habe auch eine Hörvorschädigung von unklar was Oh.
Hast du das bei dir dann aktiviert? Also hast du ein Audiogramm wo du eine klare Lücke hast?
Weil du kannst auch jetzt schon das Ability in der B-Leafing das aktivieren Ich weiß.
Dass ich eine Lücke habe bei 4 Kilohertz um 30 dB ungefähr Und das kannst du eingeben.
Du kannst per Hand dein Audiogramm eingeben und dann kannst du das anpassen,
dass deine AirPods Pro das ausgleicht.
Schon jetzt. Das macht der Marco seit zwei Jahren.
Ich habe ungefähr 25 Jahre lang schon kein Audiogramm mehr gemacht.
Aber ich werde das tun, wenn die entsprechend das nachgerüstet haben, das Feature.
Genau, aber die machen das nur mehr convenient, das ist das Testeinbauen.
Aber du kannst ein Audiogramm, wenn du das erstellt hast, in irgendeiner Form
per Hand eingeben für linke und rechte Seite, für jede Herzzahl mit Dezibelzahlen.
Und das kannst du dann aktivieren unter,
Bedienhilfen Audio,
Anpassungen, glaube ich. Und dann gibt es unten dann eine Option,
dass du eben das Audiogramm aktivieren kannst.
Und das soll wohl sehr gut sein für die Leute, die es brauchen.
Bei mir war es jetzt so wenig bei dem Test, den ich gemacht habe,
dass ich keinen Unterschied gehört habe, weil ich wollte es mal ausprobieren vorher schon.
Aber das geht schon jetzt. Was sehr interessant ist...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich bin in Einstellungen, also in Bedienungshilfen und
dann Audio und Visuelles oder was?
Es geht um.
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Weil es ist ja nix.
Headphone Accommodations heißt es auf Englisch. Der erste Einfach.
Kopfhörer Anpassungen. Genau.
Und da drin wiederum musst du dann sagen Custom Audio Setup.
Das ist leider versteckt.
Ach so, eigene Audio Konfiguration.
Und darin kannst du ein Audiogramm angeben. Dummerweise ist es,
dass du Audiogramme ja auch mit den Apps erzeugen und die kannst du dann in
Hells abspeichern, was ja ganz okay ist als Daten.
Aber dummerweise kannst du die nicht importieren. Du kannst da komische Graphen
importieren, die Leute auf ihren Audiogramm irgendwo haben. Oder du gibst es halt per Hand ein.
Das kannst du machen. Und dann gleicht dir das jetzt schon aus.
Und die Hörgerätfunktion ist ja nur mal oben drauf.
Genau. Das heißt, es geht, ich weiß nicht, ob es mit allen AirPods geht oder nur mit den AirPods Pro.
Aber bei den AirPods Pro geht es halt auch mit, vor allem durch Transparency,
die hat wirklich auch schon so aller Hörgerät aktuell.
Ich benutze Transparency ja gerne als Gehörschutz, weil Transparency nur eine
gewisse Maximallautstärke hat und wenn du auf einem Konzert bist und es ist viel zu laut,
machst du die Dinger rein, schaltest sie auf Transparency, hast du eigentlich
das gleiche Hörerlebnis, aber es ist leiser.
Also ich hätte da gerne einen Regler, um das noch feiner zu steuern.
Aber es gibt so einen extra Knopf, auch das er sogar noch ein bisschen leiser macht.
Es gibt eine Einstellung, so ein Stück leiser gibt es. Reduced Power Sounds
irgendwo gibt es noch. Da kannst du es noch ein bisschen mehr dämpfen, als es eh schon macht.
Was ich mich frage ist, wenn du einen Hörschaden hast, dann führt der normalerweise
dazu, dass das Mapping der Frequenzen mit deinem Hirn irgendwann nicht mehr so ganz stimmt.
Und es gibt Hörgeräte, die tatsächlich auch eine Frequenzanpassung machen,
wo bestimmte Frequenzbereiche dann verschoben werden, sodass es hinterher eigentlich wieder passt.
Und ich frage mich, ob sie das auch abbilden oder ob sie einfach nur sagen,
da hört er nichts, also kriegt das lauter. Aber gut, wir werden sehen.
Ich habe jetzt gerade mal meine AirPods reingemacht, um diese Kopfhörer-Anpassung machen zu können.
Und tatsächlich, zu meiner größten Überraschung, stelle ich gerade fest,
dass in meinen Health-Daten offensichtlich schon ein Audiogramm von vor drei
Jahren abgespeichert ist.
Und du kannst es verwenden, echt?
Er bietet mir das jetzt zumindest an.
Wie bist du denn dazu gekommen?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr, aber vermutlich habe ich irgendeine andere Hörtest-App
mal ausprobiert und war mir nicht bewusst, dass sie ein fertiges Audiogramm
da reingespeichert hat.
Ja, das machen die automatisch, wenn die ein Health speichern können.
Das ist schon lange drin als Feature von Health zumindest. Wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Health.
Health heißt auch Health.
Achso, der heißt nicht wo ist oder gesund.
Heißt nicht Gesundheit.
Hatschi, bless you.
Ja, wobei da geht es jetzt irgendwie nicht weiter. Jetzt sage ich Audiogramm
verwenden und dann sagt er, schließe deine Kopfhörer an, um fortzufahren.
Meine Kopfhörer sind doch angeschlossen.
Ja, musst du irgendwie, ja.
Okay.
Und dann wie gesagt, ich muss es bei Hand eingeben, obwohl ich es in den Health-Daten
hatte. Ich musste praktisch die Health-Daten abfotografieren,
das ist ja nochmal eintippen, das ist ja blöd.
So diese Gaga-Nummer, die man ab und zu machen muss, wenn die digitalen Daten
nicht untereinander reden können.
Damit werde ich auf jeden Fall mal rumspielen. Grundsätzlich muss ich sagen,
finde ich das halt ganz cool, dass sie diesen Weg gehen.
Und jetzt gehen sie ja dann auch noch den nächsten Schritt.
Also nicht nur, dass du vom Telefon feststellen kannst, wie gut du hörst oder
in welchen Frequenzbereichen, auf welchem Ohr du wie gut hörst.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das das ist, was sie im Wesentlichen herausfinden dabei.
Nein, sondern sie sagen, sie
können dann eben diese AirPods Pro auch in richtige Hörhilfen umwandeln.
Genau, nicht Hörgeräte, sondern Hörhilfen der Unterschied ist.
Ja, und was sagt der Unterschied?
Naja, eine Hörhilfe ist halt einfach nur da, dieses Absenken und Hochziehen
von Frequenzen, die zählen, wo die halt irgendwo eingeschränkt sind,
wohingegen Hörgeräte halt wirklich diesen Medizinstatus haben.
Fragen wir doch mal eben den Unterschied. Also das waren ein,
zwei Punkte, die schon relevant waren.
Hörhilfe versus Hörgeräte.
Ja, bei dir muss ich wirklich mal das neue Gate runtersetzen.
Du bist für dich so ein Pferdeflüsterer geworden.
Eine Hörhilfe ist kein Hörgerät. Das Wichtigste zuerst.
Hörhilfen sind keine Hörgeräte. Als Hörhilfe bezeichnet man gerne sogenannte Hör- bzw.
Geräusche-Verstärker. Diese sind frei verkäuflich und kostengünstig erhältlich.
Das Grundprinzip ist mit dem eines Hörgeräts identisch.
Die Hörhilfe verstärkt ebenfalls akustische Signale. Allerdings ist ein solches
Gerät standardisiert und nur auf eine einzelne Situation ausgerichtet.
Man müsste für verschiedene Situationen mit Telefonieren, Fernsehen...
So... ...
Hörgeräte sind hochentwickelte medizinische Produkte, die in enger Zusammenarbeit
mit Hörgeräteakustikern und HNO-Ärzten entwickelt werden.
Damit stellen sie eine optimale Lösung für Patienten mit Hörschäden. Kaufen sie hier.
Ja, ja, also es ist auch nur Marketing, bla bla. Also ich meine,
Apple wird bestimmt auch hochbezahlte Akustiker am Start haben.
Aber es ist schon so, wenn du ein Hörgerät, ein tatsächlich medizinisches Hörgerät
bekommst, dass du dann auch lange schmerzhafte Sitzungen mit dem Akustiker und
mit dem Arzt hast, um die Dinge richtig einzustellen.
Also es ist nicht so, dass da nichts dran ist.
Was aber auch natürlich zu Akzeptanz, Mangel der Akzeptanz führt teilweise dann auch.
Ich habe so viele Bekanntenkreise, die haben halt irgendwann viel zu spät dann
ihr Hörgerät bekommen und dann haben sie es absichtlich nicht drin.
und das ist halt, wenn die Barrier to Entry halt so gering ist,
dass du halt einfach nur deine Ohrstöpsel halt mal reintust und dann eine Verbesserung
hast, dann ist es vielleicht auch so der Wille größer dann halt zum richtigen
Gerät zu greifen also ich halte das für eine gute Entwicklung Ja.
Auf jeden Fall schon aber ein richtiges, also es gibt ja so Leute, wo du wirklich unten,
die letzten, was sie noch so hören, zusammenkratzt und das Hörgerät versucht
irgendwie aus dem, was da um die Personen rumkommt noch so viel zusammenzubauen,
dass sie wieder ein halbwegs gutes Hörerlebnis haben und das wird sicherlich
nicht das sein, was Apple macht.
Nö, klar, und das behaupten sie aber auch nicht. Aber trotzdem,
sie holen halt alles aus dieser Technik raus.
Also als die AirPods Pro rauskamen, da habe ich also bei Leuten,
die da mit Hörgeräten unterwegs sind und die Nachteile davon auch immer problematisch
fanden, da gab es schon viel Aufmerksamkeit und es war da irgendwie schon immer so diese,
Erwartungshaltung, dass sich da mal was tut und da sind wir jetzt auf jeden
Fall einen Schritt weiter.
Was ich noch sagen wollte an der Stelle ist, ich habe mir die mittleren mit
Noise Cancellation, also die ohne In-Ear, gegönnt, weil ich habe die immer nachts drin.
Und wenn ich nachts die In-Ears drin habe, meistens nur auf einer Seite,
und wenn ich jetzt irgendwas so wie eine Erkältung oder irgendwas am Ohr habe
und so weiter, habe ich das Gefühl, dass es schlechter wird auf der Seite,
wo ich das Ding drin habe.
Will aber gleichzeitig nachts meine Podcasts und so weiter zum Einschlafen hören und das nicht machen.
Deswegen habe ich mich jetzt mal dazu entschlossen, dass ich die ohne Seal nehme
für die Nachtaktion und mal schauen, ob mir das da hilft.
Ob das da besser ist. Deshalb habe ich die und ich finde sie toll.
Also ich finde, die klingen gut.
Die machen auch eine gute Noise Cancellation. Die machen natürlich weniger Noise
Cancellation. Allein weil sie nicht so gut absiegeln.
Aber die sind, also machen mir Spaß an der Stelle.
Und das einzige Feature, dass ich komplett vermisse von meinen AirPods Pro 2
an der Stelle ist und gerade auch beim Einschlafen ist der Lautstärke-Swipe,
weil das eben ohne irgendwie ans Telefon zu müssen,
praktisch einfach mal stufenweise die Lautstärke etwas leiser oder etwas lauter machen zu können,
ist für mich so der, also das ist das Killer-Feature eigentlich und das ist
ja jetzt nervig, gerade für die,
die ich jetzt fürs Schlafen verwenden will, da muss ich halt immer zum Telefon
hindatschen und dann nochmal lauter leiser justieren, bis es halt da ungefähr
eingestellt ist und das kann ich halt nicht.
Kannst du auch mit der Uhr machen.
Genau, die trägst du ja sowieso immer nachts.
Stimmt, die trage ich ja demnächst. Meine aktuelle Uhr kann es übrigens gar nicht mehr.
Also die kann praktisch, wenn ich Audio auf meinem Telefon höre,
hat die Uhr überhaupt keine Chance mehr, da was einzustellen.
Weder Play, Pause noch sonst irgendwas, warum auch immer.
Aber ich werde die auch neu aufsetzen. Die alte Uhr wird nicht umgezogen.
Die wird einfach nur entsorgt, glaube ich.
Star Wars Schrottpresse.
Was interessant ist, auch die Hülle ist ein bisschen anders.
So, also die Hülle ist ein bisschen kleiner als bei den AirPods Pro, was ganz nett ist.
Es ist am Kabel gespart auch. Kein Ladekabel dabei. Beim AirPods Pro sind noch USB-C Ladekabel dabei.
Wenn man die C-Hülle hat. Ich habe noch die Lightning-Hülle.
Ich auch, aber jetzt nicht mehr, weil das ist das einzige Gerät,
das bei mir dann noch Lightning wäre nach diesem Kauf.
Also habe ich mir noch eine leider unbedruckte dann, weil du kannst leider nicht
eine gravierte USB-C die Hülle haben.
Ich kann dir mal zeigen, so schlimm ist es nicht. Die war mal bedruckt.
Man sieht gar nichts mehr.
Bei mir sieht man es noch.
Da ist noch ein Schatten der Bedruckung, aber man kann es nicht mehr erleben.
Und unser Haushalt hat relativ viel von diesen Geräten, weil mehrere Personen
solche haben und auch schon diverse,
AirPods Pro leider das Ableben erlebt haben und deshalb haben wir mehr Hüllen als als Hörer.
Ich bin mit meinen Pro ja unglücklich. Grundsätzlich finde ich die super vom
Klang her, aber egal welche dieser,
Silikonaufsätze ich halt nehme, sie wandern aus meinen Ohren raus.
Nicht so, dass sie rausfallen, aber so, dass sie halt diesen perfekten Ziel verlieren.
Hast du schon im Drittmarkt geschaut? Hast du schon im Drittmarkt geschaut?
Ich habe noch nicht im Drittmarkt geschaut.
Ich kenne das Problem und es ist komplett durch den Drittmarkt gelöst worden.
Das sind halt diese schaumigen Aufsätze, da kriegst du für wenig Geld,
kriegst du die bei Amazon in tausend Formen und Farben.
die nutzen sich dann auch irgendwann mal ab, aber die sitzen einfach Bombe,
da fällt überhaupt gar nichts raus also so null, überhaupt nicht nada, rien,
der einzige Nachteil von diesen Dingern ist dass sie den AirPods im Case manchmal
ein wenig Ärger machen, also dadurch dass die etwas voluminöser sind,
Apple hat leider dieses Case so gebaut,
dass diese Pods brauchen,
Spiel, um richtig zu sitzen. Und wenn die oben durch diesen Schaumstoff ein
bisschen weggedrückt werden, dann kann es sein, dass du keinen Kontakt hast
und dann passiert es manchmal, dass du das Case aufmachst und dann ist einer nicht geladen.
Aber das nehme ich so hin, das ist nicht oft ein Problem und von daher bin ich da sehr glücklich mit.
Da muss man einfach mal was kaufen, aber es gibt da diverse Aufsätze,
die viel besser funktionieren als die von Apple, zumindest für mich.
Ja, es ist halt nämlich schon wirklich nervig, weil die fallen halt nicht raus.
Das ist also überhaupt nicht das Problem, sondern es ist halt einfach nur der
Bass ungefähr nur noch zur Hälfte da.
Und das halt nach einer Minute ist das soweit.
Und dann denkst du, du bist ständig wieder am Nachdrücken und so,
wo ist mein Bass hin? Ach, da war er wieder.
Ich kenne das, ich kenne das aber nicht nach fünf Minuten, sondern so nach einer
Dreiviertelstunde oder so.
Bass, Bass, wir brauchen Bass.
Ja, aber da schaue ich doch gleich mal auf Amazon.
Beziehungsweise, woran ich es dann merke, ist, dass das Noise-Canceling aufhört
gut zu sein. Dann drückt man sie wieder rein und dann ist wieder Ruhe.
Übrigens, die AirPods Pro haben sich auch geupdatet. Übrigens,
die Max. Die AirPods Max Pro.
Ja, mit neuen Farben.
Und USB-C.
Und immer noch der beschissenen Hülle und immer noch das komplette schwere Gewicht.
Ich fand die ja ganz wertig, so
von dem mal aufhaben, aber sie sind dann einfach zu schwer für auf Dauer.
Ich finde die hässlich, aber gut, vielleicht habe ich sie auch noch nie in real life gesehen.
Ich habe sie in real life gesehen, sie sind hässlich. Ja,
ich weiß nicht, also ich bin, die AirPods Pro, würde ich sagen,
also wenn du mir jetzt so die Apples Produkte der letzten 10 Jahre unter die
Nase setzt, mit was war das beste Produkt, was Apple rausgebracht hat,
dann wäre das mein Platz 1.
Ja, mir auch.
Schlägt alle Macs, alle iPhones. Die AirPods Pro. Die AirPods Pro sind für mich
das wichtigste Device und die habe ich immer bei mir und allein deshalb sind
sie auch schon so wertvoll.
Und ich habe auch ein Backup-Setup, genau wie du. Man kann da nicht genug von haben.
Also definitiv top. Noch einen Nachtrag habe ich zu machen und zwar bei den Freunden von iFixit.
Wird ja immer alles sofort ausführlich untersucht und auseinandergenommen.
Das haben sie natürlich auch mit den neuen iPhones gemacht. Ich habe das jetzt
nur bei dem iPhone 16, nicht beim Pro gesehen.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch schon.
und es ist ja erstaunlich, dass in den letzten Jahren die iPhones einen erhöhten
Reparability-Score kriegen.
Also die waren ja mal ganz unten, weil da alles total verklebt war und alle
schreien ja dann immer, dass Apple ja hier geplante Obsoleszenz betreibt und so.
Passt ja immer super ins Feindbild.
Und jetzt hat iFixit einen 7 von 10 Reparability-Score vergeben,
was schon relativ groß ist. Das hat auch viel damit zu tun.
Das ist großzügig bei iFixit.
Ja, aber sie haben dann irgendwie auch gezeigt, wie man das Ding aus,
du kannst es mühelos auseinandernehmen, aufklappen, das war schon beim letzten
Modell, glaube ich, so klappst richtig das Display wie so eine Tür auf,
kommst mit kleinen Schräubchen an alles ran, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Das Einzige, was aber immer noch so ein Nerv war, war halt die verklebte Batterie.
Um Verklebungen zu lösen, ist immer schwierig. Und da gibt es jetzt was Neues.
Sie haben jetzt einen Kleber angebracht für diese Batterie, der sich durch das
Anlegen von Spannung auflöst.
Das heißt, du hast da so einen kleinen Schnupsi, da klemmst du 9 oder 12 Volt
Spannung dran, aus dem Labornetzteil, kleine Batterie, was auch immer.
und Minus an Masse vom Gehäuse und das musst du so, 10 Sekunden oder 30 Sekunden
diese Spannung da dran halten und dann,
löst sich dieser Kleber von der Batterie ab und danach kannst du einfach die
Batterie mit dem Saugnapf flups, also auch ohne Saugnapf, du drehst das Ding
um und fällt die Batterie raus.
Irre. Also ich habe die physikalische Erklärung nur begrenzt mitgenommen, aber im Wesentlichen.
Na hoffentlich nicht Hitze.
Es ist nicht Hitze, es ist irgendeine, durch die Spannung ändern sich halt irgendwelche
Moleküle und dann verlieren die irgendwie ihre Adhesion und dann war es das.
Super.
Also, da habe ich nicht schlecht gestaunt, dass es so ein Produkt überhaupt
gibt Also, dass da jemand so dran rumforscht und sowas auch erfindet Also,
das hatte ich nun überhaupt nicht auf dem Zeiger, aber offensichtlich Also,
du kannst nicht den Strom wieder wegnehmen und dann klebt es,
also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe ist das so one way,
dann nimmst du halt einen neuen Strip Es.
Kehrt sich wohl um aber es klebt nicht mehr, es verklebt nicht mehr dasselbe
wie vorher, also insofern, man sollte es nicht tun Also Polarisierung ändern
macht das Ding wieder aktiv, aber es braucht wohl mehr dazu,
wenn man es anbringt zum ersten Mal.
Aber ein zweiter Nachtrag und zwar zur Uhr nochmal.
In dem neuen WatchOS gibt es jetzt auch diese App, um Ebbe und Flut anzuzeigen.
Das fand ich ehrlich gesagt auch ganz cool.
Allerdings gibt es kein Widget dazu. Das habe ich ja überhaupt gar nicht verstanden.
Zu welchem?
Zur Ebbe und Flut App auf der Watch. Es gibt diese Gezeiten App.
Ach die gibt es jetzt serienmäßig?
Ja. Ach.
Echt? Oh.
Ich hatte da bisher immer eine Drittanbieter-App.
Nur auf der Watch.
Da wollte ich euch auch noch was fragen. Der Blutsauerstoff ist ja in Amerika abgeschafft worden.
Ist der in Deutschland einfach noch normal verfügbar? Habt ihr den am Start?
Das ist ein USA-Thema. Also nicht der Blutsauerstoff ist abgeschafft worden,
sondern die Detektion des Blutsauerstoffs.
In Amerika haben wir keinen Sauerstoff im Blut mehr.
Weil ich hab nämlich, Nämlich, es war schwer auf der Webseite,
das gut zu finden und irgendwo am Ende habe ich dann so eine Seite gefunden,
wo die Uhr sagt, was in welchen Ländern verfügbar ist.
Die war ganz tief versteckt irgendwo und da war schon, in Deutschland geht's.
Mein Problem ist natürlich, ich habe einen AMI-Account. Die Frage ist,
ob ich diese App irgendwie so auf die Uhr bringe, wie ich es denn gerne hätte.
Ich habe auch noch einen deutschen Account, deswegen wird es schon irgendwie
gehen. Aber das interessiert mich schon auch.
Wenn man so ein bisschen liest, wie das mit Apple Intelligence ist und das funktioniert
rückwärts, sprich du bist nicht in Ami-Land, dann müsste es eigentlich funktionieren.
So wie Apple Intelligence, du bist nicht in Europa, dann müsste es eigentlich funktionieren.
Aber gut, mal gucken.
War das der Nachtrag zum Telefon, den du machen wolltest, Tim, vorher schon? oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon. In der Liste ist der so drin.
Ja. Genau. Das war der Nachtrag. Ja, ansonsten ist viel angekündigt worden mit
Intelligenz, die nicht da ist.
Mhm. Und an einer lustigen Folie mit Sprachen, die nächstes Jahr alle unterstützt
werden und es war kein Deutsch drauf.
Doch, Deutsch Deutsch war drauf, nur halt nicht in Deutschland.
Nee, nee. Es war Deutsch nicht drauf. Auf der Folie. Und drei Wochen später
sind sie, oder zwei Wochen später, sind sie zurückgerudert und haben gesagt,
ach ja, die war nicht vollständig, das haben wir nur vergessen.
Achso, gut, ich hab später dann geguckt.
Aber es war auf der Folie nicht drauf.
Wollen wir da überhaupt über Software reden?
Warum nicht?
Über das iOS 18 selber? Weil wir haben es halt nicht auf die Liste geschrieben,
zum einen, und zum anderen sondern, ja, ist halt hier eine Frage,
weil ich habe, also was mich gewundert hat, die Tastaturen machen bei mir alle
eine deutsch-englisch gemischte Tastatur auf einmal und ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich das mag.
Aber glaube ich auch noch nicht so richtig neu, dass die gemischt sind.
Also ja, so ein bisschen.
Gab es das vorher auch schon?
Ja, du konntest vorher zumindest sagen, ich will, dass die Tastatur so aussieht,
aber trotzdem die andere Sprache als Auto-Vervollständigung hat.
Weil ich hatte halt zwei verschiedene vorher und jetzt habe ich eine und die
hat so ein D-E-E-N unten an der Tastatur.
Also das ist praktisch wirklich jetzt ein getrenntes Setting,
ob ich Trend einstelle oder zusammen.
Und da bei mir eh Deutsch, Englisch immer blöd korrigiert in beide Richtungen,
habe ich es jetzt mal so gelassen. Aber ich habe halt nichts dazu gefunden eigentlich,
was es jetzt sein sollte.
Ja, Englisch und Deutsch. Deutsch und Englisch. Also es sind immer noch zwei Tastaturen.
Beide sagen D, E, N und die Konfiguration ist halt unterschiedlich, wo die Buchstaben sind.
Also er macht schon beide, er zeigt mir auch beide an.
Aber es ist was anderes. Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Einstellungen in den Settings.
Ne, aber das gibt es schon länger. Also ich habe schon vor längerer Zeit irgendwann
die Englisch-Tastatur mit Querts quasi eingestellt, damit ich nicht dieses,
wo ist das Z und das Y und wo sind die ganzen anderen Sachen, dass ich das nicht habe.
Also quasi deutsche Tastatur-Layout mit englischer Sprachvervollständigung.
Das gibt es schon länger.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht zeigen sie es jetzt erst an oder irgendwie sowas.
Okay. Na gut, dann mal iOS 18, oder? Oder wir kommen ja von den Telefonen.
Ja, genau. Gibt's da was? Also ich hab mir ehrlich gesagt gar nichts zu notiert bisher.
Naja, ich mein, eigentlich haben wir das ja auch schon mal durchgeritten.
Jetzt gibt's jetzt keine größeren, neuen Erkenntnisse.
Eher so unter dem Aspekt mit, jetzt hab ich's auch benutzt und funktioniert überhaupt was.
Die Passwort-App zum Beispiel, die gefällt mir gut. Das klappt bei mir ganz
nett alles. Die finde ich ein bisschen schicker, wie die Passwörter Autocompleten,
weil er jetzt so ein kleines Icon anzeigt, was es denn für eine Webseite ist,
was er dann denkt, was es ist.
Das fühlt sich alles ein bisschen besser an und ist auch ein bisschen zentralerer Ort.
Ja, ich finde es besser, dass man jetzt nicht mehr wissen muss,
dass man in der Safari-App irgendwo in den Einstellungen dann auch die Passwörter
rausfinden kann, sondern dass es da einen Ort gibt, wo die Passwörter sind und
das heißt auch so und ist ganz offensichtlich ein First Class Citizen. Absolut.
Also mich freut das sehr, weil es gab ja Passwort, wie heißt das Original nochmal?
One Password?
Genau, die Keychain Access. So hieß ja diese App schon immer.
Auf Mac?
Ja, als die Keychain eingeführt wurde, wurde auch dieses Keychain Access eingeführt.
Richtig.
Oder auf Deutsch Schlüsselbundverwaltung.
Genau, Schlüsselbohrverwaltung und das ist...
Das gibt es schon seit, dumm, ich glaube, das gab es schon länger, als du auf dem Mac bist.
Ja, das gab es vor 10.
Das war vor 10, das war auf macOS 9 und vielleicht sogar schon bei macOS 8.
Da bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher, ob das jetzt ein 8 oder 8.5 oder 9er Feature war.
Das war gar kein Next Feature.
Es hat nur noch nicht gesüngt damals.
Nee, den ganzen iCloud, Mumpitz und so weiter gab es nicht, deswegen war es
halt auch so ein bisschen von begrenzter Natur. Tour, aber ich meine,
wir reden hier von 1900 und 98, 98 irgendwie sowas.
Ah, okay, das erklärt auch die beschissene API.
Es war eine Carbon-App wirklich mal. Die UI, die du siehst, ist eine Carbon-App von Mac OS 8, 9 oder so.
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist die API eine Carbon-App. Also das ist ja so ganz, ganz schlimm.
Warum muss alles mit Krypto immer ganz fürchterliche APIs haben?
Ich verstehe es nicht, aber egal.
Ich kann mal kurz hier die Intelligenz fragen.
Mac OS including,
the Keychain Access App. Sowas kann man ja immer ganz gut fragen.
Mac OS 8.6 1999. Okay, dann lag ich ja nicht ganz falsch.
Und da haben die das eingebaut und ich habe das damals total gefeiert und mich immer gewundert,
warum nicht alle alle sofort alles stehen und liegen lassen und sowas auch einbauen
und dann ging das ja mit dem Web erst so richtig los und es hat einfach ewig gedauert,
aber man hatte halt auch schon auf dem alten macOS in gewisser Hinsicht ein Komfort Level für,
Passwortmanagement,
was irgendwie alles andere total überstiegen hat und dann ist es aber so stiefmütterlich
behandelt worden und ich würde sagen,
jetzt erst mit einer ausgewiesenen Passwort-App auf allen Plattformen,
haben sie den Level erreicht und teilweise auch sogar Features von One Password
in den Schatten gestellt, weil sie jetzt einfach auch ein paar Sachen eingebaut
haben, die so One Password so nicht hat.
Was denn?
Naja, zum Beispiel haben sie, du kannst so ein Menu-Icon einschalten jetzt auf dem Mac,
um Passwörter direkt zuzugreifen, so ein Menu-Bar-Icon.
Und dann machen sie so Sachen wie, sie zeigen dir die letzten Passwörter, die du angelegt hast.
Also klar so dieses, ich habe irgendwo gerade ein Passwort angelegt und dann
wird es wieder nicht richtig ausgefüllt, weil die Webseite irgendwie falsche
Domänen und registrieren ist was anderes als einloggen und so weiter.
Du weißt ja, die Webseiten machen die ganze Zeit immer alles falsch. Falsch.
Und auch irgendwie benennen sie ihre Formularfelder falsch, dass es nicht das
Richtige auswählt und dann kommt wieder so eine Webseite, die im selben User
Interface Login und Registrierung macht, wo ich dann komplett an die Denke gehe.
Es geht noch viel schlimmer. Es gibt so ein,
Dienstleister, der irgendwie Login Management macht und es gibt für Ladesäulen,
Betreiber, also nicht die Ladesäulenbetreiber, sondern die Zahlungsabrechner,
gibt es halt eine White-Label-App-Lösung, die die benutzen können,
um dir zu ermöglichen, dass du...
Und es geht immer über dieselbe Domain von diesem Dienstleister und nicht von dem App.
Es gibt mehrere Apps, die über die gleiche Domain laufen und du versuchst dich
ständig mit dem falschen Passwort anzumelden.
Sehr gut. Loser. Genau, so eine Sache.
Aber allein dieses Problem, eben hast du noch in der Registrierung irgendwie
dein Passwort erzeugen lassen, dann ist das aber irgendwie nicht der richtigen
Domain zugeordnet, dann willst du dich,
Kurz danach einloggen und dann so, wo ist das scheiß Passwort?
So, und dann hast du halt mit diesem MenuBar-Item, hast du quasi das recently
created Passwort dann auch schnell im Zugriff.
Und eine zweite kleine Sache, es gibt vielleicht noch weitere,
aber du hast ja explizit auch WLAN-Passwörter, werden ja als Kategorie aufgeführt.
Kannst jedes antippen und kannst dir dann auch gleich auch automatisch dafür
den QR-Code erzeugen lassen, mit dem sich dann andere einloggen.
Also du kannst quasi WLAN raussuchen und sagen, hier, scan mal, hast du.
Also endlich, weil dieses Ding funktioniert nicht immer mit dem Sharen.
Selbst unter iPhones ist das teilweise sinnvoll.
Und vor allem, wenn du Leute hast, die halt auf alternativen Betriebssystemen unterwegs sind.
A, haben die dieses Feature schon lange wenigstens in die andere Richtung.
So, deshalb kannte ich das auch schon. Und B, hast du halt wirklich sonst keine
Möglichkeit, denen das Passwort zu geben.
Großartig. Also ich habe einen ausgedruckt von der Fritzbox an der Wand deswegen.
per Hand, damit wenigstens meine Gäste das machen können. Aber das muss man ja aktiv machen.
Und hier kann man es einfach mit jedem Passwort irgendwie machen.
So hinhalten, fertig. Überwillig.
Was ich lustig finde, ist, dass Sie jetzt versuchen, wirklich diese neue Passwörter ab,
irgendwie in den Markt zu kriegen. Und wenn du versuchst, die Schlüsselbundverwaltung
aufzumachen, gibt es direkt mal einen Requester, wo steht,
Passwörter in der neuen App, Passwörter verwalten, bla bla bla wollen Sie und
dann zwei Buttons Passwort eröffnen, Schlüsselbundverwaltung eröffnen.
Das ist aber nicht neu. Das haben sie schon für ein paar andere Apps auch schon
gemacht, diese aus Fäden.
So ein bisschen. Das ist so ein bisschen, die haben die App doch mitgeliefert,
dass du einen Ort hast, wo du es findest.
Sie hatten in der letzten OS-Version den Requester schon drin,
der hat dich aber zu Safari verwiesen.
Ja, ich überlege, was ist noch unter Utilities? Gibt es noch mehr Drucker oder
so ein Scheiß? Macht das auch?
Also auf jeden Fall glaube ich, mit iOS 18 und MacOS 15 haben sie mit dieser
Passwort-App jetzt ein Level erreicht, wo man sagen kann, nimm das einfach.
Du musst dir jetzt auch kein One-Passwort oder Keypass oder was auch immer kaufen,
installieren, sondern du kannst einfach mit Bordmitteln korrekt Passwörter verwalten
und natürlich auch Passkeys verwalten.
Jetzt wird es nur noch mal Zeit, dass die Webseiten ein bisschen kooperativer
werden, weil teilweise machen sie es einem einfach auch unnötig schwer.
Oh ja, Talking About unnötig schwer, da fällt mir natürlich noch was ein.
Was ich ja auch gemacht habe ist, wenn man sich ein iPhone kauft,
du wirst das dann auch ab morgen tun dürfen, na?
Umziehen.
Migration.
Hatte ich jetzt schon sehr lange nicht mehr.
Ich hatte es gerade erst mit dem iPad.
Ja, aber beim iPhone, weißt du, ist es noch mal eine andere Nummer.
Weil da hast du Apps drauf, die hast du auf dem iPad nicht drauf.
Du weißt schon, auf welche Branche ich jetzt hinaus möchte.
Finanz.
Und Gesundheit. Bank.
Banküberfall.
Banküberfall, genau.
Und Krankenkassen bei mir auch.
Die sind auch ähnlich. Anstrengend. Und Steuerkram. Und Freischaltungs,
wie PIN, Fototan, hast du nicht gesehen, wie sie alle heißen.
Und man hat das ja schon wieder irgendwie komplett vergessen,
weil ja mittlerweile sogar so Tools wie Signal irgendwie eine Migration überleben.
Ja, aber Telegram nicht.
Oh, bei… Doch, Telegram auch.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Er hat den QR-Code nicht gescannt, der dazu vorgesehen ist.
Und die konnten mir auch nicht weiterhelfen, weil sie sich nicht vorstellen
konnten, dass das Problem auf ihrer Seite liegt.
Ja, dann müssen sie nochmal hier und dann müssen sie es anders halten und so weiter.
Also ich habe mir jetzt nicht zu jedem Tool Notizen gemacht,
um das mal gleich dazu zu sagen, weil ich auch in dem Moment so ein bisschen
selber erstmal wieder daran erinnert wurde, so, ah ja genau,
das Problem, das kommt jetzt auch wieder.
Aber Leute, wirklich, liebe Banken, es ist jetzt 2024.
Und Krankenversicherung.
Und Krankenversicherung, aber ihr hattet doch jetzt so viel Zeit.
Ich habe jetzt seit drei Jahren kein Telefon mehr migriert.
Was ist kaputt bei euch? Was ist das Problem?
Also wirklich, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Also ich versuche gerade mal so ein paar Details zu machen, aber das geilste
war wirklich, war es die Commerzbank,
oder Sparda ging diesmal sogar halbwegs irgendwie.
Bei denen bin ich beiden das nicht.
Ich bin bei beiden.
Ich nenne jetzt mal gar keine Namen, weil es ist eigentlich auch egal.
Ihr wisst schon, ihr seid alle gemeint. Ihr seid alle gemeint.
Aber dann so eine Nummer zu machen wie, ja, um jetzt diesen Umzug irgendwie
zu machen, dann musst du jetzt nur noch diesen QR-Code scannen.
Ja, aber womit? Bis ich dann gemerkt habe, mit einer anderen App auf demselben Telefon.
Nichts einfacher als das. Ein QR-Code, den ich mit einer App,
die auf demselben Telefon ist, scannen soll, um das dann irgendwie abzuschließen.
Wie machen normale Menschen das? Das ist doch eine unmöglich lösbare Aufgabe.
Kann man das Telefon nicht in ein Faxgerät reinschieben und sich das selbst faxen?
Ich hab natürlich ein Screenshot gemacht, das hinten in meine Fotos reinsinken
lassen und dann auf dem Mac mir den QR-Code angezeigt und es dann gemacht so,
aber die Reifen durch die man da springen muss nur um sowas billiges wie ich
ziehe jetzt auf ein neues Telefon zu machen,
vor allem wenn man sieht wie viele andere Banking-Apps, die nicht aus Deutschland kommen,
das einfach so mühelos machen, so ja gib mal das ein, gib mal deinen PIN ein,
fertig dich. Bumm, bumm, bumm. Habe ich alles migriert.
Also ich habe so super Anxiety vor diesem Umzug, weil es ist schon so lange
her, dass ich irgendwas wieder vergesse.
Der Tipp ist, alte Telefon so ein, zwei Wochen, drei Wochen rumliegen.
Ja. Aber das reicht halt auch nicht.
Doch.
Weil wenn ich was wirklich vergessen habe, dann sind die drei Wochen nicht genug.
Das passiert dann nicht.
Aber das ist die richtige Strategie. Ich habe jetzt mein altes zu früh gelöscht.
Ich dachte, ich wäre schon durch. Und dann kam mir irgendwie die DHL-Postbank
irgendwie, nicht Postbank, DHL und PostApp, wo man ja so eine,
so eine Karte zugeschickt bekommt, auf der sich so ein perfekter Barcode drauf
befindet, der einfach nur so einen Zahlenstring kodiert, ja. Das ist ihre Security.
Das schicken sie dann per Post zu. So, dann kennst du das mit dieser App ein.
Also einfach die Zahl, ja, die könnte ich auch mit Copy und Paste da reinmachen.
Nein, es muss unbedingt davon kommen. Und dann mach ich halt diese App auf und
dann so, ja, irgendwie bin ich irgendwie keine Ahnung, was ist deine Postnummer?
Ich so, ja, Postnummer, kein Problem, kann ich dir sagen. Ja,
nee, da musst du jetzt auf der
alten, auf dem alten Telefon musst du jetzt irgendwie die App aufmachen.
Wozu das denn? Ja, alternativ kannst du auch deine Karte scannen,
die ich natürlich nicht mehr rumliegen habe, weil es ist einfach nur so ein fucking Barcode.
Ja, nee, dann geht das nicht, dann muss das per Post nochmal neu zugeschickt werden.
Ich meine, wer denkt sich so einen Scheiß aus? Wo ist denn da die Security?
Wer erhält für solche Prozesse Geld überwiesen, um diese umzusetzen?
Apropos, haben wir noch einen SIM-Card-Slot eigentlich oder nicht mehr? Oh, ich habe vergessen.
Über ihr SIMs zu sprechen. Können wir gleich noch nachholen.
Machen wir gleich, genau. Guter Punkt. Das brauche ich auch noch zur Migration.
Wie ist denn mit dieser komischen Steuer-ID-App?
Oh, die habe ich letztens aktiviert vor einem Jahr.
Welche Steuer-ID-App?
Ich weiß noch, dass ich da extra zum Finanzamt hin bin und das Telefon vorzeigen musste und...
Steuer-ID-App?
Da gibt es irgendeine App um...
Der Ausweis-App habe ich.
Oder die Ausweis-App, genau.
Die musste mir auch einen Brief schicken. Die hat mir nämlich einen Brief geschickt
eine Woche später. Und den musste ich irgendwie da rein und jetzt habe ich das
auf dem Telefon so weit aktiv.
Stimmt. Die Ausweis-App, um dann den Ausweis zu benutzen um irgendwas mit Steuerdings zu machen.
Und eine Bundes-ID, glaube ich.
Aber das kannst du ja jederzeit mit deinem Perso wieder neu aufsetzen, dafür ist es ja da.
Mein Perso ist abgelaufen.
Ja gut, dann hat das ja auch nicht so funktioniert.
Stimmt, was du machen musst, ist die ich musste die ID oder die PIN von dem
Perso rücksetzen lassen.
Aha.
Und dazu musst du zum Amt gehen.
Ja, ich muss eh zum Amt gehen, weil bei meinem Perso ist der Chip gebrochen.
Ich kann das Ding gar nicht.
Anderes Problem. Aber kriege ich mal einen Termin in Berlin dafür.
Das dauert ja alles ewig.
Das ist in kleinen Gemeinden übrigens Knorke.
Ja, aber deswegen ziehe ich jetzt nicht aufs Land. Das reicht alleine als Druckmittel nicht.
Das ist doch so schön blau bei euch.
Ja, Esem, genau. Ich habe ja O2 und da erzählt, Erstmal muss ich sagen,
grundsätzlich diese ganze Migration, dafür was da alles mittlerweile so versammelt
ist auf diesem Gerät, lief das alles ganz schön seidig und auch ziemlich schnell durch.
Also das war sowas von unproblematisch.
Im Wesentlichen.
Ausnahme Banking-Apps. Das war wirklich. Und Post.
Das war das Einzige, was so ein bisschen so, ja okay gut, das ist jetzt so ein Test.
Ich glaube, die Techniker-Krankenkassen-App wird mich dazu zwingen,
bei denen wieder nachzufragen, ob sie mir nicht nochmal so einen Brief mit so
einer Nummer checken können.
Okay, ja, Krankenkassen muss ich nochmal checken. Da habe ich aber irgendwie
gar nichts Wichtiges drauf.
Ich finde allerdings, ich muss ja jetzt alle fünf Jahre zum Optiker,
um meinen Führerschein für bestimmte Klassen dann auch weiterhin gültig zu machen,
damit man so große LKW fahren darf und so.
Hast du große LKW auf deinem Führerschein?
Ja, so siebeneinhalb Tonnen halt.
Achso, das ist nicht groß.
Also kein C, sondern das Größte, was man mit B fahren darf. Der alte...
Ich finde, wenn man in der Lage ist...
seine Banking-Apps zu migrieren, dann sollte einem das einfach erlassen werden.
Ja, aber das hat ja nichts damit zu tun, wie gut du gucken kannst.
Egal. Ich will einfach irgendein Payback haben. Ich will irgendeinen anderen
Behördengang dann nicht mehr kriegen, wenn ich irgendwie unter deutschen Banken
so zu leiden habe. Die stecken doch alle unter einer Decke.
Ja, oder zwei Jahre extra TÜV oder also irgendwas.
Ja, oder zehn Freitermine in der Berliner Behördenlandschaft.
Boah, das jetzt, jetzt, jetzt hört man nicht Größos. Ich kann meine Banking-Apps migrieren.
Verstehst du? Ich bin eine Minderheit. Minderheiten müssen geschützt werden.
Freitermine in Berlin, jetzt hört man nicht zum Größos hier.
Anyway, ESEM. So, dann erzählt mir das Telefon, dass die ESEM,
die ich von O2 installiert habe, nicht migrierbar ist.
Ja, sind die ja meistens nicht.
Ich fand die Information gut, dass es eine offenbar migrierbare ESEM gibt.
Ich weiß bloß nicht ganz genau, was die Eigenschaft einer ESIM ist,
dass sie migrierbar ist.
Wahrscheinlich ein Haken in der Datenbank beim Provider.
Wahrscheinlich eine API beim Telekom Anbieter, der diesen Migrationsvorgang,
automatisiert vom Telefon durchführen lassen kann.
Weil es wäre ja ein leichtes, dass sich das Telefon gegenüber O2 mithilfe der
ESIM durch Berechnung von Krypto Zahlen,
quasi erlaubt zu sagen, hallo, ich bin's, der rechtmäßige Betreiber,
das rechtmäßige Betreiber-Telefon von dieser eSIM.
Kannst du mal auf einem anderen Telefon jetzt automatisch eine neue eSIM einspielen
oder kannst du mir einen QR-Code liefern, mit dem ich quasi bei dem neuen Telefon
automatisch die eSIM laden kann. Weil das ist ja alles, was fehlt.
Es war für mich jetzt kein großes Problem. Ich konnte das ja ja auf der Webseite
machen. Bei o2online.de, bla bla bla.
Wenn man sich das fünfte Mal einloggt, dann darf man auch wieder in seinen persönlichen
Bereich rein, der dann in 80 Prozent der Fälle derzeit irgendwie nicht lädt.
Und wenn man dann noch genug Hive Intelligence mitbringt, so wie ich,
zu ahnen, in welchem dieser kryptischen Menüs sich das jetzt befindet,
also ist das jetzt ESIM konfigurieren oder ESIM verwalten oder E-SIM-Namensänderungen und so weiter.
Also es gibt ja da so verschiedene Versteckspielchen, die du noch machen kannst.
Also wenn du das dann gecheckt hast in welchem Ding, dann kann ich mir da auch
eine neue E-SIM klicken.
Das ist ja das Schöne an meinem Tarif, deswegen bin ich ja bei O2,
bevor ihr mir jetzt wieder alle mit Deutsche Telekom kommt.
Ich habe auf meinem fucking Tarif einfach 10 kostenlose E-SIMs und es ist geil.
Da stehe ich total drauf.
Und deshalb hast du auch eh SIMs und keine normale SIM. Oder warum nutzt du
den SIM-Slot nicht von deinem Telefon?
Wieso sollte ich das?
Ich habe immer so Anxiety. Ich habe diesen SIM-Slot, diese SIM-Karte.
Die könnte ich irgendwo anders hintun, kurzzeitig. Wenn mein Telefon kaputt geht.
Wenn mein Telefon kaputt geht, habe ich trotzdem Netz, wenn ich es brauche.
Aber inzwischen habe ich auf dem iPad auch Netz.
Vielleicht reicht mir das dann auch. Und bei der Uhr werde ich es auch aktivieren.
Ich werde mir einen Ur-SIM zulegen.
Also sagen wir mal so, ich habe 10 SIM-Karten auf meinem Account und manche
davon sind physisch und manche sind davon eSIMs.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir und du könntest es in dem Fall auch,
dir auch noch so eine vollwertige physische SIM zusätzlich zu der eSIM haben,
aber ich will halt den Slot frei haben,
damit wenn ich sowas mache, wie Roddy jetzt auch gemacht hat,
ich fahre mal in die Ukraine und ich brauche mal vor Ort schnell den günstigsten
Tarif, da holst du dir halt beim Handyhüker um die Ecke nicht eine eSIM,
sondern da kriegst du halt noch richtig gutes Chipmaterial.
da steckst du dann halt rein, aber dann ist halt auch der Slot frei,
aber dazu muss der Slot frei sein weil ich will ja meine andere Nummer auch noch drauf haben.
Das wollte ich nur wissen.
Genau also das ist meine Strategie und mittlerweile kann man auch sehr viele
eSims da reinparken und ich habe generell mit eSims habe ich ja neulich schon
erzählt von der Reise gute Erfahrungen gemacht,
also klar das hat manchmal so Migrationsbruchs, ich nicht so aber im Großen
und Ganzen funktioniert das.
Ich nicht so ich hatte tatsächlich Probleme mit den eSims,
stellt sich heraus, also es gibt ja diesen einen Anbieter, den du empfohlen hast. Aerolo?
Ja, Aerolo.
Also empfohlen ist ein großes Wort, aber das hat für mich immer funktioniert.
Du hast den Hinweis gegeben, dass es die gibt.
Ja. So.
Ich habe versucht, auf dem Phone über Aerolo eine eSIM zu klicken und es ist mir nicht gelungen.
Warum geht das wahrscheinlich nicht?
Weil nämlich die eSIM vom eigentlichen Provider Vodafone kommt,
Vodafone Niederlande, die dann irgendwelche Roaming-Verträge mit Kiew Star haben.
Ich habe aber eine SIM-Karte von Vodafone da drin, eine physische SIM von Vodafone
und ich glaube, die haben sich gebissen, weil die auch irgendwie über das gleiche
Daten-Gateway wollten.
Ja.
Insofern habe ich dann einen anderen Anbieter versucht, der heißt Nomad.
Und habe mir da eine eSIM geklickt und siehe da, die funktionierte auch.
Witzigerweise funktioniert die Aero-SIM-Karte aber auf dem iPad.
Und mein Tipp zu dem Ganzen ist jetzt, wenn ihr euch bei irgendeinem Anbieter
eine eSIM klickt, dann nehmt erstmal den kleinsten Tarif, weil da ist nicht
so viel Geld weg, wenn sie nicht funktioniert.
Weil aufladen kann man die immer
noch irgendwie und das kostet dann auch nicht viel mehr oder weniger.
Interessanterweise beide eSims über Kiews da und es gab dann auch immer wieder Versorgungslücken.
Gerne mal, wenn der Strom weg war, alle Generatoren angegangen sind und plötzlich
alle Ukrainer von Landline, Internet auf.
Wir wollen jetzt alle mobiles Internet haben, war gerne mal eine Stunde,
zwei, einfach keine Daten zu kriegen.
Was aber wahrscheinlich weniger ein eSIM-Problem ist, sondern mehr ein Kiew-Star-Problem.
Ist ja mehr so ein Kriegsproblem, würde ich mal sagen.
Also wie gesagt, es gibt mehrere Provider von eSIMs, probiert einfach so lange,
bis ihr einen findet, der funktioniert.
Es kann normal sein, dass nicht der erste Provider funktioniert.
Kann immer sein, genau.
Kann immer sein.
Also im Großen und Ganzen, ich gebe der Migration Thumbs up,
weil ich finde, dass das dafür was die da mittlerweile alles umziehen und wie
viel kritische Krypto da dran hängt etc.
Zumindest wenn man halt jetzt hier irgendwie das volle iCloud Bouquet eröffnet.
Also ja, happy customer kann ich nur sagen.
Also man im Januar lief auch gut, mit Ausnahme von genau einer Banking App,
die ich vergessen hatte.
In dem Fall VW Bank war das. Und dann war das alte iPhone in der Tat weg.
Ich habe das auch irgendwie vier Wochen aufbewahrt und irgendwann ist alles zu blöde.
Und dann ist dann dieses Prozedere so, da musst du wieder einen Brief zuschicken
lassen und dann ist da wieder irgendwie dein Spezialkode drin und hab den reingescant
und natürlich dann Fehler, funktioniert nicht. So, gut.
Hotline angerufen, müssen Sie nochmal einen neuen Brief zuschicken.
Was soll denn überhaupt dieses Brief zu schicken?
Schicken Sie mir einen neuen Brief zu. Gut, Brief zugeschickt,
vier Tage später kam wieder an, wieder eingescannt mit dem iPhone.
Error, geht nicht, keine Verbindung, Connection. Wieder Hotline angerufen.
Ach ja, das Problem kennen wir, wir müssen Ihnen einen neuen Brief zu schicken.
Ja, wissen Sie, ich kenne das Problem jetzt auch schon. Und was genau führt
Sie zu der Annahme, dass das, was jetzt zweimal nicht funktioniert hat,
beim dritten Mal funktionieren wird.
Nein, nein, also ernsthaft, schicke ich Ihnen jetzt einen neuen Brief?
Siehst du, wie Angst schweißt und es steht doch hier in meinem Telefonsupport-Reihenfolge,
dass das jetzt der Weg ist. Gut, also dritten Brief geschickt.
Welch Wunder, natürlich hat es wieder nicht funktioniert.
Wieder in die Hotline und wollte es mir wieder andrehen. Mittlerweile sei das
bekannt, dass das mit iPhones Probleme macht.
Ja, nach drei Wochen würde ich das bestätigen, dass das mit iPhones Probleme macht.
Ja, Sie könnten mir, jetzt kommen wir wieder zu dir, auch so ein Kartenlesegerät
schicken, was sich dann irgendwie damit verweht.
Ich möchte bitte kein Kartenlesegerät haben.
Ja, mit Android funktioniert es. Ja, warum sagen Sie das denn nicht gleich?
Ich habe auch ein Android-Handy.
So, das heißt, der allererste Brief hätte schon funktioniert.
Aber das ist jetzt auch irgendwie so Banken, wo man ja auch immer denkt,
so Vertrauen, da ist mein Geld und da will man das Dinge funktionieren und,
es dann irgendwie zig Wochen lang nicht hinbekommt und der Support dann auch
irgendwie so im Dunkeln tappt, dass man weil irgendwie nicht geholfen wird.
Das hinterlässt Fragen.
Aber mit dem Android hat es dann funktioniert, beim ersten Versuchen.
Dann kann man in der Tat dann wieder die App vom Android aufs iPhone rüber bauen.
Also ist das schon alles Fledermausland.
Davon abgesehen, da wollte ich ja hinkommen, der Rest hat bei mir auch super
funktioniert. Also alles andere ging glatt und Und ohne Schmerzen,
ich war aber auch vorbereitet und hatte mir genau eine Liste schon hingeschrieben.
So, was hast du alle für Apps, die wahrscheinlich kritisch sind?
Wobei hier die mit Versicherung, ich bin ja Beamter und dann hast du ja nochmal
Beihilfe-Apps und sowas.
Dieses ständige auch Vergessen von Log-In-Daten, das macht mich auch so rasend.
Das ist halt eine App, die nutzt du nur alle zwei Monate, wenn du halt wieder
irgendwie neue Arztrechnungen eingritzt.
Und jedes Mal steht da, wollen Sie hier die biometrischen Log-In nehmen?
Ja, möchte ich gerne. Soll ich mir das jetzt für immer merken,
diesen Lock-In? Ja, das wäre super.
Merk's dir, bitte. Hast du eine Ahnung.
Was da passiert?
Das ist einfach eine schlechte Softwarequalität. Ich erlaube es dir.
Da gibt es irgendeinen technischen Grund.
Dass das dann stirbt.
Und zwei Monate später ist es wieder alles weg.
Also ich habe da einen Verdacht. Und der Verdacht...
Cookie.
Nein, O-Orth.
Das ist so eine Krankheit mit Auth-Token und Access-Token und Gültigkeitslängen
von Tokens und so weiter.
Das ist also, wer auch immer sich das überlegt hat, der gehört standesrechtlich
irgendwie gratuliert oder so. Ich weiß es nicht.
Mag ja sein, aber warum lügt mich dann diese App an? Also das muss doch irgendwie
den App-Entwicklerinnen dann irgendwann mal aufgegangen sein.
Einfach ein Stern Bewertung fertig. Nicht aufregen, ein Stern.
Das ist das Einzige, was hilft.
Dann hast du schon so komische separate Tarn-Apps, die dann irgendwie nochmal
irgendein Sicherheitsfeature mit reinbringen sollen. Dann installierst du die neu.
Dann wollen die erstmal für sich auch nochmal ein Passwort. Nur für diese scheiß Tarn-App.
Dass du zweimal eingeben musst. Dann musst du dich noch belehren lassen,
dass ein gutes Passwort natürlich auf jeden Fall noch ein Ausrufezeichen und
ein Unterstrich und keine Ahnung, noch noch eine Gedenkminute,
für Franz Beckenbauer brauchst, bis du dann auch nur irgendwie erlaubt bist, das dann zu benutzen.
Wo ich mich auch frage, also warum?
Guckt euch doch mal richtige Banking-Apps an. Die brauchen das irgendwie auch alle gar nicht.
Und dann kannst du natürlich auch nicht irgendwie ein Passwort extern erzeugen
und das mit Cut und Paste,
dann sperren sie auch noch Paste, weil das geht ja nicht wegen der Sicherheit
und nein, du musst das alles ja erinnern du musst jetzt beweisen,
dass du das merken kannst und es ist einfach alles richtig scheiße.
Wir waren doch bei den schönen iOS 18 Features, die uns allen gut gefallen haben.
Da gibt es zwei tolle, die ich noch erwähnen will.
Die eine ist die Kalender-App auf dem Telefon ist weit besser,
aber Tim, du hast gerne, wenn du willst, ist mir egal, aber die hat einfach
Icons und so, das ist viel übersichtlicher.
In der Monatsansicht sieht man jetzt was und da sind nicht nur rote Pöppel.
Und Messages, der schickt zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt eine Message.
Das ist super für meine Nachtaktionen, wo ich irgendwie, oh,
ich will jemandem was mitteilen, ich will das aufschreiben, aber ich will dem
jetzt nicht direkt was schreiben.
Morgen, Vormittag, getimte Messages sind super. Die funktionieren auch.
Also ich habe es noch nicht verwendet, aber ich finde das gut,
dass es das jetzt gibt, weil früher oder später werde ich das Feature auch auch brauchen.
Es ist ein bisschen wirr, wenn man es aktiviert, weil es ist so links im Plus
so eine Sonderfunktion, die man dann aktiviert und dann wird die oben eingeblendet
über der Message-Bubble.
Dann ist es relativ einfach zu bedienen, aber man muss halt wissen,
dass es wie ein Foto hinzufügen ist, als Feature aktivieren.
Aber das sind meine zwei Blizz iOS 18 Geschichten, Kalender und das.
Ja, vor allem der Kalender, es ist ja nicht nur so...
Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass du jetzt in der Monatsübersicht mehr siehst. Habt ihr da mal,
Du kannst entscheiden.
Wie viel du mehr sehen willst.
Genau, du kannst das auch noch so aufziehen. Vertikal.
Oh, wie? Versuche ich gerade.
Also du hast hier im Kalender den Monatsview und dann ziehst du das auf und
dann kannst du richtig schön immer mehr, immer mehr, immer mehr sehen.
Ja, dann kannst du die Wand an.
Also hier.
Dann hast du so eine Ansicht hier. Genau.
Ja, warum geht das gerade bei mir nicht?
Da musst du erst noch ein neues Passwort eingeben.
Nee, rechts oben. Es gibt da glaube ich in Stacked oder irgendeiner Ansicht.
Also das gibt oben, ich habe die Ansicht gehabt mit List, da geht es nicht.
Details heißt die.
Du musst da oben umstellen, in der Toolbar auf eine andere und die kann dann so rauf und runter.
Aber ich bin immer in Liste drin. Ich auch.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr so, weil ich weiß meine Termine an der Stelle. Ich habe da umgestellt.
Ja. I approve.
Und dann die kleinen Icons, die Geburtstagssachen und die Dinge waren weg. Also finde ich besser.
War eine Kalenderverbesserung, dass ich das noch erleben darf.
Was ich immer noch schwierig finde, ist, dass es dieses Ding für Passwörter,
die letzten Passwörter, die letzten Kalenderänderungen auch noch in einer Liste
und rückgängig machen können, wäre auch super, weil Accidental Kalenderveränderungen
sind immer noch der Killer, gerade bei Shared Kalendern.
So. Naja.
iOS 18 Bliss.
Ja, da geht was. Gut.
Wollen wir uns noch weiter über so iOS, macOS Features,
hat noch jemand was? Also meine, die schönen Sachen gibt es ja leider für uns nicht.
Ja, da wollte ich sagen, Mirroring ist bei euch wirklich geht nicht,
oder? Bei mir geht es, weil ich bin ja Ami-Account.
Gibt es nicht.
Und es ist ein schönes Feature, iPhone-Mirroring.
Wo wäre das denn, wenn es gehen würde?
Einfach ganz aktiv unten im Menü taucht es sofort auf. In welchem Menü?
Im Dock. Einfach im Dock präsent. Und dann hast du halt wirklich einfach mal,
wenn das Telefon irgendwo liegt, kannst du da mal eben schnell die Wetter-App
aufmachen und da mal kurz das nachgucken.
Oder mal eine Signal-Nachricht zurückschreiben, ohne dass du die Signal-App
installiert hast auf deinem Computer.
Oder was auch immer du machen willst. Alles geht mit Mausbedienung und so und Tastatur.
Genau, also die App ist bei uns auch installiert. Das heißt also,
wenn du im Programmeordner nachschaust, dann liegt dort iPhone-Synchronisierung-App.
Aber sie meckert halt beim Start und VPN hilft da auch nichts.
Ja, das ist unsere neue Freiheit, die wir jetzt gewonnen haben durch DMA. A.
Ansonsten ist auf dem Mac so wenig passiert, oder? An neuen Features,
die man unbedingt gerne gebraucht hätte. Also die Fotos-App ist ganz anders geworden, überall.
Ja, außer auf dem Mac. Da ist sie ziemlich ähnlich noch so. Also da haben sie
an dem GUI-Konzept nicht viel geändert.
Ist sogar besser geworden, finde ich. Erstens hat sie nicht viel geändert,
aber ein paar Sachen sind so im Detail besser.
Also zum Beispiel hast du jetzt direkt ein Kartenview und musst nicht über das
Album Orte gehen und so weiter.
Also ja, ich...
Habt ihr schon in Notizen gerechnet?
Ja, aber nur auf dem auf dem iPad.
Achso.
Ich nicht. Ich rechne mit dem Taschenrechner. Ganz Altschule.
Ich glaube, das macht nur Sinn, wenn man so einen Stift im Einsatz hat.
Ich überlege gerade, was eigentlich wirklich besser ist.
Also ich meine, diese ganze Fensterpositionierungsgeschichte,
das habe ich dann erstmal ausgeschaltet.
Weil ich das irgendwie wollte ich auch noch machen.
Das fehlt mir viel aus Versehen.
Ja, genau, das kam mir so ein bisschen zu sehr in die Quere,
aber man kann das ja auch so machen, dass wenn man Option drückt,
dass es dann auch auftaucht.
Das brauche ich jetzt nicht unbedingt.
In Windows kann man das nicht ausschalten. Zumindest heißt es nicht gefunden.
Das ist so nervig. Du ziehst ein Fenster nach oben und plötzlich, sich, bumm, es ist,
Fullscreen, das ist bei so einem Ultra-Wide-Display echt nervig,
weil du hast das Window gerade irgendwo anders hingeschoben,
dass es weg ist und plötzlich ist es irgendwie na egal. Aber Windows halt.
Also ich habe relativ wenig zu klagen, aber auch jetzt nicht vieles, was ich groß bejubel.
Also Passwörter hat man ja im Prinzip schon und die anderen Änderungen,
ja, die wichtigen Sachen kommen erst noch.
Also sie scheinen irgendwas am Finder gedreht zu haben, der hat manchmal so
ein bisschen Probleme damit, die Dateien in richtiger Menge und Sortierung anzuzeigen.
Keine Ahnung warum, aber das ist jetzt auch nur so ein kleines Kram.
Das wird sicherlich zum nächsten Punkt Release gefixt sein.
Aber es wirkt so ein bisschen, als hätten sie einen Finder in SwiftUI oder irgendwas neu geschrieben.
Also das war vorher irgendwie tighter.
Man kann jetzt auf iOS für iCloud-Ordner auch sagen, dass die immer gesynct sein sollen.
ich suche das gerade auf macos und finde das nicht ehrlich.
Gesagt für ios wäre mir das aber auch wichtiger als für macos aber.
Für mich wäre es auch für macos wichtig weil dann würde ich mal benutzen also
kann man es ja nicht benutzen doch mal unter man würde erwarten dass man also
so Info macht und das dann so anklickt,
aber irgendwie nicht der Fall.
Ist mir gerade unklar. Aber das ist,
kleine Trippelschritte. Ich denke mal so in 10, 20 Jahren kann man irgendwie
iCloud auch iCloud Drive richtig gut benutzen. Naja.
Was ich kurz mal ausprobiert hatte, war Live Audio Description in Notes.
Das ist so ein bisschen absurd, aber Aber es hat ganz gut geklappt.
Was heißt das?
Du kannst in Notes, wie du so ein Dokument scannen kannst, eine Audionotiz anlegen
und dann macht er automatisch gleich Text raus.
Achso, eine Transkriptionsfunktion.
Genau. Eine Transkriptionsfunktion, die in Notes eingebaut ist,
so wie das Dokumentenscannen in Notes auch eingebaut ist.
Und es war unterschiedliche Sprachen, glaube ich sogar, hat er diesmal sogar erkannt.
Your mileage may vary. Und natürlich Emojis in Messages.
Also wer von diesen Screen-Recording-Prompts genervt ist, die jetzt kommen,
also wenn man Software verwendet, die Screen-Recording machen möchte...
Soll ja vorkommen.
Ja.
Was weiß ich, sowas wie Text-Sniper oder so. Also so Programme,
die haben... Also irgendwas, was den Bildschirm auslesen möchte.
Dann gibt es ja jetzt so ein Feature in Anführungsstrichen, dass man das dann
immer nur für einen Monat freischalten kann.
Das war mal irgendwie ein oder zwei Tage während der Beta und das war richtig nervig.
Eine Woche, ja.
Die haben das so Stückchen für Stückchen haben sie das angehoben, zum Glück.
Ja. Jetzt gibt es natürlich Leute, die wollen das vielleicht nicht jeden Monat machen.
Stellt sich raus, das ganze Sicherheitsfeature ist nur ein Textstring in einer,
Konfigurationsdatei, wo ein Datum drin steht.
Und das kann man halt auch einfach von Hand ändern, beziehungsweise gibt es
mittlerweile auch so ein kleines das GUI-Tool, was das macht,
da kann man dann irgendwie sich das irgendwie auch auf,
ein Jahr legen oder irgendwie sowas und dann ist Ruhe im Karton,
wenn man der Meinung ist, das zu machen.
Ich verstehe ja die Motivation von Apple, was solche Sachen betrifft.
Sie wollen halt irgendwie, dass Leute nicht sich einfach mal eben irgendwie
sowas eintreten und dann ist es immer da, aber ...
für Power-User ist es dann immer wieder so ein bisschen hart.
Ja, Amnesia heißt die Software, die das irgendwie schnell mal fixt,
wenn das für euch ein Problem ist.
Ja. Sehr viel mehr Lust darüber zu reden habe ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Es gibt ein neues iStart Menus.
Wie neu?
Das habe ich nicht downgeloadet. Lohnt sich das?
Das ist so geil.
Wie neu.
Was findest du da besser dran?
Das sieht einfach cooler aus.
Ach so.
Allein schon die Ansicht, also allein schon, dass er bei der CPU-Ansicht Effizienzkerne
und Leistungskerne trennt.
Und also auch viele andere, die haben einfach nochmal, der Designer hat nochmal
über Stunden geschoben. Es sieht einfach so viel geiler aus.
Okay. Okay, vielleicht kaufe ich es mir dann doch auch.
Und für die 10 Euro Update oder was das waren oder 13 oder was ich bezahlt habe,
war das für mich ein No-Brainer.
Da sind auch so Kleinigkeiten haben sie natürlich verbessert,
aber im Großen und Ganzen, also ich finde das sehr, sehr cool.
Da sind auch Themes drin. Du kannst die Optik auch nochmal anpassen.
Ja, das sind im Prinzip nur Farbsets, aber das ist auch ganz cool.
Du kannst halt die Themes für Dark Mode und für Light Mode getrennt einstellen.
Sodass, wenn der Rechner von Light Mode auf Dark Mode schaltet,
du dann auch das entsprechende Theme, was du eingestellt hast, bekommst und so.
Also die haben schon nochmal ordentlich die Sau rausgelassen.
Ja, iSight Menu ist bei mir auch Pflichtprogramm und da gehe ich jedes Update mit.
treuer Gründer bin.
Ich finde, das kann man mitkennen.
Dieses Ja, du, dann habe ich aber noch, soweit ich habe ja noch so dieses Apple
Vision Gerät in der Ecke liegen.
Das hatte ich lange Zeit an meinem Bruder verliehen und für die Vision OS 2
wollte ich es mal wieder haben.
Ja. Jetzt habe ich es wieder gehabt.
Also was,
große Begeisterung.
Verleihe mir das doch mal nach Berlin dienen als nächstes, wenn du da so underwhelmt.
Also ich muss, also jetzt mal, der längere Ausflug ist, nach so langer Zeit
es wieder aufzusetzen, macht dann doch wieder einen guten Eindruck im Sinne
von, es ist doch gutes Display im Verhältnis zu anderem Zeug.
Es ist doch wieder, also man hat vergessen, wie gut das Display wirklich ist.
Das ist das eine, was ganz schön ist.
Im Vergleich zu was?
Aber es ist auch im Verhältnis jetzt zu den anderen VR-Sachen,
die ich so auf der Birne hatte.
Ja, aber ich weiß ja nicht, was du auf der Birne hattest. Quest oder was?
Eine Quest 3 und eine Quest 2 natürlich hier irgendwo rumlegen.
Eine Playstation VR Zeug.
Also man ist positiv überrascht so von der Seite.
Es ist immer noch schwer und warum ich es eigentlich wieder gemacht habe,
war hauptsächlich wegen den Betriebssystem-Features,
und was bei Vision OS 2 wirklich gut ist, sind die Gesten jetzt,
dass man nicht mehr an den Homebutton die ganze Zeit drücken muss.
Man kann praktisch die Hand einfach vor das Gesicht halten und irgendwie so
den Daumen, Zeigefinger so ein bisschen aufhalten, so in die Hand reingucken
und das ist dann ein Homebutton und dann kann man da drücken und dann kommt das Homemenü vor einem.
Das ist ganz gut und der Status auch.
Das heißt, man muss weniger oft oben an das Ding rum hingerangen,
das haben sie gut gemacht.
Was sie wirklich super gut gemacht haben, ist, dass du alle deine Fotos spezialisieren
kannst, wenn du willst, also 3D machen.
Also nachträglich meinst du?
Nachträglich, genau. Das ist das Geile eigentlich. Also Fotos von vor zehn Jahren.
Also gerade mit den Live-Fotos haben sie wohl aus dem Video genug Informationen,
auch diese mit übernehmen. Das wird so richtig gut.
Es ist dann wirklich so, da hast du einfach mal so richtig schönes 3D-Foto von
der Situation von einigen Jahren her.
Was meinst du jetzt mit aus dem Video, also wenn man Live-Fotos gemacht hat?
Wenn man Live-Fotos gemacht hat, genau. Da ist ja ein Video dran mit wenigen
Frames, aber die werden da bestimmt mit einbezogen, weil so ist es viel besser,
als wenn du Fotos nimmst, die nur flach sind. Die können sie auch,
die machen sie aber mit AI.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel von meinem Nachwuchs so Babyfotos und da kommen dann
so AI-Artefakte von der Tiefe her, weil da wird einfach das Gesicht ein bisschen
anders, babymäßig gemacht, so von der,
Quellung her, weil der hat einfach keinen Unterbiss an der Stelle. Hatte er nie.
Das ist aber so ein klassischer Baby-Mobs-Blick. Der kam dann halt ein, zweimal rein.
Aber alle anderen Sachen sind wirklich, also, und das ist halt wirklich schick,
so ein altes Foto von den Eltern, auch noch so gescannte Fotos teilweise. Und dann...
so ein bisschen 3D zu haben. Das macht schon nochmal, das ist ein cooles Feature,
aber es ist halt auch ein Gimmick, aber halt ein cooles Gimmick.
Viel geht auch noch nicht, also das Curved Display, das große Display,
haben sie noch nicht mal gemacht. Coming Later This Year selbst an der Stelle.
Der Airplay-Receiver selber ist ein tolles Feature, weil dann kannst du endlich
mal alles, was Airplay schicken kann, auch in die Brille reinbeamen.
Das ging ja vorher auch nicht, so automatisch.
Und was Was ganz cool funktioniert, ist da meine kleine iPhone-App,
die ja nicht so erfolgreich war, aber die ich mal gemeint habe,
für Leute, die Apple-TVs haben,
also mit Tageslicht kannst du einfach so deine iPhone-Kamera mirrorn und dann
kannst du was herzeigen,
wenn du eh ein Apple-TV rumstehen hast oder ein Airplay-fähiges Display und
das funktioniert jetzt auch ganz gut mit dem eingebauten. Das ist ganz gut.
Und ansonsten ist es halt einfach immer noch zu teuer, zu wenig,
nicht zu viel, zu schwer, abwarten, Tee trinken, mal gucken,
wer denn die Sache besser löst.
Ob der Sack nicht davonläuft.
Mit dem, was die machen. Gibt es das noch?
Ja, gibt es noch.
Was macht die App? Erzähl doch mal, was macht die?
Fürs iPhone. Das ist nur eine kleine App, die die Kamera benutzt live.
Und da kannst du, wenn du Airplay Mirroring anmachst am Telefon,
hast du praktisch auf deinem Telefon so einen Sucher, den du bedienen kannst,
aber auf dem Fernseher praktisch einen 16 zu 9 Bildausschnitt davon,
damit du irgendwas herzeigen kannst.
Einfach mit deiner Kamera jetzt mal schnell, was ein Ding, das du in der Hand
hast, herzeigen oder hinterm Ding was suchen.
Einfach nur das Live-Bild von deiner Kamera auf ein Airplay-Reflektoren packen.
Arges Licht Overhead.
Geht das so nicht mit Bordmitteln, wenn ich einen Mirroring habe?
Ja, aber dann hast du immer komische UI irgendwo. Also ich habe halt wirklich
den Fullscreen-Fernseher mit voller Auflösung, mit voller Qualität von dem Kameraversuch.
Du hattest uns irgendwann mal ein paar Codes übergeholfen. Also ich hab das dann auch...
Und das funktioniert, also ich nehm's halt in Situationen her,
wo wir einen Airplay-Receiver irgendwo haben,
und das ist ganz nett, also bei Bekannten oder so auch noch,
wenn das dran ist, da kannst du halt so Gegenstände herzeigen mal eben schnell
oder so, dass das alle sehen, so Beamer-technisch.
Du hast halt seit drei Jahren keine Features bekommen, die Software.
Nee, das hat keine Features. Aber hat volle Kamera-Qualität, das reicht doch.
Aber so eine richtige iPhone-Mirroring Dings haben sie jetzt der Vision nicht gegönnt.
Nee, nee, wenn du aufs Telefon guckst, hast du nach wie vor die unscharfe Ding
vom Telefon, das geht nicht automatisch.
Also wie gesagt, das ist ein Hobbyprojekt noch, das ist jetzt so unter,
land unter, bis die coolere Hardware machen, kann man sich das getrost sparen.
Außer man will irgendwas für die Plattform machen, glaube ich.
Weil jetzt ja die letzten Tagen Berichte rauskamen, dass die Hardware nicht
geiler wird, sondern günstiger.
Dass sie also jetzt überlegen, wohl die Auflösung runterzufahren vom Display,
um das Ganze irgendwie unter 2000 Euro.
Das können sie eigentlich nicht machen. Wecker darf es nicht werden in keiner
der Aspekte. Glaube ich nicht.
Das halte ich für eine Ente.
Das geht nach hinten.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie schlechtere Qualität machen.
Sie haben ja kein Konzept einfach, das Ding. Und deshalb werden sie schon viel
Sachen probieren, aber sie haben das noch nicht gelöst.
Wenn sie die Hardware auf die Hälfte des Preises mit der Qualität bringen können,
haben sie eine Plattform und dann stecken sie weiter Geld rein und bis dahin
dümpelt das jetzt, glaube ich.
Ja, aber die Frage ist, gibt es schon eine Anwendung. Also gibt es eine Killer-App.
Und Filme gucken alleine ist glaube ich nicht Killer-App genug,
weil es ja auch nur für so Solitäre ist.
Aber das habe ich ja schon mal gesagt, du kannst so ein Gerät nicht für 3,5
K Dollar, hier 4.000 Euro, anbieten, es Pro nennen und dann ist deine Killer-App,
ich gucke mir Filme drauf an.
Ja klar, aber deswegen frage ich ja gerade, ob Dom irgendwas entdeckt hat in
der Zwischenzeit oder sagen wir das so, da tut sich was.
Nee, das fühlt sich eher an als stagniertes, finde ich.
Also auch der Content, der dazu gewachsen ist, die paar Spatial-Videos,
die sie da gemacht haben, die sind zwar nicht schlecht, also der Parcourslauf,
der da dazu kam, auch nochmal.
Also die Adventure-Serie ist schon cool, aber das war's halt dann auch wieder großartig.
Die Sportgeschichten könnte ich mir noch vorstellen. Für Leute,
die Sport wollen, ist es natürlich toll.
Was sie besser gemacht haben, sind die Handerkennung, also bei Spielen oder
so ist das jetzt ein bisschen schneller, weil das war ein bisschen arg laggy davor.
Es ist aber eher so, dass es vorher einiges schlechter war als woanders von
dem, was die Spiele abbekommen haben und Spiele, da gehst du eh lieber auf die
Quest, weil da hast du die besseren Spiele an der Stelle.
Also das haben sie komplett verkackt, die Seite, leider.
Für Spieler wäre es ein ganz gutes Gerät, wenn es Controller unterstützen würde,
wäre die Qualität echt zu bi.
Ja, oder du ein ordentliches Mirroring von irgendwas, von, keine Ahnung.
Es gibt ja bei Steam jede Menge VR-Games, die du mit einem entsprechenden Device,
das halt VR-Games unterstützt, dann spielen könntest. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das geht.
Ne, ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie das machen in die Richtung.
Es ist eine deutliche Nicht-Kaufen-Empfehlung, aber gerne ausprobieren,
wenn ihr es mal in der Nähe habt.
Ja, schick mal rum.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob sie da nicht nochmal versuchen,
was drunter zu positionieren. Also ich habe jetzt hier in den Chat gerade mal
den Heiser-Artikel dazu gegeben.
Wenn sie irgendwie wirklich sagen, okay, das Teil heißt jetzt Pro,
ja, Vision Pro und wir machen jetzt die normale Vision, die kommt jetzt hinterher
und die liegt bei 1.999 Dollar und hat die Hälfte der Auflösung und hat außen
nicht diese albernen Zusatz-Displays drauf.
Da hast du immer noch keine Keine Anwendung.
Ja, aber damit kriegst du dann vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen mehr Mark.
Für 2000 Dollar?
Ja, aber wie willst du denn einen Markt haben, wenn du keine Anwendung hast?
Der andere guckt bei 300 rum. Also auf 300 kommen sie nicht runter, glaube ich. Großartig.
Naja, ich glaube, und das ging ja auch so ein bisschen durch die Gerüchteküche
durch, dass sie selber schockiert waren davon, wie wenig sie von den Dingern verkauft haben.
Und dass das vielleicht da ein gewisses einsehen, ist, dass sie eine neue Plattform,
wenn sie die etablieren können, können sie nicht die Preise nehmen,
die sie bei einer gut etablierten Plattform nehmen.
Und also meiner Meinung nach muss das Ding für unter 1000 über den Ladentisch
gehen, damit es halbwegs Traktion bringt.
Sonst macht da auch, portiert da keiner Software drauf.
Du siehst es Du siehst es am Apple TV, es ist viel zu teuer.
Es kauft keiner, deswegen macht keiner Software dafür. Fertig.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass das das eigentliche Problem von dem Apple TV ist
und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es das eigentliche Problem von dem Apple Vision ist.
Sondern es ist einfach, dass es einfach als Plattform noch nicht überzeugend
genug ist für eine neue Generation von Anwendungen.
Ja, aber es kommt immer darauf an, zu welchem Price Point.
Ja, aber unabhängig vom Preis.
Nee, den an der Stelle kannst du das nicht unabhängig von dem Preis sehen.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir jetzt die Apple Vision Pro für 500 Euro kaufen könnte.
Dann würde ich das tun.
Ja, dann würde ich das auch tun, aber ich würde sie trotzdem nicht benutzen.
Das ist ja egal.
Nee, das ist nicht egal.
Nee, dann würde ich sie aber anders benutzen. Dann würde ich sie zum Beispiel
für die Zugfahrt mitnehmen oder sowas. Weißt du?
Also für mal Medienkonsum irgendwo ist eher so eine Geschichte, könnte ich mir Ja.
Aber dafür ist sie dann zu groß.
Nein, das ist nicht der Punkt oder nicht mein Punkt.
Mein Punkt ist, wenn die billig genug wären,
dass du nicht drüber nachdenkst, dass ich nicht drüber nachdenke,
dass Ralf nicht drüber nachdenkt, dann hätten sie schon drei verkauft,
dann hätten sie jede Menge von denen verkauft und dann gibt es die Möglichkeit,
dass jemand, der Software macht und davon auch leben will und nicht einfach
nur, weil es nett ist, irgendwie Xcode zu benutzen, was es nicht ist,
aber das ist nur am Rande. Ja.
würde dann qualitative Software auf die Brille bringen. Dann wären auch die Ideen da.
Ja, aber qualitative Software setzt ja voraus, dass es eine Anwendung gibt.
Eine Anwendung, die überzeugend ist. Und ich glaube, dass es einfach diese Anwendung nicht gibt.
Doch, ich glaube, diese Anwendung gäbe es schon. Aber halt nicht für ein System, das keine User hat.
Ich sehe es genau andersrum. Ich glaube, dass es derzeit nur Anwendungen gibt
für Leute, die auch 3.500 Euro dafür zahlen.
In der Industrie, für so Telegram, für so aufwendige Sachen,
wo der Preis der Vision Pro selber im Gesamtaufwand ist.
Für die Industrie ist es ein zu sehr geclosedes System. Da steht Apple drauf,
das kauft die Industrie erstmal nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn das eine Lösung ist für ein Problem, dann kaufen die auch nicht.
Wenn es eine Branchenlösung gibt, das ist halt so ein Henne-Ei-Problem an der
Stelle, aber die Branchenlösung gibt es nicht, weil es nicht hackbar genug ist
und die muss halt mit dem SDK lösen können.
Und das ist dann wieder, da haben sie andere, also glaube ich nicht.
Ja, aber das ist ja das, was ich meine. Also die Plattform taugt derzeit einfach
noch nicht ausreichend, um wirklich Anwendungen zu erzeugen,
wo man sagt, dafür brauche ich jetzt so eine blöde Brille.
weil die Brille bringt so viel Einschränkungen mit sich und sie haben ja eine Menge versucht,
diese Einschränkungen aufzulösen mit dieser Kamera vorne und dem Display und
allem möglichen Klimbim und Gestenerkennung und hast nicht gesehen,
sie geben sich ja die größte Mühe,
nur damit sind sie noch nicht über den Berg und das ist halt einfach Quest,
okay, meinetwegen Spiele aber das wird halt auch an der Stelle eher nischig
bleiben wie lange reden wir jetzt schon über diese Dinger, dass das jetzt angeblich
irgendwie die totale Revolution ist und es ist halt nicht das.
Ja gut, am unteren Spektrum ist es halt so, dass die Qualität auch einfach noch nicht da ist.
Gut, Quest 3 kann sein, aber ich kaufe mir auch kein Facebook-Gerät,
also das kannst du vergessen.
Aber nein, also ich denke, dass wenn du 3D-Objekte manipulieren willst,
will virtuelle Knete kneten oder CRD-Software oder irgendwie sowas in der Art,
dann glaube ich, dass du mit dem Gerät gut sowas gut bauen könntest.
Nur, das ist hochkomplexe Software.
Wir reden da über ein Team von locker 30 Leute, die da locker zwei bis drei
Jahre dran entwickeln. Das ist ein riesen Invest.
Das machst du nicht für eine Plattform, die keine User hat.
Und das ist das Problem. Das machst du aber auch nicht für irgend so ein Billigding.
Ja gut, CAD ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt der Gassenhauer.
Also ich meine, das ist ja genau das Beispiel, was ich meine mit da hast du
eine… Das ist nicht der Gassenhauer.
CAD.
Ja, also die gesamte Industrie benutzt CAD.
Ja, die Industrie benutzt CAD, aber es ist kein Massenprodukt CAD.
Aber es ist schon eine Menge Industrie. Es ist kein Consumer-Produkt.
Wir reden aneinander vorbei. Also ich sage nur eins, so wie es derzeit ist,
die Plattform hat bisher nichts, in diesen sechs Monaten ist nichts rausgekommen,
wo man sagen würde, boah, was ist das denn?
Nichts. Sondern es ist alles ganz nett und so weiter.
Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass Apple sagt, brauchen wir derzeit auch
nicht und wir konzentrieren uns erstmal darauf,
dass die Idee Fuß fasst und dann machen wir Vision OS 4.0 und dann haben wir
irgendwie noch ein Upgrade für die nächste Brille und dann haben wir irgendwie
diesen Punkt erreicht und dann kommen wir da an, wo wir dachten,
wo wir vielleicht schon früher sind.
Aber Massenmarkt ist noch sehr weit.
Ich hoffe, dass sie den Atem haben und dass dann Consumer, also so ein Plattformprodukt
auch bei rauskommt dann im Endeffekt hinten, das dann wirklich auch,
einen tollen Anwendungsfall hat, weil es ist schon interessant.
Aber wie gesagt, in der aktuellen Lage ist es ein Luxusprodukt,
das ganz seltsame, das einfach ganz seltsam geschnitten ist.
Das ist den ganzen Markt ganz seltsam beschneidet.
Und das hat sie, glaube ich, echt auch wirklich überrascht.
Ja, aber nochmal, also es ist ein Henne- und Ei-Problem.
Du musst irgendwie dieses ich habe User, deswegen kommen Entwickler auf meine
Plattform und ich habe Entwickler auf der Plattform und dadurch kriege ich mehr User.
Dieses Henne-Ei-Problem musst du lösen. Das löst du aber nicht mit einem goldenen Ei.
Ich glaube, sie sie könnten es lösen, wenn sie ein Companion-Produkt zum Telefon
oder zum iPad sehen, aber am besten zum Telefon.
Also wenn das praktisch das geile Display fürs Telefon wäre,
der Medienkonsum-Ding und das wäre halt so der Preis 300, 400,
Dollar oder so.
Dann bist du im Konsumermarkt.
Man hat einfach gemeinsam eine geshared Experience, wenn man Medien konsumiert.
Irgend so was, wo man so einen Einstieg hat und danach baut man vielleicht mehr drum rum.
Aber was das mehr sein soll, weiß halt auch noch keiner so wirklich so dolle.
Jenseits von den,
Banded Reality spielen und so, die halt schon auch immer für die Leute schon
ein positiver Hammer sind, die aber, wie gesagt, eher auf der Quest funktionieren.
Also, wenn du mal jemanden an der Quest sehen hast, dass irgendwie Aliens dein
Zimmer stürmen und du die irgendwie stoppen musst, das macht denen alle Spaß,
sofort in der Größenordnung von, haben sie noch nicht erlebt,
wenn sie es noch nie gemacht haben.
Nicht mal sowas gibt es ja auf der Vision.
Also, wo ich ja immer noch der Meinung bin, wo echtes Potenzial ist,
ist ja Live-Übertragung oder meinetwegen auch außer Konserve von.
Echten Live-Events, seien es jetzt Sportveranstaltungen, seien es irgendwie
Musik-Events, Taylor Swift-Konzerte, was auch immer.
Und in dem Kontext hat jetzt Meta ja für die Quest wieder so ein neues Virtual
Reality Second World, wie auch immer, Ding gestartet, Meta Horizon.
Und das habe ich mir mal irgendwie vor zwei Wochen ein bisschen genauer angeguckt,
was da eigentlich so passiert. Du hast halt wieder so einen Avatar und läufst
durch irgendwelche digital gestalteten Marktplätze durch und andere Leute hüpfen um dich hin.
Also dieser ganze Kram, den man irgendwie alle, finde ich, dann doch nicht so
richtig ernst nehmen kann.
Aber du kannst dann halt dort ins Kino gehen und setzt dich also dann auf einen
Kinosessel und neben dir sitzen die anderen Avatare und ihr guckt zusammen einen Film an.
Oder du gehst dann halt in ein Musikkonzert oder gehst in einen Club und hast
dann da einen DJ, der da irgendwie auflegt.
Und was aber irgendwie die kapitale Enttäuschung bei der ganzen Sache ist.
Alles ist halt 3D modelliert, außer der eigentliche Content.
Das heißt, die Sportveranstaltung ist also einfach nur ein 2D-Video,
was gigantisch groß, dann zwar irgendwo hin projiziert wird,
aber es ist halt 2D. Du bist überhaupt nicht drin.
So, der DJ legt da auf, du bist in einer Venue drin, die Venue um dich rum ist,
3D modelliert, aber das, was da vorne eigentlich auf der Bühne passiert,
ist dann wieder eine 2D Projektion. Was soll denn der Scheiß?
So, wenn doch der Gag ist, dass man gerade das doch irgendwie jetzt sinnlich
erfahrbar machen will, so, warum hören sie dann da wieder auf dem letzten Meter auf?
Weil es ist doch nun nicht so, dass es 2024 ein Riesenproblem wäre.
Jetzt Stereoskopen, Konzerte oder ein Sportevent abzufilmen.
Das ist doch ein total gelöstes Problem.
Also sie haben halt, wenn du dich natürlich in der Venue dann bewegst,
nach nach links und rechts, können sie das natürlich dann quasi in der Projektion
nicht mit ausgleichen. Ich verstehe schon, dass sie da so in das eine oder andere
technische Problem reinlaufen.
Aber so wie es jetzt ist, ist es halt totaler Downer, weil es einfach halt olles
3D-Brimborium um dich rum ist.
Aber der eigentliche Content, der mich interessiert, ist nach wie vor 2D.
Und so funktioniert es halt nicht.
Ja gut, aber wir reden jetzt über den Konzern, der Avatare ohne Beine gemacht hat.
Naja, nun, also ich finde Man muss Meta hier zumindest mal zugute halten.
Die experimentieren mal deutlich mehr als Apple das derzeit macht.
Apple macht gar nichts, gefühlt.
Ja, ich glaube, dass sie dich damit völlig verhoben haben, dass da irgendwie
in ihrer Filter-Bubble die Meinung war, guck mal, tolle Hardware und so weiter
und das ist nicht ein Spitzenpreis und sind dann halt einfach an der Realität zerschellt.
und meine Meinung ist, sie müssen den Preis unter 1000 Dollar kriegen.
999, auch vielleicht mit Hardware-Einschränkungen, aber sie müssen das Teil in den Markt kriegen.
Du kannst eine Plattform ohne User, das ist keine Plattform,
das bringt nichts. Sie müssen da irgendwie User drauf kriegen.
500 Dollar, that's the most expensive Headset I've ever seen.
Jaja, ist es ja auch. Der Unterschied ist nur, das iPhone wurde Apple aus den
Händen gerissen, wie blöde.
Und die Brille liegt jetzt bleichschwer in den Regalen.
Die ist halt auch kein iPhone. Also das muss man schon auch deutlich sagen.
Das, was der Touchscreen beim iPhone war, das ist die Zukunft von der Geräteklasse,
ist jetzt das Spatial Computing nicht.
Das ist eine ganz interessante Interpretation von dem, was man denn mit so einem 3D-Raum machen kann.
Aber keine der Interaktionen ist wirklich so mindblowing, wie jetzt an sich
direkt die Interaktion auf dem iPhone war.
Ja, und das, was du jetzt gesagt hast, was Vision OS 2.0 ist,
muss ich sagen, das ist auch gelogen, dass das jetzt ein Major Release sein soll.
Also das hätten sie mal 1.1 nennen können.
Das ist ja wirklich egal, wie sie es nennen.
Ja, aber es zeigt halt auch die große 2.0, Next Major Version und was ist besser?
Neue Gehäusefarben.
Also da müssen sie noch mehr User mit irgendeinem Scheiß.
Du, 2.0 darf es dann heißen, wenn sich interne APIs geändert haben.
Ja, das ist eine API. Versionsnummern als Marketing,
Ding finde ich immer noch total unangemessen das ist irgendwie Quark lass sie
es doch 2.0 nennen, wenn es 2.0 ist, weil sich die APIs geändert haben,
dann ist es halt so, aber das Ding wird besser werden, das Ding kann sich vielleicht,
das ist jetzt das letzte was ich dazu sagen werde es hat noch die Chance sich
bestimmte Branchen zu erarbeiten, das können sie durch die Verbesserung ihrer Software machen,
Das können Sie vielleicht in einem zweiten Schritt auch nochmal durch die Verbesserung
der Hardware machen. Da müssen Sie halt gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ich sage, kann sein, kann nicht sein.
Ich bin da auch komplett emotionslos.
Massenmarkt mit dem Teil ist, glaube ich, nicht Apples Ziel,
sondern Sie wollen da ein Pro-Device haben.
Sie wollen auch die ganze Zeit im maximal Möglichen agieren,
weil sie sagen oder denken, oder ich denke, dass sie das denken,
auch wenn sie es nicht sagen, wir.
Gehen davon aus, für das, was sie im Kopf haben, und das traue ich ihnen zu,
dass sie dann eine Vision haben, die sie nicht teilen, weil sie die erst teilen
werden, wenn sie da sind.
Aber das ist der erste Schritt. Sie wollen irgendwo hin, wo all diese Qualität
erforderlich ist und wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel mehr.
Und das kann funktionieren, das kann nicht funktionieren, aber sie sind nicht
auf dem, wir müssen da Millionen von verkaufen und wir müssen jetzt irgendwie
für 999 irgendwie das Videodevice sein,
auch wenn es vielleicht unter reinen wirtschaftlichen Aspekten und Shareholder-Value
und diesem ganzen Quatsch irgendwo Sinn machen würde,
aber Apple kümmert sich da nicht drum.
Das ist für die einfach gar nicht das Thema.
Man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob es ihr Thema sein sollte,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass es ihr Thema ist derzeit, sondern sie wollen woanders
hin und sie wollen noch besser werden.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich wäre überrascht, wenn wir eine Vision Pro sehen mit
weniger Auflösung. Ich wäre überrascht, wenn wir eine Vision Pro sehen.
Ja, auch eine Vision, was auch immer. Also wenn es eine Vision ist ohne Pro,
dann fehlt vielleicht eher das Display vorne oder sowas.
Aber nicht Qualitätsverschlechterung. Das kann ich mir auf gar keinen Fall vorstellen. Niemals.
Nee, auf der anderen Seite ist es halt so, du hast entweder ein Device,
was einfach nur ein Device ist und du lebst mit dem, was da drauf läuft.
iPhone 1.0, keine Third-Party-Software. Wir erinnern uns alle,
alle waren sehr enttäuscht, dass sie keine Software dafür machen können.
Das hat aber als Device wunderbar funktioniert. Aber die Zeiten von Revolutionary
Internet Device und ein iPod und all diese Dinge,
das hast du ja selber gesagt, du siehst die Killer-Anwendung nicht für das Ding.
Es zeigt Potenzial, aber es gibt keine Anwendung dafür. Apple scheint ja auch
keine Anwendung dafür zu haben.
Insofern müssen sie eigentlich darauf vertrauen, eine Plattform anzubieten und
für eine Plattform brauchst du Third-Party-Developer.
Okay, ich meine 15, 20 Jahre App Store haben gezeigt, dass sie mit ihren Third-Party-Developern
nicht wirklich gut umgehen.
Und nur weil sie so gut im Markt vertreten sind, funktioniert das trotzdem. dem.
Nur, wenn sie von dem hohen Ross und dem hohen Preis ausgehen,
dann würgen sie den Markt ab, bevor er überhaupt möglich wurde.
Das ist meine Meinung.
Haben wir jetzt zur Kenntnis genommen. Ich sag da jetzt nichts mehr zu,
hab ich ja gerade gesagt.
Haben wir noch Themen?
Wir haben noch ganz viele Themen für mindestens noch zwei Stunden Sendung.
Die Frage ist, wie viele Stunden wollen wir das noch füllen,
Ralf, du hast ja auch noch was. Ich hätte noch was für die letzten zwölf Minuten.
Ja, also KI würde ich ganz gerne schieben.
Dann schieben wir das. Unbedingt, um nochmal die Ausrichtung der Sendung in
eine andere Richtung zu bekommen.
Habt ihr schon mal Geoguessr gespielt?
Wisst ihr, was das ist?
Nein.
Ja, ich weiß, was das ist, aber ich habe es noch nicht selber gespielt.
Ah, Dom?
Nee.
Nicht?
Also ich weiß nicht, ich kenne so einen Typen auf TikTok, der von einem Bild
versucht zu erkennen, genau wo diese Person ist. Und das finde ich sehr lustig. Ist das Geoguessing?
Ja, also Geoguessr selber ist ein Spiel, was auf Google Maps basiert.
Das kannst du jederzeit auch kostenlos mal ebenso in der Minimalversion online spielen.
Und die Idee ist, du wirst halt randommäßig irgendwo auf diesem Planeten,
wo es Street View gibt, wirst du gedroppt.
Und dann darfst du da durch die Gegend latschen und dann musst du irgendwie
raten, wo du da eigentlich gelandet bist.
Das ist ganz interessant, man kann das mal so machen,
ich habe da immer ein bisschen Zeit mit verbracht, da guckst du dann durch irgendwelche
mexikanischen Städte oder was weiß ich,
bist irgendwo in Australien da in der Wüste gelandet oder keine Ahnung,
irgendwo in Deutschland im Wald. Ja.
Und es ist bemerkenswert, wie viel man da so durch die Gegend laufen muss am
Anfang und wie viel Zeit man braucht, bis man überhaupt erstmal checkt,
wo man ist und sein könnte.
Und dann schätzt du halt so durch einen Klick auf die Karte,
wo du wahrscheinlich bist.
Und dann kriegst du halt Punkte dafür, wie nah du an dem eigentlichen Ort bist. Das ist das Spiel.
Und da kann man ganz schön ablosen. Also da ist schon eine Herausforderung,
den richtigen Kontinent zu raten. Sagen wir es mal so.
Oder überhaupt erstmal rauszufinden, in welcher Stadt bin ich denn jetzt hier?
Bin ich überhaupt in der Stadt? Und so weiter.
Das ist ganz schön teuer.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, was sie so nehmen, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall also
es gab zumindest früher immer so ein freies Modul.
Ich bin gar nicht, aber das ist echt Dark Patterns, bis du das freie Modul gefunden
hast. Du musst dich halt erst mal registrieren mit E-Mail.
Ja, da haben sie es ein bisschen schwerer gemacht. Ich habe es schon länger nicht mehr gemacht.
Warum ich das jetzt überhaupt auf die die Liste gesetzt habe,
ist, es gibt mittlerweile Geoguessr World Championships.
Die haben sie jetzt durchgeführt und es gibt da so ein Acht-Stunden-Video,
wo so Viertelfinale, Halbfinale und Finale gezeigt wird, wo also die besten
Geoguessr der Welt antreten.
Und das müsst ihr euch anschauen. Es ist wirklich unfassbar,
mit welcher Geschwindigkeit diese Leute und mit welcher Präzision die sozusagen orten.
Also da gibt es wirklich Momente, wo die so innerhalb von ein paar Sekunden
den Ort auf diesem Planeten bis auf wenige Meter genau orten.
Die maximale Punktzahl, die du dann bekommen kannst, sind 5000 und umso größer
deine Distanz ist, umso mehr Punkte kriegst du abgezogen.
Ab einer bestimmten Distanz gibt es halt einfach gar keine Punkte mehr.
Und dann treten halt immer zwei gegeneinander an.
die quasi an demselben Ort rausgeworfen werden.
Ein Kilometer.
Dammit, das war Oslo.
Das war Oslo.
Hast du das auch?
Naja, das Oslo Jazz Festival stand auf der Fahne.
Das war jetzt nicht so schwer.
Ich hatte Kopenhagen getippt. Verdammt.
Siehst du mal. So eine Sachen. Und da fragt man sich natürlich jetzt,
wie schaffen die das so schnell da irgendwie zu den Lösungen zu kommen?
Weil du guckst da drauf, denkst du so, ja okay, wo ist das denn jetzt?
Also da kommen dann so Sachen wie, ist es in Japan,
Japan kann man dann schnell erkennen, da hast du halt viele solche Telegraph-Poles,
die rumstehen, weil die ja immer alles oberirdisch machen in Japan und überall hängen tausend Kabel.
Aber dann gibt es natürlich so bestimmte Codes, die dann eben genau einem sagen,
welche Company jetzt hier zuständig ist für diesen Telekommunikationsbereich
und das agiert dann quasi, also so kleine Farbmarkierungen auf irgendeinem Telegraph-Poll
agieren dann eben als Postcode.
Und dann wissen die halt alle auswendig und wissen einfach sofort,
in welcher Präfektur die sind oder in welchem Stadtteil von Tokio oder so.
Irre, ja. Und auch andere Kleinigkeiten, so ja, Beschaffenheit des Bodens,
Stand der Sonne, Schattenwurf.
ich hatte ja hier in der letzten Sendung auch schon dieses OSINT-Tool da mal mit irgendwie,
misst den Schatten im Foto aus und ich sag dir wo du bist, solche Faktoren spielen da mit rein,
aber die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die das machen ist wirklich unglaublich,
also kann ich nur sehr empfehlen ich muss nochmal den Link raus,
schicken Geo.
Gather, World Also ich bin zumindest immer auf dem richtigen Kontinent Das ist
schon Ich hatte Paraguay, aber es war Peru naja.
Nun gut Also gewonnen hat Blinky,
der irgendwie alle schlägt.
Die besten Geogässer, die können halt die lernen dann halt auch Kyrillisch,
verschiedene Sprachen also die können die nicht sprechen, aber die können die
alle lesen, weil es einfach darum geht schnell,
Hinweisschilder, Straßenschilder etc.
aufzunehmen die kennen Baustile von Häusern, Dachformen, also das ist wirklich
mal nutzloses Wissen, wirklich in Perfektion.
Aber ja, und der eine, der hat da mittlerweile so seine,
Profession draus gemacht, dass er einfach jetzt auch durch die Welt,
also Profession ist eine falsche Bezeichnung, aber der reist jetzt viel,
wird irgendwie wohl auch eingeladen, aber bereist jetzt sozusagen all die Orte,
die er nur vorher irgendwie aus Streetview kannte.
Indien, richtig. Also es ist schon sehr lustig.
Dazu ist mir einer eingefallen, Und zwar, ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle Wordle,
wo man so Mastermind-mäßig ein Wort raten muss. Da gibt es jetzt was Neues, nennt sich Past Puzzle.
Da musst du eine Jahreszahl raten.
Und du kriegst vier Hinweise. Und jedes Mal, bevor du rätst,
bekommst du einen neuen Hinweis.
Und ja, ist ganz nett.
Und manchmal hat man Glück, da rät man auch das Jahrzehnt schon richtig, dann wird es einfacher.
Und der sagt dir halt auch, die Zahl kommt vor, ist aber an der falschen Stelle oder sonst was.
Ja. Wenn man schon an diesen Zeitvertreib muss, dann mache ich es nochmal ganz schnell.
Ich habe vor kurzem meine Liebe von Sudokus wiederentdeckt und es gibt einen
YouTube-Channel, auf dem kann man gut jemanden verfolgen, wie er Sudokus guckt und löst.
Und zwar nicht nur die normalen, sondern die mit allen möglichen Sonderregeln,
wo irgendwie eine Rennbahn passiert.
Das heißt, dass irgendwie alle Zahlen von 1 bis irgendwas auf dieser Zahl sein müssen.
Oder irgendwelche geraden, ungeraden Kombos. Da gibt es ganz viele Zusätze zu
Sudoku, die mir noch unbekannt waren und die haben auch eine iPad-App gemacht,
mit der man das auch so schön markieren kann, wie die das machen.
Die ist auch sehr zu empfehlen und seitdem mache ich wieder Sudokus an der Stelle
oder guckt dem einfach mal eine Stunde oder anderthalb zu. Cracking the Cryptic
ist der YouTube-Channel.
Die haben mehrere Apps.
Show Notes, bitte.
Fast ein Dutzend.
Ja, mache ich gerade. Mache ich gerade, bin ich gerade dabei.
Die haben fast ein Dutzend Videos und die sind vor zwei Jahren oder so ein bisschen
durch die Decke gegangen, weil das sind halt zwei Typen.
Einer sucht immer das Doku raus und der andere darf es lösen.
Also der eine von den beiden löst es dann meistens. Und der eine hatte eins
rausgesucht, wo irgendwie nur zwei Zahlen gegeben waren.
Und Simon, der das gelöst hat, ist dann erst mal wütend geworden.
So, das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Das muss doch ein Joke sein.
Und dann, Und wenn das ein Joke ist, dann werdet ihr das Video nie sehen und
er bekommt einen wütenden Anruf und dann fängt er an und überlegt und überlegt
und eine Zahl nach der anderen trägt er dann ein und zum Schluss löst er das
und ist völlig aus dem Häuschen.
Also ich finde es erstaunlich, wie sehr mich das fesselt, also,
dieses Mitdringen und vielleicht früher auf einen Clou zu kommen,
so ist so mein Thrill-Faktor an der Stelle.
Und so ein-, zweimal habe ich schon ein paar Sachen mal gesehen,
die er dann später erst zieht.
Aber meistens ist es echt hart. Und dann selber machen, in dieser App,
da gibt es ja verschiedene Packs, wo halt diese verschiedenen Arten nochmal,
die Zusatzregeln so noch alle drankommen.
super cool, es dauert halt immer so ein Sudoku, dauert mindestens eine halbe
Stunde bei mir da muss ich Zeit und Ruhe haben, das habe ich im Urlaub angefangen wieder zu machen,
aber ja und die App ist echt super im Sinne von wie man was einträgt und wie
es funktioniert also die ist nicht so, das ist jetzt ein Game wo man jetzt random
irgendwas macht, sondern man kriegt ein paar gute Rätsel,
und die löst man dann auch wirklich sehr traditionell nur mit den eigenen Hinweisen,
kriegt ein paar Tools dazu, die praktisch so diese mathematische Seite ein bisschen
helfen für die Sonderfunktion. Und,
Was ich halt wirklich gut finde, ist so, einfach der Default ist an,
wenn du einen Fehler machst, siehst du es.
Und dann hast du halt so, du strengst dich an, keine Fehler zu machen,
weil du willst das Rätsel so lösen, wie es gedacht war.
Aber wenn da mal eins passiert, dann bist du halt ein bisschen schneller dran.
Das ist trotzdem nicht schlimm.
Also mit so Selbstdisziplin daran arbeiten macht mir viel mehr Spaß als so ein
Doku-Game, wo du gleich irgendwie extern gescored wirst.
Der einzige Kritikpunkt an der App ist ist,
dass sie diese App mit irgendeiner komischen Game-Engine-Technologie gebaut
haben und die relativ viel Strom verbraucht dafür, dass sie eigentlich nichts tut.
Also das fand ich ein bisschen nervig immer.
Aber es ist trotzdem immer noch die beste Sudoku-App, die ich so hatte, von der Bedienung her.
Es gab ja mal ein paar gute andere auch, aber haben sie gut gemacht.
Es gibt von denen mehrere Apps, die meistens sind spezialisiert auf eine bestimmte
Unterkategorie von Sudokus.
Die kann man auch alle, ich hab sie irgendwie alle.
Aber in der Haupt-App gibt es halt dann auch so Packages, die man kaufen kann
und da will ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich alle hab, aber viele.
Und das macht süchtig, weil da gibt es so viele Unterarten, die dieses Konzept
Sudoku nochmal so eine Schraube weiterdrehen, das ist schon sehr geil.
Ist auch sehr abwechslungsreich und auch so das Wissen, dass die Rätsel immer
lösbar wären eigentlich und du halt in diese neue Unterregel so ein bisschen
eindenken musst jeweils.
Also ich mag es gar nicht, wenn sie so super schwer sind. Ich mag es eher so,
wenn man halt so, oh, das ist einfach eine neue Regel.
Ja, ja und dann kombinieren sie die Regeln ja teilweise und so.
Obwohl die ganz harten irgendwo so bei 6, 7 Sterne, da bin ich dann raus.
Also da bin ich dann komplett raus. Ähm.
In dem Zusammenhang, The Talos Principle muss ich nochmal anteasern.
Das ist auch so das geilste Rätselspiel irgendwie ever in den letzten paar Jahren.
Gut, ob man die Story gut findet oder nicht, muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden.
Aber diese Rätsel sind schon sehr, sehr geil.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das durchgespielt habe.
Ich habe es durchgespielt.
Es ist erst mal Zelda dran. Zelda, Zelda, Zelda. Wir müssen Zelda spielen.
Ich sehe keinen Link. Was ist der Link?
Ja, Dom und ich machen ein großes Opfer heute für die Sendung,
dass wir nicht zu Hause schön auf der Couch sitzen und das neue Zelda spielen.
Was heute rausgekommen ist.
Ja.
Zelda.
Ich hab mal eine Stunde reinverdenkt.
Der größte Teil für die Switch. Wo man zum allerersten Mal überhaupt Zelda spielt.
Ach echt? Man muss nicht mehr die Prinzessin retten?
Die Prinzessin selber? Jetzt muss man Link retten und die Prinzessin nimmt das jetzt mal in die Hand.
Ah, echt?
Und es ist halt nicht mehr so 3D, sondern wieder so eine alte 2D.
Kann man denn Zelda spielen, wenn man die anderen Zeldas nicht gespielt hat?
Ja. Ja, kannst du. Also meine Jungs haben sich jetzt sehr tief in die Zelda-Lore
eingearbeitet, die auch wirklich sehr verwirrend, aber das ist ja...
Lore, also so die Spiel Weltgeschichte. So wie das alles, Lore.
Ist das nicht Star Wars, Lore, Backstory?
Lore. L-O-R-E geschrieben.
Um die Geschichte, ja.
Echt nicht?
Also das ist auch jetzt gar kein Hipsterbegriff oder so.
Nö, also ich weiß jetzt gar nicht eine Lore irgendwie. Also was heißt denn das eigentlich?
Lore ist so die Weltgeschichte der Mythos hinter der Welt.
Die Überlieferung, genau.
Die Überlieferung wäre das.
Also bei Herr der Ringe hast du so die drei Bücher, aber dann gibt es ja noch
ganz viel drumrum und wie heißt das?
Simulierikon oder so ähnlich und die Anhänge hinten und das ist alles Lore.
Und bei Zelda Da ist es ganz witzig, weil irgendwie die Geschichte ist ja immer
dieselbe eigentlich bisher gewesen.
Und das wird damit erklärt, dass also irgendwann, ich glaube in Spiel Nummer
drei oder vier sind sie selber auf den Trichter gekommen, okay irgendwie müssen
wir das mal erklären, warum die immer wieder eigentlich so dasselbe Setup haben.
Und das Setup ist immer, man muss die Prinzessin retten.
Man muss die Prinzessin retten, genau. Und wacht im Gefängnis auf und so.
Und das Ganze ist jetzt so erklärt, dass es also ein ewiger Kreislauf von Gut
und Böse ist, der sich also immer wieder selber gebiert und ein großer Fluch
auf ihnen allen lasst. Und sie können quasi gar nicht anders als immer wieder,
dasselbe Grundszenario irgendwie durchleben. Und es gibt nie einen echten Fortschritt.
Und von daher ist jetzt das neue Spiel ganz interessant, weil jetzt zum ersten
Mal gefühlt seit irgendwie 20 Jahren mal ein Perspektivwechsel da reinkommt.
Und vielleicht das ein oder andere mal anders erzählt wird. Ich bin's gespannt.
Es soll ja jetzt eine neue Switch rauskommen, wird gerüchtet. Ist da was dran?
Das wird ja auch schon seit Jahren gerüchtet und so richtig passiert nichts.
Sie haben selber doch letztens, vor der letzten Nintendo Direct haben sie gesagt,
ja, wird kommen, aber wir kündigen sie jetzt noch nicht an.
Das ist so die klarste Aussage von Nintendo dazu.
War so, ja, wir machen eine, aber ihr werdet nichts dazu hören in unserer nächsten Ankündigung. Ja.
Also die Hardware-Specs wurden quasi schon geleakt. Es sieht so aus,
als wäre da ein Nvidia-3D-Chip drin.
Und ich glaube aber,
AMD-CPU. Und ansonsten...
Ja, aber was ändert das?
Schneller? Bessere Grafik?
Soll sie 4K können? Steht das irgendwo bei? Man kann schneller spielen. Flüssiger.
Mehr Rechenleistung heißt mehr gut.
Ich glaube, sie machen eine boring...
Was denn mehr gut?
Sie machen eine boring Geschichte an der Stelle. Sie machen einfach einen,
mehr oder weniger Speedbump, ein bisschen von dem Ding, ein bisschen Refinement
und haben halt ein Spiel dazu.
Also sieht es dann besser aus oder was?
Ja, ich glaube, diesmal machen sie es wirklich so rum.
Detaillierter, du kannst weiter gucken. Die Texturen sehen plötzlich realistischer
aus, nicht alles so matschig.
Die machen es immer noch in der Hardware, die wirklich günstig zu produzieren ist.
Die machen weiter auf die Gewinncharge, aber auch nicht sowas wie bei der Wii
U damals, wo sie so einen Griff ins Klo gemacht haben mit, wir machen ein ganz
absurdes neues Feature an der Stelle.
Also ich glaube, das wird ein ganz konservatives, wird an einem Spiel gebunden
sein. Wenn das Spiel fertig ist, dann bringen sie die Konsole raus.
Fertig. Das reiten sie jetzt nochmal ein Jahr. Also eine Generation.
Ein Jahr ist übertrieben, weil die Switches, wie lange gibt es die schon?
Die gibt es schon seit ewig. Seit Amerika.
Ich habe die von Amerika mitgebracht. Ja, stimmt. Über 5, 6, 7 Jahre. Krass.
War aber doch einfach ein gutes Konzept und meine Jungs wissen immer noch nicht,
dass man die in der Hand halten kann.
Habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt. Aber ich will halt Medienzeit kontrollieren.
Das heißt also die ist wirklich fest verbaut halt in dieses Case am Fernseher
und wenn dann der Fernseher aus ist, dann kann man auch mit der Switch nichts
mehr machen. Also, dass man die da rausnehmen und in der Hand halten kann.
Irgendwann wird der Stunt auffliegen, wenn in der Schule plötzlich mal einer
damit rumläuft und sieht, Papa, was ist das da?
Wir werden sehen.
Ne, meine Jungs wissen das, die benutzen die auch.
Sieben Jahre ist sie alt, ja, Tatsache. Aber bringt nicht Nintendo alle zehn
Jahre was raus irgendwie?
Naja, dann haben sie ja noch drei.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das so zehn Jahre?
Keine Ahnung, also sie werden auch noch drei brauchen.
Früher gab es mal relativ klare Zyklen bei Konsolen.
Der 5-Jahres-Schweine-Zyklus, wie man ihn nannte.
Aber die Zeiten sind...
Sie haben, glaube ich, auch No Need einfach an der Stelle. Weil die tut, was es soll.
Die spielt, wie es soll. Die ist ein bisschen schwachbrustig,
aber das ist jetzt nicht... Sie haben keinen harten Need dafür.
Da geht genug kaputt, was man ausbessern muss, dass Leute noch nachkaufen.
Und sowas wie Tears of Kinddom...
Tears of Kingdom sieht auch einfach fantastisch aus. Spielt sich super, sieht super aus.
So klar hätte man das gerne in
4K, aber so viel Unterschied würde es dann glaube ich auch nicht machen.
Der hat immer so wenig Zeit, ne? Aber dann sitzt er hier und erzählt wie er
stundenlang durch irgendwelche Abenteuerlandschaften laufen ist.
Meine Jungs laufen da.
Ja, ja, du kennst ja jedes Detail.
Naja.
Du guckst nur stundenlang zu, während du wichtige Sachen machst.
Naja, gut. Okay, gut. Ihr spielt spielig.
Die guten Nintendo-Spiele muss man einfach spielen.
Ja, ich spiel Mario Kart.
Ja, ist wichtig. Auch gut. Das habe ich letztes Mal wieder gemacht.
Endlich habe ich die ganzen Download-Strecken gespielt.
Die neun. Die sind gut.
Hier übrigens, The Talos Principle 2. Das ist das Spiel, von dem ich sprach.
Ach, das ist der zweite Teil?
Den gibt es nur auf Windows.
Aber das ist richtig geil.
Den ersten fand ich so lala.
Ja, den ersten finde ich auch nur so lala. Aber der zweite ist geil.
Vor allen Dingen gibt es nicht mehr diese dämlichen Selbstschussanlagen und
Roboter, die einen wegbritzeln wollen, sondern man kann sich ganz in Ruhe auf
die Lösung von einem Rätsel,
konzentrieren, ohne dass einem jemand irgendwie ans Messer will.
Ist es super krasse Grafik oder meinst du, dass er mit dem Game Dev Toolkit geht?
Das ist super krasse Grafik, aber es könnte mit dem Game Dev Kit funktionieren.
Ich glaube, es ist Unreal Engine 5 oder so. Das sieht schon extrem gut aus.
Und wenn man erstmal in der Megastructure ist, dann muss man schwindelfrei sein.
Sage ich jetzt schon mal dazu.
Also ich fand die Ansätze vom ersten gut genug. Dann muss ich jetzt doch wieder
mehr spielen. Aber erstmal Zelda. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es dauert.
Ein paar Tage.
So Leute, ich denke, wir machen jetzt hier mal Klappe zu. Affe tot.
Wir haben unsere vorgeschriebenen vier Stunden erreicht. Ralf muss wieder nach
Hause, der ist müde, der muss noch Zelda spielen.
Planerfüllung ist gelungen.
Nächstes Mal habe ich ein sehr schönes KI-Thema, da könnt ihr euch schon drauf
freuen. Das wird zum Mitdenken und Mitfiebern.
Vielleicht ist bis dahin ja auch schon Apple Intelligence genießt worden.
Ich habe mich nämlich mal wieder mit Max gestritten.
Oh, ist ja nicht so leicht.
Und da kommen dann ja aber doch ganz lustige Sachen raus. Und da haben wir die
eine oder andere Erkenntnis mal rausgezogen.
Alright. Ich sag, wir machen jetzt hier mal Abgang.
Tom, vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein.
Ja gerne, hat mich gefreut, dass es mal wieder geklappt hat.
Genau, schön hier remote. Rudi, Ralf und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei der Freakshow,
beim Mitschatten, Shownotes machen und all diese ganzen Dinge, die ihr immer macht.
Und das war's jetzt erstmal wieder. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss. Ciao.
Bis dann.
Servus.